HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE. ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY'S OF COURSE OUR
EARLY HAD A HEARING WILL HEAR
FROM SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AS WELL JUST GET UP
LATE ONLY AS FAR AS WHERE WE'RE
AT WITH. EARLY LEARNING IN
CALIFORNIA ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS A
STATE OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION RECOVERY WE HAVE
PROMISES A SERVICES L. A. L.
NDSS. SO WE'LL START WITH THEM
THIS PANEL. KIM JOHNSON. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CHAIR GOOD MORNING
AS CHAIR AND MEMBERS KIM JOHNSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES GLAD TO BE
WITH YOU THIS MORNING I WANTED
TO START BY THANKING THIS BODY
AFTER DISSIPATING MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND SOME OF
TODAY'S CATALYST THAT YOU'RE
HEARING FOR THE LEADERSHIP BRING
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO DEVELOP
THE ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE INCORPORATED INTO THE
MASTER PLAN KERR LEARNING CARE
IN BOTH THE COURTS IN FRANCE
WITH UTILIZED. TO INFORM THE
HISTORIC AND UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND THE WORK
FORCE OF SOCIAL SERVICES HAVE
PRIVILEGE TO ADMINISTER WITH THE
TRANSITION OF CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THESE PLANS
CONTINUE TO FACILITATE AND TO
PROVIDE A ROAD MAP YEAH THE
LANDSCAPE CONTINUES TO CHANGE
AND OBVIOUSLY AS YOUR AGENDA
POINTS OUT THIS MORNING ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN
THE LANDSCAPE WAS CREATED BY THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND I
WANT TO. DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
MEMBERS OF THE CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT- LEARNING WORKFORCE
WHO KEPT THEIR DOORS OPEN TO
SUPPORT CLOSE THE CENTRAL
WORKERS INVOLVED FAMILIES
CONTINUE TO TAKE THE STEPS
NEEDED AT TO KEEP THE CHILDREN
HEALTHY AND SAFE TO KEEP
THEMSELVES HEALTHY AND SAFE. AND
THEIR OWN FAMILIES. YOUR CHEN
THAT OUR YOUR THE PANDEMIC WE
MAY. INCLUDING THINGS LIKE.
RELEASE START FOR THE WAY FORCE
THE WHOLE FOR. RELATED TO
CHILDREN'S. DECEMBER OF PERSONAL
FOR. EQUIPMENT AND TESTING KITS
AND MORE PREVENTED THE PERMANENT
LOSS OF SOME OF THE CHILD CARE
CAPACITY IN THE ANSWER IS YES.
THESE INVESTMENTS WERE DESIGNED
TO DO JUST THAT IT IS TRUE THAT
WE HAVE LOST PROGRAMS AND
CAPACITY AND HAVE WORK TO DO TO
REBUILD AND EXPAND ACCESS.
YOU'LL HEAR MORE FROM OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR I NEED MY LOOK AND
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR CHANG
WAS SECOND WORK UPDATE THAT. AND
THE RESOURCE INTERVENTIONS ON
THIS FRONT. BUT I WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT THE CHEAP LANDSCAPES
CHANGING WITH OUR STRENGTHENED
AND IMPROVED OUR PARTNERSHIP.
WITH THE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED. IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNED ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
AUTHORIZES FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO JOIN FORMULATED
PARTICIPATING ACTIVITIES THAT
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS. AND TO
SEEK THE CERTIFICATION OF A
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS THE CPU
NAP TODAY. AND WE ENTER INTO THE
FIRST MADE AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED IN
JUNE OF LAST YEAR. REPRESENTING
A HISTORIC INVESTMENT IN THE
FIELD AT SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. IN THE BUDGET.
YEAR WE ALSO HAVE. A LANES
LANDSCAPE WITH A GREAT- WHY. I
WOULD THE FEDERAL MINISTER AND
OF HOW. INVESTMENTS THIS. AND
THAT HAS CERTAINLY AND ARM
ABILITY TO MAKE GREAT STRIDES ON
THE RECORD. OF THE RIBBON
COMMITTEE RECORD MASTER LANNED.
INCREASED TO CHILD CARE SUBSIDY
. PROVIDING YOUR UNIVERSAL
ACCESS THE STATE FUNDED
PRESCHOOL FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS. AND INCREASED ACCESS OUT
FOR THREE YEAR OLDS. THAT
INCREASED RATES ARE IN OUR RATE
WORK AS WELL AS DEVELOPING OUR
WORK TO DEVELOP A UNIFIED RATE
STRUCTURE THAT WE ARE DOING NOW.
INFRASTRUCTURE NOT ONLY ON THE
CAPITAL SIDE ACTUAL BRICKS AND
MORTAR OF PROGRAMS. BUT ALSO ON
THE DATA INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE TARGETING TARGETING
DISINVESTMENT STRATEGICALLY. AND
OF COURSE FOR OUR ABILITY TO
RECRUIT RETAIN AND PROVIDE
UPWARD MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES
AND CAREER PATHWAYS FOR THE WORK
FORCE. SO AS WE LOOK AHEAD WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO BUILD ON THE
LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED AFTER
THE PANDEMIC AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE FULLY OPERATIONALIZE AND NOT
ALL THE INVESTMENTS. I WITH THE
MAIN AGREEMENT WITH YOU SEE CAN
YOU BUT ALSO AS AGREED UPON
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE THAT
EXTRACTION. FURTHER OUR WORK
TOGETHER ON THE MASTER PLAN AND
REALLY LOOKING AT UNIFYING AND
STRENGTHENING OUR PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO SUPPORT CHILDREN'S
LEARNING. THAT RELATES TO THE
CHILD CARE TRENDS OF THE- THOSE
SERVICES IS NOT ONLY. WERE
TOWARD IT HE- AB TOWARD
STRENGTHENING LINE. WITH OUR OWN
. AND STUFF THIS POVERTY SUCH AS
HOW AND HOW. FOOD SUPPORTS.
EARLY INTERVENTION AND MORE
VISITING. ABBOTT ALSO ACROSS THE
PARK HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WITH EARLY INTERVENTION.
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
MORE WHAT WE'RE INVESTING IN
THOSE SPACES WE ALSO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
FURTHERING AND STRENGTHENING OUR
COLLABORATION WITH BOTH
PRESCHOOL AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN ON THAT FRONT. AND
FINALLY I JUST AND AGAIN WITH
WORKFORCE OBVIOUSLY THIS IS ARE
THE- BEST AND GREATEST GIFT. WE
CAN GIVE TO OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS AND CHILDREN IT'S
EIGHT. ALCOHOL CITING
INCOMPETENCE- WE ARE RUNNING AT
SHAKYA PROFESSIONAL AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING IN THE SPACE WE HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO. TO MEET OUR
GOALS BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
DOING THAT TOGETHER AND WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER. TO YOU
OUR TEAM AT SOCIAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SERICA.
GOOD MORNING THERE CORTES
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
ARE ASKED TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S CHILD
CARE SPECIFIC PANDEMIC ACTIONS-
AND TOTAL FEDERAL FUNDS PROVIDED
I'M STARTING ON PAGE THREE OF
YOUR AGENDA SHOWS THE TABLE THAT
SUMMARIZES THE STATE'S PANDEMIC
ACTIONS I'M SPECIFICALLY FOR
CHILD CARE WHICH INCLUDE A
NUMBER OF POLICIES SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL PUNCTURE SLOTS FOR
CENTRAL WORKERS POLICIES THAT
ALLOW FOR PAYMENT FLEXIBILITY
STIPENDS FOR CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
ABOUT THE TABLE ON YOUR AGENDA
SHOWS A MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE
LIST OF THESE POLICIES. WITH
REGARD TO FEDERAL FUNDS ROUGHLY
FIVE BILLION WITH PROVIDED FOR-
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SPECIFICALLY FOR CHILD CARE AND
THE FUNDS WERE PROVIDED ACROSS
THREE FEDERAL ALREADY FILLED IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE CALENDAR YEARS- BUT THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT I'M
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AT THEAPPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
BACK TO EARTH PARCEL SERVICES.
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU AGAIN I'M
A LITTLE BEHIND IN MY LAND AND I
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CHAPTER DEVELOPMENT DIVISION.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN DIRECTOR
JOHNSON FOR THE INTRODUCTION AND
IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE AND ADDRESS QUESTIONS. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE FIELD AT
ALL THE PARTNERS FOR THE
COLLABORATION DURING THESE
DIFFICULT. PRESIDENT TIMES. AS
REFERENCED BY THE L. A. L.
OFFICE AND ALL THE PANDEMIC
RELATED AND HEALTHCARE LEAF
INVESTMENTS ARE FOCUSED ON
STABILISATION STABILISING WHICH
HEALTHCARE INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
SERVE FAMILIES AND THEIR
CHILDREN. CCGT IS A FULL
IMPLEMENTATION MODE AND AS
MODERATE AT ALL THE INVESTMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE. ALL THE SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE STIPENDS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED BUT TODAY PAYMENT
PROGRAMS. ISSUED THE STATEMENTS
DIRECTLY TO THE FIELD. ALSO
PRICES HAVE BEEN SENT TO THE
FIELD REGARDING ACCESSIBILITY TO
CLARIFY ANY QUESTIONS AND
PROVIDE DIRECTION. FOR THE
FIRST. AB FOR THE FIRST ISSUE
KAREN CHANG ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMMUNICATOR
LICENSING. AND I WILL BE
ADDRESSING THE QUESTIONS ON THE
AGENT THAT THE DIRECTOR JOHNSON
AND CHIEF DEPUTY TROY YEAH WILL
ALSO JOIN US IN ANSWERING ANY
FURTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
LET ME TURN IT OVER. TO- ERIN TO
SPEAK TO FIRST QUESTION REGARDS
TO DATA AND BE ON THE- MATT DR.
I MADE MY LAMB AND THANK YOU THE
CHAIR AND MEMBER FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU OUT
TODAY MY NAME IS KAREN CHANG AND
I'M THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING. ARE LOOKING SINCE
CHILD CARE FACILITY
STABILIZATION STIPENDS ARE
FUNDED THROUGH THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE KNOWN AS OUR BEST. THESE
LICENSE BY BANDS RANGE FROM
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
ALL NIGHTS BEEN SEIZED. I'M WHO
ARE LICENSED ON JUNE TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
LICENSE DISTRIBUTION THE LICENSE
TYPE AND DISTRIBUTION IS GOING
VERY WELL WITH THREE QUARTERS OF
ELIGIBLE LICENSEES IN RECEIPT OF
HER P. MEANT. AND COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING DOING TARGETED
OUTREACH TO ANY AND REGISTERED
PROVIDERS THROUGH CONTACTS MADE
BY CCL TO THE LICENSEE AND A
DIFFERENT TACK OUTREACH EFFORTS
THAT INCLUDE OUTREACH BY EMAIL
PHONE SOCIAL MEDIA. AND DIRECT
MAILERS. TO THE LICENSEES ACT.
IN ADDITION TO THE LICENSE BEN'S
STADIUM IS ALSO LEADING EFFORT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL AGENCIES STATEWIDE
AND WANT TO EXPRESS MY DEEP
GRATITUDE. FOR THEIR SUPPORT
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND HELPING
US TO DISTRICT PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. THE CHILD
CARE COMMUNITY. CDS CONDUCTS THE
QUARTERLY SURVEY AND THEN A
QUARTERLY DISTRIBUTION THE STOCK
. AND THE SURPRISE OVER THE PAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS HAVE INCLUDED
ADULT SURGICAL MASK CHILD MASS.
HEY GUYS ARE BASED. NOT LATEX
LAB THERMOMETERS DOWN AND THEN
IN RESPONSE DIPLOMA CRIME IN
JANUARY CBSSN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR IN OUR AGENCIES DISTRIBUTED
MORE THAN EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION PIECES THAT PDP HAD OF
OUR QUARTERLY SCHEDULE. AND IN
THIS SEGMENT WE ALSO INCLUDED
AND NINETY FIVE MASS WHICH WERE
REALLY CRITICAL TO REDUCE THE
SPREAD. OUT KOPET DURING.
FEBRUARY OUTBREAK. WE ALSO SHIP
TO HER THOUSAND AT HOME KOBE TO
TAX. ARE ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
CDPH IFTY THERE ARE MORE CAST
AND DISTRIBUTE TO THE FIELD IS
AN IMPORTANT INFECTION CONTROL
MEASURE TO HELP CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS REMAIN OPEN. AND
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS
TO REMAIN SAFE. I'M GOING TO
TRANSITION BACK TO THE DOCTOR.
THANK YOU THANKS ZERO SO AS
ABSENT TO ADD TO THEN ASK
REFERENCE BY THE L. A. O. THE
ADDITIONAL PANDEMIC RELIEF
INVESTMENTS ADMINISTRATIVE FOR
THE CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION OF CDSS INCLUDES
SEVERAL OTHER FORMS OF RELIEF
RANGING FROM ADDITIONAL STIPENDS
TO BELCHER SLOTS OR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THE HOLD HARMLESS POLICY
TO PAPER AUTHORIZED OTHER HOURS
THE CARE THE WEEK OR A FAMILY
FEES AND ADDITIONAL PAID NON
OPERATIONAL DAYS ALTHOUGH WE'RE
NOT MONITORING SPECIFIC DATA
POINTS REGARDING THE DIRECT
EFFECT. AT THESE PANDEMIC
MEASURES AT THIS TIME WE DO NOW
AND IT TOTALLY WHAT A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES THIS
INVESTMENTS HAVE MADE ON THE
GROUND FOR FAMILIES CHILDREN AND
THE CHILD CARE WORKFORCE AS WELL
AS CHECK FOR BUSINESSES HE'S THE
BEST MAN SUPPORT DESIGNED TO
RESPOND TO MANY OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS THAT WE
HEARD FROM THE FIELD DURING THE
TIME. OF THIS CRISIS. HELP NEXT
GOING TO THE NECK QUESTION- THAT
TALK ABOUT FLEXIBLE AND
STABILISED BECAUSE- FOR THE
CURRENT TIME HERE. AND SO THE
ADMIN. CONTINUES TO MONITOR AND
RECEIVE FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS ON FLEXIBILITY AND
STABILIZATION POLICIES FROM THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATOR AND WE AT IN REGARDS
TO THIS PARTICULAR QUESTION. SO
THE NEXT QUESTION SPEAKS IN
REGARDS TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
PATTERNS THAT PERMANENT CLOSURES
THAT THE STATE SHOULD ADDRESS
AND I'M GOING TO TRADE OVER TO
KAREN TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO
PASS. EIGHT ZERO. THE TRENDS IN
CONTACTS THAT THE PREVIOUS YEAR
OUR THAT WE HAD AN AVERAGE OF
FORTY THREE HUNDRED FACILITIES
WITH THE CAPACITY TO SERVE SIXTY
NINE THOUSAND CHILDREN NEWLY
ADDED CHILDREN AN AVERAGE OF
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED FACILITIES
WITH THAT CASSIDY TO THERAPY
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND CHILDREN
PERMANENTLY CLOSED AND BY THE
END OF TWENTY NINETEEN OVER ON
THE NUMBER OF FACILITIES
INCREASED BY EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FACILITIES. AND THE TOTAL
CAPACITY BY FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
SLOTS SO THIS WOULD BE RIGHT
BEFORE WE'RE HEADING INTO THE
PANDEMIC. BETWEEN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THERE WAS A
SLIGHT DECREASE POINT 7% IN THE
NUMBER OF TOTAL LENGTH AND
FACILITIES 240-200-0800 WHICH IS
PASSED THAT BY S. LIKE INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF CHILD CARE
SLOTS WHICH WAS AFTER FIVE POINT
3% TO ONE POINT ONE MILLION
SLACKS WITHIN OUR LICENSE CHILD
CARE STRUCTURE. HOWEVER AS A
RESULT OF THIS PANDEMIC AND
NUMBER OF CHILD CARE LICENSE
FACILITIES HAVE EXPERIENCE
PERIODIC TEMPORARY CLOSURES. AS
OF DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE NUMBER OF OPEN AND OPERATING
FACILITIES WAS CLOSER TO THIRTY
SIX HOURS THAN. WHAT THE
CAPACITY TO SERVE NEARLY NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN. THE
TEMPORARY CLOSURES HAVE AFFECTED
STATEWIDE CAPACITY BUT IT IS NOT
CLEAR YET. HOW MANY WILL REMAIN
. THERE WILL BE OPEN BURKE WILL
PERMANENTLY CLOSE THE DEPARTMENT
IS CURRENTLY USING SELF REPORTED
DATA AT A POINT IN TIME WHICH
MAKES DATA ACCURACY MORE
DIFFICULT. THE COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING DIVISION RECENTLY
BEGAN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE THE
ACCURACY OF THE TEMPORARY
CLOSURE DATA. AND IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE BEGAN
REACHING OUT TO THESE FACILITIES
AND ASKING ABOUT THEIR CURRENT
OPERATIONAL STATUS IDENTIFYING
PRIMARY REASONS FOR CONTINUED
CLOSURE IDENTIFYING THE
LICENSEES NEXT STEPS. I AM
SEEING THEIR TECHNO AS THE-
CONNECTION TO RESOURCES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN PROVIDE TO HELP
FACILITIES WE OPEN. THE SURVEY
RESULTS ARE EXPECTED IN SPRING
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IN
ADDITION TO THAT EFFORT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC WE
ALSO IMPLEMENTED OUR WAIVER TO
HELP INCREASE LICENSE CAPACITY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. CDS ASSET
SUCCESSFULLY LAUNCHED A POP UP
WEAKER PER PROGRAM TO HELP THE
LICENSED CHILDCARE PROVIDERS.
TEMPORARILY EXPAND THEIR
CAPACITY AND TO ALLOW UNLICENSED
CHILD CARE FACILITIES TO OPEN
TEMPORARILY. THIS RESULTED IN
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
LICENSED CHILD CARE SLOTS. THIS
CONTINUES TO BE AN OPERATION
TODAY BUT SINCE ITS INCEPTION
EIGHTEEN POP UP. CENTERS HAVE
BECOME LICENSE. FREE TRIAL CARE
PROPER IN THE CHILD CARE HOMES
BECOME LICENSE AND I WONDERED IF
FIFTY NINE LICENSE CARE
PROVIDERS EXPANDED THEIR
CAPACITY THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GOING TO
HAND IT BACK TO THE DOCTOR HI MY
NAME MIKE LEAVITT. THANK YOU
THIS CONCLUDES OUR RESPONSES TO
THE QUESTIONS IN THE EXTENT THAT
WERE OPEN TO ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU WELCOME BACK TO YOU WE
HAVE A PANEL NOW- SOME. SOME
FOLKS FROM THE FILD. TO TALK
ABOUT- EARLY ED. IN THIS
RECOVERY SO REMIND- THAT WE'RE
GIVING EACH PANELIST NO MORE
THAN THREE MINUTES- WE HAVE A
LOT TO GET THROUGH- SO WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH THE
REPRESENTED FROM CRYSTAL STAIRS
. THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- THIS IS JUST LIKE
WE DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL STAIRS
IN THE EASY COALITION I WANT TO
START OFF BY REFLECTING ON THE
CRISIS IN THE CHILDCARE INDUSTRY
AND HOW THE PANDEMIC SEVERELY
IMPACT. BILL BEFORE I BEGIN I
BUT I'M NOT I WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO ELEVATE HOUSE CENTRAL
RATE INCREASES ARE TO THIS
CONVERSATION PER CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. HOW DIRE THE NEED FOR
SUPPLIES ARE AS WELL THIS IS
REALLY ADDRESSED THE LACK OF
FUNDING AND- LACK OF
ACCESSIBILITY AND CHILDCARE SHE
- AND- RELIEF WITH HELP TO
PROVIDE. WHEN WE- GOT IT HOWEVER
IT WAS OFTEN VERY DELAY IN THAT
**** TACK MEET PRACTICE NEEDS.
THIS WAS A SPECIAL TRUE MORE. IN
THE OLD RECALL WADE WITH THE
LACK OF OUR PREPARATION SUPPLIES
FOR TESTING HIGH QUALITY. WE'VE
HEARD THE ENDEMIC FROM MANY
PROVIDE. IN THE CREW C. R. THERE
AREA THAT THEY HAVE OFTEN. NOT
HAD. THE PERSON CHECK EQUIPMENT
YES TO PROTECT THEMSELVES OR
THEIR CHILDREN FAMILIES THEY
SERVE. AS A RESULT MANY HAVE HAD
CLOSED- SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
CAPACITY CRYSTAL'S THEIR AT- IN
THE COMMUNITY. IN HOME TESTING
KITS AND KEEP THE SUPPLY ROUTE
ENDEMIC MOST RECENTLY WHEN THE
OVERCOME BARRIERS RAN RAMPANT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES MANY PROVIDERS
GAVE TESTIMONY THAT IF THEY DID
NOT RECEIVE THE RESOURCES WE
WERE ABLE TO QUICKLY PIVOT
INDUSTRY OUT TO THEM. MANY OF
THEM WOULD HAVE THE CLOTHES IN
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT PREPARED
AND LET'S NOT FORGET BACK
DECEMBER WHEN THERE WAS A NATION
WIDE LACK OF ACCESSIBILITY
TESTING KITS HOWEVER OUR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WERE EXPECTED TO
KEEP PROPER OPERATING IT DID NOT
HAVE THE ACCESSIBILITY TO THESE
RESOURCE. SO THE LAST HOUR WE
ABSOLUTELY CANNOT BE REACTIVE
FUNDING FOR PROVIDING
ACCESSIBILITY TO THE FIVE
PROVIDERS. WE MUST BE PROACTIVE
. WITH TO THE RELY MAN. INSULTS
WITH THING SO THIS MANAGE. GIVE
ME BACK REMAIN THAT THE PANDEMIC
IS NOT A- ONLY NINETEEN. TO
DISPLAY. IMPACT COMMUNITIES UP.
INCLUDING ARE A PEOPLE. WHILE
SOME BUYERS ARE ABLE TO REMAIN
OPEN OTHERS. ABLE TO REBOUND
FROM A TEMPORARY CLOSURE DURING
THE HEIGHT OF ENDEMIC ROUGHLY
25235% OF CRYSTAL SPHERE SPREE
KOBE PROVIDERS. REMAIN
PERMANENTLY CLOSED TODAY. CHAU
PROVIDERS STRUGGLING WITH THESE
CALLS OF EVERYTHING YOU'RE TO DO
THEIR WORK YOU CAN COLLATION
BIRTH CENTER IN FAMILY CHILD
PROVIDERS WITH THE SYSTEM THEY
WERE- THEY HAVE VERY FEW WORKERS
AVAILABLE- BECAUSE OF THE- THEY
ARE ABLE TO PAY. I SPOKE LAST
WEEK SPENT ON ANOTHER WHERE WE
TALK ABOUT HOW- A PROVIDER HAS
BEEN LOOKING FOR AT THIS INSTANT
NEED TWENTY TWENTY AND STILL HAS
NOT BY WHAT SHE'S PLANNING ON
LEAVING THE INDUSTRY AT THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS IS
THE REALITY FALLS OFF AND
THEY'RE COMPETING WITH HIGHER
WAGES BETTER BENEFITS AND HIRING
BONUSES THE RATE INCREASES
IMPLEMENTED ON JANUARY FIRST
WE'RE NOT ENOUGH TO COME CLOSE
THE KEEPING UP WITH THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS ALONE- LET'S
DISCUSS. IT AS A RECENT ANALYSIS
BY THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET POLICY
CENTER SHOWED THAT THE RATE
INCREASES IN THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR CHILDCARE SMITH
SERVING INFANTS AND TODDLERS IN
THIRTY FOUR COUNTIES THEY SAW IT
MICROCENTER LEFT INCREASE. AND
ONE OF THOSE PROVIDERS IN TWENTY
TWO COUNTIES RECEIVED. ZERO
INCREASE. AT CENTERS SERVE
PRESCHOOL AGE THIRTY EIGHT.
RECEIVED A 5% OR LESS INCREASE.
AND PROVIDERS AND EIGHT SIGN IN
. UP ZERO- 0% SIX ME. CHAPTER
EIGHT THAT NEED IN THE BUT STILL
AT THIRTEEN. FOR INSTANCE IT'S-
IT COUNTY- PRIEST WERE INCREASE
THEY RECEIVED WAS LESS THAN 5%
RIGHT. EIGHTEEN TO SEE PROVIDERS
THEIR DOOR IN OUR BELOW CAPACITY
THE WORK FORSURE. THIS IS NOT
THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST A
THE PRICE YOU NEED CHAU CARE-
PRIVATE COMMUNITY IN- BUT IN OUR
STATE FUNDED PRE PROGRAM.
SCHOOL- GENERAL CHILDCARE AND
FEDERAL FUNDED HEAD START.
PROVIDES COMPETING READ THAN PAR
WITH IS THAT BEEN THEY HAVE BEEN
VERY U. S. TO PARTNER LEVERAGE
BROWN RECENTLY CHILDREN IN QUITE
FRANKLY MANY ARE THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE A TO REFER OLD- LET'S BE
CLEAR. I DON'T THINK CAN MEET.
TO KEEP EACH WE NEED TO WE NEED
COMFORT AND NO THAT. PROVIDE ARE
ARE CONSIDERED SPRINT AND SEND
WORKER. AND HAVE ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY WITH. THE FIVE TO KEEP
CERTAIN SERVING OUR CHILDREN
EVERY DAY. WE HAVE HAD TO COME
TO THE LETTER. TO RUN YOU ALL
OUT OUT. PROVIDE WERE INSTEAD
REMAIN THE BACKBONE CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY BIRTH WITH THE SPECS
THEY BLACK. BILL REQUIRES BUT.
ALSO RIGHT IN THE ASSISTANCE
DURING POST OF REVENUE CALL BY
REDUCING IN THE- IN THE- IN A-
OUR- AND THAT'S NOT GOOD LET'S
CONSIDER THE MOST AWAITED. ME I
HAVE ALL WAIT ON. THE CALL BEAST
MODE. WORRIES OVER NOT HAVING
THE SUPPLIES NECESSARY TO REMAIN
OPEN. PROVIDERS ALSO NEED THE
MOST NO WELLNESS. A PLACE TO
CONNECT OTHER. IN SIMILAR.
BECAUSE IT'S THAT. LONG OR IT.
I'LL LET YOU CONCLUDE THAT WE
MUST TAKE EAT- THE SIGNATURE.
INCREASE THE REAR RATE PER ARCH
CARE. WE CANNOT WAIT FOR PROCESS
CAN WE- WAIT ON THE COAST. AFTER
THAT. THERE IS A CRY IN FOR
EARLY THE PRO. PROFESSED NOW AS
I BEAT. ANY NEED. USING UP FRONT
. ACROSS THE BOARD RATE INCREASE
IS MUCH BE AT. THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF. ARE YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NXP WILL BE LAKE JUST THREE
TO PANELISTS TO KEEP IT THREE
MINUTES OR LESS- WELL ROBBINS A
UP- WE WERE TO- TO THE ROLE IN
WELCOME MARK ARE. NEW MEMBERS
THE CAN- REPLACING- SOME MEMBERS
MY ENTIRE AND GET- SOMEONE CHOI
. AND MEMBER WILD THERE THE-
MEMBERS OF THE KEY- FOR THE
RIVER SIDE SO I THANK YOU AND
WELCOME PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
MCCARTY HERE. CHOI YEAH. PLEASE
MEDINA. WHAT DONALD. PRESS HERE
WALDRON YEAH OKAY THANK YOU
ROBIN LAYTON. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I AM
ROBIN LAYTON PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF EDUCATIONAL RICHMOND SYSTEMS
AND NONPROFIT CENTER BASED TITLE
FIVE DIRECT SERVICE CONTRACTOR
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. IT'S BEEN A
REALLY REALLY CHALLENGING TWO
YEARS AND THREE MINUTES IS
DEFINITELY NOT ENOUGH BUT I WILL
DO MY BEST I JUST WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE ENTIRE FIELD OF
EARLY EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE
WORKERS. IF COME TO WORK EVERY
DAY SINCE MARCH SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY THE FIRST DAY THAT THIS
HORRIFIC PANDEMIC SHUT DOWN
EVERYTHING ELSE. SINCE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY MY TEAM HAS BEEN
TAKING CALLS AT ALL HOURS OF THE
NIGHT AND DAY INCLUDING WEEKENDS
FOR PARENTS WHO CALL AND SAY
THEIR CHILD TESTED POSITIVE FOR
OR FROM PARENTS THAT COLIN SAY
THEY ARE A CLOSE CONTACT
INFORMATION PLOYS WHO DON'T HAVE
CHILD CARE BECAUSE THEIR CHILD
CARE. CENTER CLOSE OR FROM
EMPLOYEES WHO TESTED POSITIVE OR
BECAUSE THEIR OWN CHILDREN
TESTED POSITIVE SO I JUST REALLY
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO MY
TEAM FOR TAKING THIS CALLS AND
THEN DOING THE CONTACT TRACING.
TO DETERMINE WHICH SCHOOLS HAVE
TO PIVOT TO DEARTH DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND FOR HOW LONG AND
HOW TRAGIC IT IS AND ALWAYS THE
FIRST QUESTION IS ARE THE
CHILDREN OKAY AND IS THE TEAM
OKAY. OUR WORK FOR CITY AT EDS
IS MADE UP OF TWO HUNDRED
AMAZING AND DEDICATED HUMANS
THEY LEAVE THEIR HOME EVERY DAY
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND PUT THEIR
LIFE ON THE LINE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION MUST
RECOGNIZE THEM THANK THEM AND
SUPPORT THEM WITH A PROFESSIONAL
WAIT. FOR FORTY THREE YEARS EDS
HAS BEEN SERVING OUR COMMUNITY
IN TWENTY TWO EARLY EDUCATION
CENTERS WE SERVE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED ESSENTIAL WORKER
FAMILIES THEIR INFANTS TODDLERS
THREE YEAR OLD AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS IN PRESCHOOL. WE ARE HIGHLY
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- MANDATE ARE
RESEARCH BASED CURRICULUM. THE
STUDENT TEACHER RATIOS AND
TEACHER QUALIFICATIONS IN
ADDITION TO THE QUALITY EARLY
EDUCATION AND EXPERIENCE THAT
OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
RECEIVED WE ALSO PROVIDE CHILD
CARE THE CHILD CARE PORTION OF
OUR PROGRAM SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL WORKER
FAMILIES. ARE FAMILIES WORK IT
LOOKS THEY WORK IN THE HOSPITALS
THEY WORK AT IT NOW SO LONG AND
THE GROCERY STORE THERE YOUR
DOCTOR IN YOUR NURSE. I
PERSONALLY RESPECT AND SUPPORT
THESE REGULATIONS IN OUR TITLE
FIVE PROGRAMS I WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS IF I HAD NOT. IMAGINED
TESTIFYING LIKE THIS FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS. COMING TO
SACRAMENTO AND SPEAKING HERE AS
BEEN MOST. OVER THE- WHAT I
HEARD AND WHAT I HEAR IT YEAR.
IT IS THAT THERE IS NO MONEY WE
RESPECT WHAT YOU DO AND THANK
YOU FOR SHARING. THANK YOU FOR
BEING OPEN TO SERVE THE FAMILIES
DURING COLD FOOD WHEN DISTRICTS
WERE CLOSED. AND IMAGINE HOW THE
TEACHERS IN MY PROGRAM FELT WHEN
OUR OWN GOVERNOR CAME TO VISIT
AND DISCUSSED WITH THEM HOW HE
THOUGHT THEY NEEDED A
PROFESSIONAL WEIGHTS BECAUSE
THEY ARE EDUCATING AND CARING.
FOR THE YOUNGEST LEARNERS IN OUR
STATE AND YES THIS INCLUDES FOUR
YEAR OLD. NOW IMAGINE ALL THIS
AND HAD BEEN HAVING A BUDGET ALL
OF A SUDDEN HAS MILLION TO
MILLION DOLLARS OF DOLLARS FOR
THOSE SAME FOUR YEAR OLDS. BUT
ONLY A PAIR SERPENTI K. AND
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO RECRUIT STAFF AND TO PLAN BUT
ONLY FOR TWO K. TEACHERS. FOR
THEM TO PLAN WITH US BUT NO NEW
DOLLARS FOR US TO PLAN WITH THAT
. WE'RE WONDERING WHERE THE
MONEY CAME FROM AND WHY THE IN
EQUITIES ON WHERE IT IS
ALLOCATED. OUR STATE DID
DETERMINE THAT T. K. PROGRAMS
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLD SHOULD BE
SERVED AT A CERTAIN RATE I
PROPOSE. TITLE GRAMS THAT SERVE
THE SAME FOUR YEAR OLD. BE
FUNDED AT THE SAME BASE RATE.
AND THEN ON TOP OF THIS BASE
RATE TITLE FIVE PROGRAM SHOULD
RECEIVE AN ADJUSTMENT FACTOR. A
FACTOR BECAUSE WE HAVE LOWER
TEACHERS- TO STUDENT RATIOS.
THEN THE T. K. PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROPOSED
BUDGET DOES NOT REFLECT THE NEED
OF EVERYTHING I JUST SAID NO NEW
FUNDING IS PROPOSED TO SUPPORT
OUR PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE. YOU
KNOW THE HOLD HARMLESS FOR
CONTRACTORS. WHICH IS HOW WE ARE
KEEPING THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM
OPEN FOR SESSION WORK ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. THIS BEING ABSENT IN
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS NOW
CAUSING PROVIDERS TO PLAN FOR
SHUT DOWN ON JULY FIRST WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME. CONTINUING TO
SERVE THE VULNERABLE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
BEG FOR THIS AND IT SHOULD IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET. IN DECEMBER AND JANUARY
ALONE WE HAD TWO HUNDRED
POSITIVE CASES. THAT'S FROM FOUR
NOVEMBER. TWO HUNDRED TIMES WE
HAD TO CONTACT PARENTS ABOUT
STAFF CLOSURES DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND THEN RE OPEN. WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE HOME HARMLESS
WILL BE CLOSED FOR GOOD. RATE
INCREASES ARE ALSO MISSING WE
ALREADY HAVE A PROFESSIONAL WORK
FORCE FOR WORKFORCE TEN USED TO
SUBSIDIZE THESE PROGRAMS. BY
ACCEPTING LOWER WAGES. UTK
PROVIDES AN AVENUE FOR TEACHER
TEEKAY TEACHERS TO EARN
PROFESSIONAL WAGES AND BENEFITS
IT DOES NOT LOOK AT THE LEAGUE
NEEDLE. FOR NON ELLIE A
COMMUNITY EARLY EDUCATION
EDUCATORS SALARY PARITY IS
NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE EXISTING
GAPS IN PAY AND OPPORTUNITY. WE
ALSO MUST CONTINUE TO WAIVE THE
FAMILY FEES IF WE TRULY ARE TO
HAPPEN EQUITABLE SYSTEM. I VERY
MUCH WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY. THE
GUIDING QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN THE
SAME FOR YEARS WE KNOW THE
ANSWER CARRENTALS CHOICE HAPPENS
WHEN FAMILIES. OPTIONS IN A
MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT IS
FULLY FUNDED SO PROVIDERS CAN
PROVIDE BENEFITS AND PAY
PROFESSIONAL WAGES. NOT POVERTY
WAGES THANK YOU. THANK YOU JUST
A REMINDER WE HAVE- QUITE A FEW
PANELISTS WE WANNA HEAR
EVERYBODY TODAY SO PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES
OR LESS. GIRLS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO STOP AND MOVE
ON. AT NEXT SPEAKER. HIS FROM
PARENT VOICES MARIN. HELLO MY
NAME IS CAITLYN HUDSON AND I
LIVE IN NEVADA I HAVE A SEVEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND A ONE YEAR
OLD SON- I'M PART OF. OUR VOICES
AROUND COUNTY. WHEN I WAS TOLD I
DID NOT HAVE TO PAY MY FAMILY
THING UNTIL JULY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO I WAS SO THRILLED AND
WAS ABLE TO ROLL MYSELF INTO THE
SPRING SEMESTER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHICH IS SOMETHING I
HAVE DREAMED ABOUT FOR A LONG
TIME. FREEZING FAMILY FEES
ALLOWED ME TO DREAM BIG FAN
YOU'RE PURSUING MY DREAM OF
GETTING MY DEGREE. IT WAS GREAT
NO I KIND OF JUST A LITTLE EXTRA
MONEY EACH MONTH TO PAY FOR THE
EXTRA COST OF SCHOOL SUPPLIES
AND TRANSPORTATION TO CLASS. I
ALSO RUN MY DAUGHTER TO
GYMNASTICS SHE HAS ALWAYS WANTED
TO JOIN BUT THE COST HAS ALWAYS
BEEN TOO MUCH FOR US TO REPORT.
I LOVE WATCHING HER TUMBLE AND
BE A PART OF THE TEAM. AS A
PARENT THESE ARE THE MOMENTS WE
HOPE FOR AND HOW WE DREAM ABOUT
PROVIDING FOR OUR KIDS. LET ME
SHARE WITH YOU WHAT MY BUDGET
LOOKS LIKE EVERY MONTH SO YOU
CAN BEGIN TO UNDERSTANDJUST WHY
KEEPING THE FAMILY FREEZE. THE
FAMILY FEES FROZEN IS ESSENTIAL
FOR MY FAMILY. I WORK AS A BANK
TELLER AND BRING HOME ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED A
MONTH. MY RENT IS TWO THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED WHICH IS EATING UP
OVER TWO THIRDS OF MY PAYCHECK.
BETWEEN GAS AND ELECTRIC MY
PHONE BILL INTERNET MY CAR
PAYMENT AS WELL AS INSURANCE
AND- TRANSPORTATION GAS. I HAVE
ABOUT FIVE DOLLARS LEFT OVER
EVERY MONTH. YOU MEAN NO ROOM
FOR ANY EMERGENCIES ARE
UNEXPECTED COSTS. I RELY ON HIGH
INTEREST CREDIT CARDS THE KEEP
THIS MERRY GO ROUND GOING. THE
FAMILY FEE WAIVER HAS ALSO
ALLOWED ME TO ROLL MY SENATE
BILL GATES CHILD CARE. ALTHOUGH
IT WAS HARD TO FIND SPACE FOR
HIM. HE WAS BORN DURINGCOBIT
AND FROM THE DAY HE WAS BORN
I'VE HAD HIM ON A WAIT LIST FOR
THE ONLY ENTRANCE. CENTER AND
RAN COUNTY THAT ACCOMMODATED MY
WORK SCHEDULE. I WAS FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO FIND CHILD CARE FOR
HIM BUT THAT BUT THEY DID NOT
OPEN UNTIL EIGHT THIRTY. I HAD
TO REDUCE MY WORK HOURS AND
THERE'S INCOME IN ORDER TO HAVE
ANY CARE AT ALL. MY CHILD CARE
CENTER WAS ALSO FAR OUT OF THE
WAY AS WELL AND ADDED THIRTY
MINUTES MY COMMUTE IN BOTH THE
MORNING. AND AFTERNOON. NOT
HAVING A SIZEABLE CHILDCARE
CLOSE TO HOME IS THE HIDDEN
COSTS OF FAMILIES. ESPECIALLY
WITH GAS PRICES BEING SO HIGH.
IT TAKES TIME AWAY THAT WE COULD
BE SPENDING WITH THEIR KIDS AS
WELL. ALL THIS ADDS ADDITIONAL
STRESS AND DURING THIS TIME I
FELT AN IMPACT ON MY MENTAL
HEALTH. I CALLED EVERY MONTH FOR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS HOPING FOR A
SPACE OPEN UP FOR MY SON SO WE
COULD GO BACK TO A MORE NORMAL
ROUTINE. I WAS FINALLY ABLE TO
ENROLL MY SON IN THE ENTRANCE
CENTER NEAR MY HOME AND MY
DAUGHTER'S ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
AFTER EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF BEING
ON THE WAIT LIST. HE ACTUALLY
JUST STARTED YESTERDAY. BUT I
CAN'T GET BACK TO THE HOURS. I
SPENT IN THE CAR THE MONEY A LOT
TO MAKE THE CHOICE. TO MAKE
CHILDCARE WORK AND CAN'T TAKE
WITH THE STRESS OF HAVING MORE
ON MY PLATE BECAUSE THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO CHILDCARE. IF I HAVE
TO START PAYING MY THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR DOLLARS AND THE
FAKE AND- I WILL HAVE TO DROP
BACK TO PART TIME CARE FOR MY
SON TAKE MY DAUGHTER. OUT OF
GYMNASTICS. AND SCRAMBLE TO HAVE
ENOUGH TO PAY FOR THE COSTS OF-
STARTING COLLEGE MYSELF. AFTER
LAST YEAR'S THE DISTANCE
LEARNING I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
AWAY THOSE THOSE ABILITY TO MY
KIDS. I CAN FEEL MY STRESS LEVEL
RISING JUST THINK ABOUT THE
FAMILY HE'S COMING BACK.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT. RECEIVE INSTRUCTIONS
NUMBER AS WELL. CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO TAKE ACTION TO PROTECT
WORKING FAMILIES LIKE MINE WE
NEED TO PASS A BUDGET THAT
EXTENDS THE FAMILY FEE WAIVER
WHICH HAS ALLOWED ME TO PURSUE
MY EDUCATIONAL GOALS PROVIDING
EXPERIENCES FOR MY DAUGHTER AND
WILL MY SON IN FOR DAY CHILD
CARE. TWENTY TWO EXPANSION
OCCURS WHAT'S REDUCE THE WAIT
LIST AND WE NEED TO RAISE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROVIDERS TAKING
CONNECTICUT. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
SPEAKER WILL WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
REPRESENTED FROM CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS UNITED. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME'S YVONNE COTTAGE I AM A
CHILD CARE PROVIDER AND MEMBER
OF THE CHILDCARE PROVIDER UNION
JUNCKER PROVIDERS UNION WHICH IS
A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN SEIU LOCAL. NINETY NINE FIVE TWO NINE AND
YOU D. W. WE HAVE ALSO A MOM I
HAD THREE CHILDREN- OLDEST IS.
TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY AND OUR
YOUNGEST IS FIFTEEN GOING ON THE
- I ALSO THREE SMALL
GRANDCHILDREN AND THEY ALSO
ATTEND MY CHILD CARE CENTER HERE
WHICH IS A BLESSING I WANTED
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR LETTING ME TESTABLE
TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY. I
OPENED MY SHOP WITHOUT AN AND
THEN PROVIDING CHILD CARE TRAUMA
INFORMED OUT CHAIR IN LANCASTER
EVER SINCE I CAME INTO THIS
FIELD CAN MAKE A POSITIVE CHANGE
TO MAKE AN IMPACT A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON MY COMMUNITY AND I
THOUGHT WHAT BETTER WAY THAN TO
OFFER PARENTS A SAFE PLACE FOR
THEM TO LEAVE THEIR CHILD A SAFE
PLACE FOR THEIR CHILD WOULD
LEARN WHAT BLACK WOULD GROW- I
LOVE WHAT I DO. I LOVE IT IT'S
A- IT'S A IT'S A- IT'S A
MINISTRY. AND EIGHT IT'S A LOT
HARDER THAN IT SHOULD BE THE
PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED SO MANY
FLAWS IN SO MANY. AND
DISCREPANCIES IN THE FIELD- WITH
SCHOOLS BEING CLOSED ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- HAD TO LEAVE THEIR KIDS
IN CHILD CARE AND WHILE MANY ARE
PERFORMING THESE LIFESAVING
LIFESAVING WORK. THUS FAR THE
CHILD CARE COMMUNITY HAS HAD TO
STEP UP WE'VE HAD TO STAY OPEN
WE'VE HAD TO MAKE CHANGES WE'VE
HAD YOU RISK EXPOSING OUR
FAMILIES TO DAYCARE. I'M DOWN
WITH THE FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS NOT HAVING HEALTH
CARE. THE RISK THAT WE FACE AS A
MAN. AND THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACE DURING THE PANDEMIC TO NOT
ONLY PROVIDE CHILD CARE AND ALSO
PROVIDE DISTANCE LEARNING I WENT
FROM BEING A PRESCHOOL TEACHER
TO BEING AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER. AND ALTHOUGH I TOOK THE
CHALLENGE ON IT HAS BEEN IT HAS
TAKEN A TOLL ON MY MENTAL
HEALTH. IT'S TAKING A TOLL ON MY
FINANCES MY EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH. I'M AYE YOU'RE LITERALLY
EVERY TIME THAT WE HAD. TO I'M-
UPDATE OUR FACILITY TO PURCHASE
CLEANING SUPPLIES TO PURCHASE
INTERNET AYE LAPTOPS EXTRA TAX.
WE HAD TO TURN OUR WHOLE
DOWNSTAIRS INTO A CLASSROOM. AND
THE HOURS ARE GRUELING MY HOURS
FROM TEN HOURS TO FOURTEEN HOURS
A DAY. AND YOU MIGHT BE
WONDERING WHY I CONTINUE TO DO
THIS. ARAMBULA I DO IT BECAUSE I
HE REALLY BELIEVES THAT EARLY
CHILD CARE AND EDUCATION IS MY
COLLEAGUES. AND I AND IT GIVES
ME A PURPOSE. IT THERE'S BEEN
DAYS WHEN I. CONSTANTLY
QUESTIONED MYSELF. ON HOW TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT SAME
QUALITY. WE'VE THE CHANGE THAT
WE'VE HAD DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
A LOT OF US PROVIDERS ARE
QUESTIONING THE SAME THING. WE
ARE RUNNING INTO BERNAU THERE'S
THOUSANDS OF PROVIDERS THAT ARE
RUNNING IN SUPPORT NOW. WE WAKE
UP EVERY DAY WITH THE SAME SMILE
TO GIVE THESE KIDS NO MATTER
WHAT IS GOING ON. IN THE
BACKGROUND. AND DESPITE THE
CRUCIAL NATURE OF OUR WORK WE'RE
STILL NOT VALUES. AS CHILD CARE
WORKERS AND I'M REMINDED OF THAT
EVERY DAY. TAKING ON OTHER
PEOPLE'S CHILDREN IN OUR HOME
AND TO PROVIDE THAT SAFE
ENVIRONMENT IS AN ENORMOUS GIFT.
AND ALSO WE'RE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WE HAVE. AND YET WERE AMONG
THE NATION'S MOST LOWEST PAID
WORKERS. I AM WITH EXTREMELY
LIMITED TO ALMOST ZERO TIME ALL
. NO BENEFITS SUCH AS RETIREMENT
OR HEALTH CARE. AND AS WITH
EITHER INDUSTRY OR OCCUPATION.
IN A LIVING WAGE AND PROVIDING
THE NECESSARY ANSWER ESSENTIAL
TO ATTRACT AND NOT GET
DISTRACTED HAVE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BUT ALSO RETAIN THOSE
CHAPTER PROVIDERS. AND THERE'S
REALLY NO INCENTIVE AT THIS TIME
THERE'S REALLY NO INCENTIVE FOR
US. TO CONTINUE TO DO THE SAME
MARK. AND TO BE HONEST PASSION
AND LOVE WILL ONLY TAKE YOU SO
FAR. WHEN YOU WAKE UP IN THE
MORNING IN YOUR BACK HURTS
BECAUSE OF THE REPETITIVE
MOVEMENT THAT YOU MAKE FROM
BENDING OVER EVERY DAY TO PICK
UP CHILDREN. AND YET THERE IS NO
LOW HEALTH CARE FOR US TO GO
MAKE A DOCTOR'S VISIT LET ALONE
EVEN THINK ABOUT RETIREMENT. I'M
I TRULY BELIEVE IF WE HAD
BENEFITS. I STRUCTURE PROVIDERS
WOULD BE IN A MUCH BETTER PLACE
. TO MENTALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
DEAL WITH THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING EVERY DAY AND THOSE
CHALLENGES ARE TRAUMA. CHILDREN
HAVING SIDE HE RETURNING BACK TO
SCHOOL THEY HAVE PTSD AND WE'RE
HAVING TO NAVIGATE THAT. WITHOUT
ANY TIME OFF WITHOUT ANY HEALTH
CARE. AT LEAST IF WE KNEW WE HAD
HEALTH CARE THEY KNEW WE WOULD
KNOW WE HAD A SAFETY NET IN CASE
SOMETHING HAPPENED OR CAME UP.
THERE'S MANY FAMILIES ARE SO
MANY FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
IN LACK OF JUST BASIC ACCESS TO
THE MUCH NEEDED CARE THAT. YOU
COULD PROVIDE. AND LACK OF THAT
ADEQUATE STATE INVESTMENT IN
SUBSIDIES WORK. DISTRIBUTION OF
IS PART OF THAT PROBLEM. BUT
STILL IT'S A LACK OF JUNCTURE
PROVIDERS BECAUSE WE CANNOT GET
THEM WE CANNOT ATTRACT THEM INTO
A FIELD THAT HAS NOTHING TO
PROVIDE FOR THEM. AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK YOU TO INVEST IN US
BY PROVIDING US WITH THOSE
ESSENTIAL NEEDS WITH HEALTHCARE
WITH RETIREMENT AND THE ADEQUATE
TIME OFF. BY INVESTING IN US
YOU'RE ALSO INVESTING IN OUR
CHILDREN COULD YOU REALLY
DESERVE THE BEST IN EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION. AND IT WORRIES ME
TO THINK THAT LIKE MR BLAKELY
MENTIONED IN THE BEGINNING OF
THIS AS WE SPEAK THERE ARE
PROVIDERS THERE ARE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS LEAVING THE FIELD.
AMAZING TEACHERS THAT HAVE GIVEN
THE BEST OF THEIR YEARS TO THIS
FIELD INTO THIS COMMUNITY THAT
ARE WALKING AWAY BECAUSE OF LACK
OF BACK THE BASIC HEALTH CARE
AND RETIREMENT AND TIME OFF. SO
AGAIN I JUST I'M ASKING YOU
TODAY TO INVEST IN US. INTO A
MESSAGE TO OUR CHILDREN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE REPRESENTAN
FROM SEIU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'LL JUST DO A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
WHERE WE'RE AT ON THE JAIL AND
SEES- THEY REFER TO THAT THREE
PRIORITY BENEFITS MENTIONED IN A
BONDS TESTIMONY- THAT WE
IDENTIFIED AS URGENT THAT'S
HEALTHCARE RETIREMENT. AND PAID
TIME OFF OUR WORKERS ARE ALREADY
RECEIVING LOW RATES DESPITE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WE'RE
SEEING RATES OF 70% OF THE
MARKET RATE FROM FIVE YEARS AGO
ON TOP OF THAT. MANY ARE PAYING
UP TO TWO THOUSAND A MONTH JUST
FOR HEALTH INSURANCE OUR
PROVIDERS ARE STRUGGLING TO
BALANCE THE RISE EVERYDAY ITEMS
SUCH AS DIAPERS FOOD AND RAN IT-
WHICH MEANS THAT MANY CAN'T SAVE
FOR RETIREMENT TAKE TIME OFF OR
EVEN PAY FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE.
I THE PRIORITY ITEMS SUCH AS
HEALTH CARE WE FOUND THAT MORE
THAN 50% OF OUR FAMILY'S HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS SURVEYED REPORTED
TO LEAD OUR POSTPONED MEDICAL
TREATMENT DUE TO LACK OF HEALTH
INSURANCE ARE BEING UNDER.
INSURED 20% REPORT THAT THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE INSURANCE
BECAUSE THEY'RE UNABLE TO AFFORD
THE MOST BASIC PLAN THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA. OUR ESTIMATE
IS TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS WOULD
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS. RETIREMENT
MANY OVER 90% THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND IN SAVINGS-
FOR RETIREMENT EXPERTS ADVISE
THAT RETIREES SHOULD PLAN TO
COVER EXPENSE OF FORTY THOUSAND
A YEAR TO RETIRE BY AGE SIXTY
FIVE. I AM BASED ON THE AVERAGE
LIFE EXPECTANCY THAT WOULD
REQUIRE A SAVINGS OF ONE
MILLION. OUR CURRENT COST
ESTIMATES FOR A SAVINGS FOR
PROVIDERS WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FOUR MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN MILLION TO ENROLL
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. INTO A FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN B. RETIREMENT PLAN.
FINALLY PAID TIME OFF. A MANY OF
OUR PROVIDERS ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS OF THE STATE AND
CANNOT TAKE OFF. THE HOLIDAYS OR
VACATION TIME THEY DON'T HAVE
SUFFICIENT PAID TIME OFF FOR
SICK LEAVE VACATION EMERGENCIES
AND HOLIDAYS. SO THIS CAN BE
REALLY TAXING ON A PROVIDERS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
FOR EIGHT POINT SIX MILLION THAT
WOULD PROVIDE ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS
WITH FIVE ADDITIONAL PAID TIME
OFF TO EASE. INCLUDING
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CHILDREN
UNPAYABLE SCHEDULES. CCP YOU IN
THE MYSTERY IT HAPPENED. WORKING
TO RE AGREE. AND RECOGNITION OF
THE URGENT OF THE NEED AND TO
GIVE- RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS IN
IMMEDIATE. IDEALLY IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
BUDGET YEAR I'M HAPPY TO GO INTO
MORE DETAIL- BUT I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE ARE-
THE BENEFITS ALONG WITH
ADDITIONAL RATE INCREASES.
INCREASES ARE CRUCIAL TO
REVITALIZE THE ARTS HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY IN STAFFING TO THE
LEVEL OF CALIFORNIANS WORKING
FAMILY NEEDS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. OKAY
THANK YOU THE LAST SPEAKER THE
REPRESENTED FROM THE LOW INCOME
INVESTMENT FUND. HI MY NAME IS
ANGIE CARLENE AND I'M WITH THE
LOW INCOME INVESTMENT FUND WHERE
A FINANCIAL INSTITUTION AND- WE
ARE I'M HERE AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF LAUGHFEST STAKEHOLDER OF THE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM BUT WANT TO
MAKE THE DISCLAIMER THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH CDS LAST.
ON THE AND FOR STRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM A PROGRAM DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION WERE ALSO MEMBERS
OF THE EASY COALITION AND
SUPPORT THEIR PRIORITIES FOR THE
SECTOR. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE SAID IN
THE PREVIOUS- TIME IS. THAT THE
WORK FORCE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE REALLY THINK ABOUT IS.
THE STATE THAT IS THE PHYSICAL
SPACES THAT THOSE PROVIDERS AND-
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROFESSIONALS SPEND THEIR TIME
AND DOESN'T HAVE GOOD
VENTILATION DOESN'T HAVE A NON
LEAGUE RUTH. DOES IT HAVE- OTHER
IMPORTANT PHYSICALS STRUCTURES
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE GREAT
SPACES. AND WE REALLY HAD FOR
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS A FRONT
ROW SEAT TO THE SUPPLY BUILDING
CHALLENGES THE PROVIDERS AND THE
SPECTER OF HAD FOR DECADES. AND
THE PANDEMIC'S ONLY MADE IT
WORSE BOB THERE'S NO FEDERAL
STANDALONE FUNDING FOR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION FACILITIES.
AND UNTIL RECENTLY A THERE
HASN'T BEEN ANY I'M AT THE STATE
LEVEL BURKE- GRATEFUL THAT NOW
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR. A
BEGINNING TO FACILITIES OF
FUNDING. THIS WILL REALLY HELP
ON THE SUPPLY BUILDING SIDE AND
THERE IS A LOT MORE NEEDED-
PROVIDERS HAVE REALLY SPENT THE
LAST TWO YEARS. FILLING IT IN
CLASSROOMS BECOMING PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS AND EXPECTED NOT
TO ALSO BECOME FACILITIES%
EXPERTS IS A BIG ASK. FOR ANY OF
YOU WHO'VE EXPERIENCED HER OWN
HOME IMPROVEMENT PROJECT YOU CAN
JUST IMAGINE WHAT'S INVOLVED HOW
LONG IT TAKES TO FIND TO GET
BIDS FROM CONTRACTORS. TO
COMPLETE CONSTRUCTION. GET
PERMITS AND WE KNOW THAT THE
STATE REALLY WANTS TO PUT NEW
SPACES IN CHILD CARE DESERTS AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF TUCKER TYPE
DESERT'S ACROSS CALIFORNIA. LIFT
REALLY BELIEVES THE BEST WAY TO
DO THIS IS TO BUILD EXPERTISE
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS THAT ARE
RURAL AND TRIBAL NATIONS AND
PLACES WHERE MOST CHILDREN.
COULD BE FASTER AND HOME BASED
SETTINGS. EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THERE WAS A HUGE
UNDERINVESTMENT IN EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION. BOB AS OUR ROLE
AS THE CO CHAIR OF THE NATIONAL
CHILDREN'S FACILITIES NETWORK WE
SPONSORED RESEARCH THAT SHOW TO
THAT SHOW THAT IN THE FIVE YEARS
LEADING UP TO THE PANDEMIC.
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND BUSINESSES
IN THE FIVE MOST POPULOUS STATES
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. RECEIVE
LOANS FROM THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION AND- CDFI IS LIKE
LEFT. HOWEVER OF THOSE FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND BUSINESSES ONLY
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY OF THOSE
WENT TO CHILD CARE. SO THIS
SHOWS YOU HOW MUCH MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE IN THE FINANCIAL SECTOR
TO HELP. LEVERAGE PRIVATE
DOLLARS AND PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
REALLY BUILD SUPPLY. AND IN THE
HOUSING SECTOR THEY'VE STARTED
pTHEY DO A LOT OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE LEVERAGING AND IT'S EXAM
IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF HOW YOU CAN
USE PRIVATE DOLLARS. TO INCREASE
SUPPLY BUILDING AFTER. ADD WE
BELIEVE MODELS LIKE THE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES FUNDED SAN
FRANCISCO. WHICH WAS THE ONLY
COUNTY IN THE STATE THAT
ACTUALLY INCREASE THEIR SUPPLY
BY 20% WHEREAS THE REST OF THE
STATE ACTUALLY DECREASED SUPPLY
UP BY 14% BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THEY'VE MADE IN
THE WORK FORCE AND IN
DISABILITIES. PARTICULARLY WITH
HANDS ON TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS CONTRACTING
NEGOTIATING LEASES. SITE
EVALUATION ETCETERA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATION TO
BUILDING BACK IN INCREASING THE
SUPPLY OF CHILD CARE. TO MEET
THE REAL NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE. OKAY
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GET TO ASK
QUESTIONS FROM BOTH THESE PANEL
SAID THAT THE SECOND PANEL OF
COURSE IS THE FIELD THE FIRST IS
MORE. FROM BY THE STATE IN THE
L. A. L. I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS-
WE HEARD THESE ISSUES OVER AND
OVER FROM ALL OF THEM. SO THE
FIRST IF THE- DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES COULDN'T AND
LIGHTNESS MORE ON THE TEMPORARY
CLOSURES HANNAH YOU REFERRED TO.
THIS TABLE AND OUR AGENDA. AND I
KNOW OVER THE YEARS WE'VE HAD
ATTRITION- BUT THE NUMBERS ARE.
ARE ARE MORE SO DURING THIS-
PANDEMIC SO. DO YOU TRIBUTE THE
TEMPORARY CLOSURES TO BE. WHAT
THEY'RE NOTED HERE IS TEMPORARY-
I KNOW WE'RE JUST. YOU KNOW
CHANGING RAPIDLY WITH THIS- YOU
KNOW AFTERMATH OF COVERED
NINETEEN. SO WHERE DO YOU THINK
THESE- TEMPORARY CLOSURES ARE
HEADED. WE DO SEE THEM AS HIGH
THIS IS KAREN CHANG DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES WE DO THINK
MS TEMPORARY CLOSURES AND MANY
OF THESE FACILITIES CLOSE AND
OPEN AND SOME OF THE SPEAKERS ON
THE PANEL JUST SPOKE ABOUT- BUT
POSITIVE AND THE IMPLICATIONS
FOR CLOSING A FACILITY FOR A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. AND IN OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS WILL BE
DISCUSSING WITH LICENSEES THERE
PLANS TO RE OPEN SOME OF THEM
ARE RE OPENED AND SO THEN WE'RE
NOTING THAT IN OUR DATA. AND
ALSO OFFERING RESTORE SAYS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
ANYONE CLOSE TO RE OPEN BUT YES
DEFINITELY SEE THESE AS
TEMPORARY CLOSURES NOT PERMANENT
STRUCTURES AND WHAT MAKES YOU
THINK THAT WHAT'S WHAT'S IS YOU
KNOW WE'RE COUNTING ON THIS OUR
ECONOMY IS COUNTING ON A LOT OF
THESE PROVIDERS ARE. HOPING TO
GET BACK OPEN WHAT MAKES US
THINK THAT THEY ARE TEMPORARY
AND THIS IS NOT- YOU KNOW
PERMANENT HIT TO OUR ALREADY
FRAGILE CHILD CARE INDUSTRY.
THEY'RE PART OF THAT IS BASED ON
THE RESPONSES WE RECEIVED
TEACHER THE SURVEY THAT STARTED
IN JANUARY. SO THE EARLY
INDICATIONS ARE THAT A LOT OF
THESE FACILITIES EITHER ARE WE
OPENING OUR HAVE REOPENED. BUT
IT'S VERY DYNAMIC AND FLUID AND
SO YOU MAY BE RE OPENED FORMALLY
CONTOURING JANUARY YOU MAY HAVE
HAD AN OUTBREAK LATER IN JANUARY
AND CLOSED. AND THEN NEEDED TO
RE OPEN AND SELL. IT THAT
COMPONENT I BILLS EARLY
INDICATORS FROM THE SURVEY AND
THEN ALSO IN A TOTAL INFORMATION
FROM THE FIELD. OKAY.
THANK YOU CAN I ASK THE
REPRESENTED THROUGH CRYSTAL
STAIRS WHO- OF COURSE IS A
MAJOR- PROVIDER OF CHILD CARE IN
THE- L. AREA. TO GIVE YOUR
INSIGHT ON ON THE RATE REFORM WE
HAVE I JUST INCOME UP JUSTIN
BLAKELY. CBSA COUPLE WORDS US
AND WE CAN SEE SEE YOU BACK HERE
ONLINE. IF YOU CAN COMMENT ON
THE- THE RATE REFORM THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH LAST YEAR
AND- ACKNOWLEDGED THAT IT
WASN'T- QUITE A FINISHING THE
JOB IN OUR PERSPECTIVE. SO HOW
IS THAT PLAYING OUT AS FAR AS-
INCREASES TO PAY LIVING WAGES
AND KEEP THE FINANCIAL VIABILITY
OF THEIR CENTERS AND WHAT MORE
IN ANY IN OUR PERSPECTIVE NEEDS
TO NEEDS TO HAPPEN TO COMPLETE
THE TASK. YEAH THANK YOU- I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT- YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR'S CHILDCARE RATE INCREASE
GOT PROVIDERS UP TO THAT SEVENTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE. ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REGIONAL
MARKET RATE SURVEY IN A PRE TEND
TO MAKE LIFE UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THOSE FUNDING
LEVELS WITH A CAT. THE NORMAL
RISE OF INFLATION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY WHILE
WE ARE YOU KNOW GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT OUR RATE
INCREASE. AT THE LEGISLATURE UP
ALL OP WORK DEPENDING DEMOCRATS
FOR THE NEW REALITY UP ON US-
THAT THE LAST YEAR'S RATE
INCREASE IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH-
JUST TO KIND OF. HIGHLIGHT SOME
SPECIFIC POINTS THE WHATEVER
REFERRING TO I THINK THAT NEEDS
TO PARMAR SURVEY THE MINIMUM THE
MINIMUM WAGE HAS INCREASE. OR
DOLLARS WITH THE LAST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION TAKING EFFECT IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR SMALLER
PROVIDERS. SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
INFLATION HAS INCREASED BY 11%
WITH A 7% INCREASE OF ONLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FINALLY
FINALLY EARLY DATA FROM JANUARY
INDICATES THAT THE NATIONAL
LABOR CRISIS IS FINALLY HIT THE
CHILD CARE PROFESSION- SO
ESSENTIALLY- THERE THAN
INFLATION. AND THE- THE LACK OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO MEET THE
CURRENT TIMES OF WHERE WE ARE
WITH THE COST OF LIVING IS
SEVERELY. ACTING UP PROVIDERS
WHICH IS WHY WE NEED TO. YOU
KNOW. CONTINUE TO- RETIRED THE-
FAR. RESTRUCTURE. OKAY THANK YOU
COULD CAN WE ARE THAT CAN BE
ROSEN FROM TO TALK ABOUT- YOUR
PURSE ON RATE WE'VE IN AN- WHERE
WE'VE GOT WHAT LAST YEAR AND HOW
MAY MORE IN DO. YES ABSOLUTELY
SO I THINK OF THE MOST RECENT
SURVEY IS TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION THOSE ADDITIONAL
COSTS BUT- WE HAVE SEEN
INFLATION INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY. I'M TO THE POINT
WHERE MANY OF OUR PROVIDERS ARE
UNABLE TO EXPAND FOR NEW KIDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT SURE IF THE
RATE INCREASE BALL WILL
SUBSTANTIATE WHAT THEY NEED- TO
ABSORB THE COST ESPECIALLY WITH
THEM TAKING IN MORE INTENSE- IT.
WE LIKE I MENTIONED IT WAS 70%
OF- TWENTY EIGHTEEN RATES AS
SINCE THEN WE'VE SEEN BUT- THE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE WE'VE SEEN
INFLATION IN THE PANDEMIC HAS
BECAUSE- CLOSURES WHICH WERE NOT
AS CERTAIN THAT WE WILL SEE RE
OPENING SENSE A NUMBER OF OUR
PROVIDERS ARE- MORE MATURE IN
ARE ARE JUST RETIRING OUT OF THE
SYSTEM. GIVEN THE COST TO
CONTINUE OPERATING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT I DID WANT TO- I WANT TO
MAKE IT JUST A FEW COMMENTS THAT
I KNOW I DIDN'T GET IT I DID NOT
MAKE EARLIER I DO WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND OUR TEACHERS. FOR
THEIR DEDICATION TO SERVING OUR
STATE'S CHILDREN FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES AND I THINK
THAT THE PANELS HAVE BEEN CLEAR
ON TWO THINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY
AND ONE IS THE WAIVER FAMILY
FEES THE OTHER HAS TO DO. WITH
FAIR COMPENSATION FOR THOSE WHO
ARE PROVIDING SUCH AN IMPORTANT
SERVICE. I OUR OUR TEACHERS OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS HAVE SERVED
ON THE FRONT LINE. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND HAVE RISK THEY'RE
VERY HEALTH- TO SERVE OUR
CHILDREN'S FAMILIES. OR DARK
DARK BUT THE OUR FAMILIES
CHILDREN- AND IT'S BEEN A GREAT
RISK. FOR THEM PERSONALLY IN
DOING THIS- SOME PEOPLE HAVE
CALLED OUR PROVIDERS. HEROES
DURING THIS TIME AND I JOIN WITH
THOSE WHO HAVE. WHO HAVE SHARED
THAT. I THE QUESTION OF BEING
FAIRLY COMPENSATED ESPECIALLY
BEING A CENTRAL WORKERS I THINK
IS AN IMPORTANT THING AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS QUESTION
EARLIER REGARDING THIS. ON THE
WAIVER FAMILY FEES IF I MAY HAVE
CAITLYN HUDSON FROM PARENT
FORCES- SHE TESTIFIED EARLIER
ABOUT. WHAT THIS MEANT FOR HER.
CAITLYN ARE YOU STILL WITH US.
WHAT CAITLYN SHARED IF SHE IS NO
LONGER THAT SHE SAVED THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS. EVERY
MONTH I WAS ABLE TO DO SO MUCH
MORE WITH THAT MONEY
-
ALL RIGHT THE QUESTION FOR CDSS
THEM OF THE WAIVER OF THE FAMILY
FEES IS SET TO END IN JUNE OF
THIS YEAR JUST A FEW MONTHS FROM
NOW. IS CBO SAYS THEM PREPARED
TO EXTENDED THE WAIVER THROUGH
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
. DIRECTION. DIRECTOR JOHNSON.
X. SHARE THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
ASKING IF WE COULD
OPERATIONALIZE THAT IS THAT THE
QUESTION IT'S GOING TO MAKE SURE
I'M CORRECT IT WHAT LEGISLATURE
SPOKEN WE OPERATIONALIZE THAT
EXTENSION. YES WE COULD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHTS WITH THANK YOU ALL OF
THE PANELISTS I'D LIKE TO NOW
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER. TWO
FIRST PANELISTS SARAH CORTEZ.
GOOD MORNING FAIR CORTES ELLIE
L. AS WE WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACTIONS AND
PAGE NINE OF YOUR ENGINE THAT
PROVIDES THIS INFORMATION- AND
I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT CHIU MAJOR
ACTIONS VERBALLY- FROM THE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF WHAT IN
YOUR AGENDA I'M THE FIRST IS
THAT THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE FOR CHILD CARE SLOTS IN
AND THIS THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET- THE CAREER BUT GETS I'M
INCLUDED SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO ACROSS THE STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDING- FUND
SOURCES TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SLOTS FOR CHILDCARE ACROSS
SEVERAL THE CHILD CARE PROGRAMS.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FREDERICK REACHED EIGHTY
THOUSAND CHILD CARE SLOTS FROM
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX OF WHICH IS
ANTICIPATED TO COST AN
ADDITIONAL ONE BILLION GENERAL
FUND BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN AND THE SECOND MAJOR
ACTION I'LL HIGHLIGHT IS THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET I'M ALSO
PROVIDED APPROVED INCREASED
RATES OF CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
WHICH WENT INTO EFFECT JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THEN
IT ALSO PROVIDES- TEMPORARY
SUPPLEMENTAL RATES THAT. ARE IN
EFFECT FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THROUGH DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSS THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET- WE WOULD NOTE THAT
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING INCLUDED
IN THE JANUARY PROPOSAL TO
ANALYZE THE GENERAL CHILD CARE
SLOTS THAT WERE PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET AGREEMENT FOR THE
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE MILLION
TO COVER THE FULL YEAR COST
GENERAL CHILD CARE SLOTS ADDED
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- BASED
ON COST PER CASE CALCULATIONS
FROM THE TWENTY. ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET ACT WE EXPECTED THIS
AMOUNTED TO A TOTAL OF EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO MILLION
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WELL
THE PROPOSED BUDGET ONLY
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED AND-
THIRTY NINE MILLION LEFT WE
EXPECTED- BASED ON OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE DECREASED
AMOUNT AVAILABLE. FOR SLOTS IN
THE PROPOSED BUDGET IS DUE TO A
CHANGE GEN METHODOLOGY- WE THINK
THERE'S A SICKENING THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT OF. FROM THE BUT
AGREEMENT GIVEN THAT- IT WOULD
ONLY PROVIDE SICK PERCENT OF THE
FUNDING. I'LL BE EXPECTED WOULD
RESULT IN LESS SPENDING ON AN
ONGOING BASIS FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
BUT I'M AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU I'M SO GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK
. NOW WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
DOCTOR LUPE HI MAN MILE HIM FROM
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES ON
THE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSALS. I
THINK YOU'RE CAN- SO FULL BUT
LIKE TO BEGIN BY RECOGNIZING
FIRST THAT THAT THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET INCLUDES A
HISTORICAL INVESTMENT TO
STABILIZE AND EXPAND THE CHILD
CARE AND DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
CDSS IS IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS. AND INVESTING WITH
URGENCY IN KEEPING UP WITH THE
INTENT TO STABILIZE THE CHILD
CARE AND DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM. FOR
EXAMPLE AND ALSO AS REFERENCES
YEAH THAT'S REFERENCE BY L. A.
B. O. PERFECT RELEASED NEW
CULTURE BASED ON SLOTS THIS FALL
AT GENERAL TEMPER SPOTS ARE ON
TARGET TO BE RELEASED IN APRIL.
RATE INCREASE TICKET BACK TO
JANUARY FIRST THE INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT MINOR IMPLEMENTATION
REPAIR RFA RESPONSES ARE DUE IN
MARCH AND THE NEW CONSTRUCTION
RFA IS ANTICIPATED TO BE THE
LEAST THIS LATE SPRING. THE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CONTINUES THE
HISTORIC INVESTMENT IN CHILDCARE
AND DEVELOPMENT THAT BEGAN WITH
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AGREEMENTS
THE BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION TOTAL FUNDS FOR
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY.
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR HE SAID
THAT SPENT FOCUS ON ACCESS
THROUGH ADDITIONAL SLOTS AND
CAPACITY INCREASES TO
STABILIZING THE FILLED. WITH
THAT I WILL MENTION THAT
TOMORROW WEBER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS OUTLINED IN
THE AGENDA IT CAME DIRECTOR
JOHNSON CHIEF DEPUTY CHARLIE
HAPPENED I. AM ALSO BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAPPEN BEFORE JUMPING QUESTIONS-
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF YOU WOULD
LIKE US TO HAVE. ON OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- INTO A
OUR NEXT ROLE OF. ASKED FOR IN
THE AGENDA WORKS BECAUSE OR
SHOULD WE WAIT TILL THE PASS.
WELL BEFORE WE DO THAT WHY DON'T
WE HAVE A SERVER CORTEZ FROM LA
SO RESPOND TO THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS. HEY THERE CORTES L.
A. L- I DID I DID JUST I'M
ACTUALLY FAIR RESPONSE IN IN MY
INITIAL COMMENTS I MADE ABOUT
THE GENERAL CHILD CARE SLOTS IN
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT NOT HAVING
ENOUGH MONEY FUNDING FOR THE
FULL YEAR COST OF THOSE SLOTS-
IN THAT TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
PROPOSED BUDGET. THANK YOU MS
CORTEZ- AND NOW THE NEXT SPEAKER
JUSTIN BLAKELY. S. THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNING JUSTIN BLAKELY
AGAIN ON BEHALF CRYSTALS THERE'S
AN EASY COALITION AT THE ECL THE
EASY COALITION ADVOCATES FOR
STATE BUDGET INVESTMENTS THE
POLICIES THAT SUPPORT THE
COALITION'S VISION OF CHILD CARE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SYSTEMS THAT SIR MEET THE
DIVERSE NEEDS OF ALL CHILDREN.
FAMILIES X. PEOPLE AREN'T BY
SYSTEM SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
HISTORICAL INJUSTICE THAT.
INTEGRATE CULTURALLY DEVELOPMENT
GREEN AND LINGUISTICALLY
RELEVANT AND RESPONSIVE HIGH
QUALITY CARE IN EDUCATED
CHILDREN. SO THE ONLY DISABILITY
AND VALUE AND JUST THE
COMPENSATE ALL- CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES- I LIKE. COALITION
BUDGET LETTER- LAST YEAR HAVE
THAT SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER LAST
YEAR'S CHILDCARE RATE INCREASE
GOT PROVIDERS UP AT SEVENTY
PERCENTILE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ARMAR SURVEY IN PRE
PANDEMIC LIKE UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THE FUNDING LEVELS
WITH CAP- NORMAL RISE OF
INFLATION IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY WHILE WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT RATE INCREASE-
THERE'S STILL SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
RIGHT. AND ACCORDING TO THE
CENTER FOR CHILD HERE EMPLOYMENT
NATIONALLY THE CHOPPY INDUSTRY
IS STILL DOWN A HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND JOBS SINCE FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ET LOCATION IT'S
REQUESTING A 20% ACROSS THE
BOARD RATE INCREASE TO HELP
RIDER TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
IN RESPECT THE FAMILY NEEDS MANY
FAMILIES UTILIZING SUBSIDIZED
HERE ARE REQUIRED TO PAY A
FAMILY B. THE FAMILY BASED ON
THE FAMILY SIDE ADJUSTED MONTHLY
INCOME AND WHETHER THEY USE FULL
TIME OR PART TIME HERE MOST
FAMILIES WITH CHARACTERS THAT'S
THE THAT LACK AND LEAD THAT.
THEY'RE PAYING AN ESTIMATED
SIXTY A MILLION A YEAR IN P.
THAT THEY CANNOT AFFORD
CALIFORNIA IN THE BILL SOME OF
THE ARM CALLS I CHARACTER
POLICIES THAT KEEP FAMILIES THE
COMP COLOR FROM BUILDING WEALTH-
INTROSPECTIVE SPACE IT'S- EASY
COALITION SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SPENDING UP
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SLOTS STILL WITHOUT ADEQUATE
RATES FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
IN THE PERMANENT WAVING THE
FAMILY FEES. THE ADMINISTRATION
INTENTIONS WILL NOT BE MET SOME
SHOPPERS BUYERS ARE EXPERIENCING
SUCH EXTREME STAFFING SHORTAGES
THAT THEY HAVE HAD TO CLOSE. IT
TO THE LACK OF STAFF. I IN
RESPECT THE VILLAGE THE
STATEMENT TO INVEST THE CHILD
AND THE IF STRUCTURE GRANT. THE
COALITION RESULTS IN DOLLAR BETH
- OF WHICH WOULD BE YOU-
EXPLAINING OUTSIDE THE THAT CAN
LIVE. IN TEN MILLION THE CAR OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY TO STUDY
ON. AND PROVIDING START PLANNING
FOR PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS GAP
FUNDING FINANCE THE APERTURE HOW
CARE ENTERS FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOUSING UNITS ARE COLOCATED
WITH. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS- PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AT
COMMUNITIES THAT FAMILIES WITH
THE GREATEST NEED INCLUDING
TRIBAL RULE RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND CHAPTER. SURE THE GRANT
PROGRAM IS ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL
PROVIDERS. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
PLANNING ATASSI BUILDING AND
DEDICATED FACILITY PLANS ARE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIANS NEED THE
PROVIDERS NEEDS ACTIVELY THANK
BILL THE STATE BUILDING SEES ME.
I AM EXPECT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE REQUESTED RE
INSTATEMENT INCREASE OF THE
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANTS
PROGRAM. TO REBUILD AND EXPAND
WORKFORCE CAPACITY TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN IN
FAMILIES AT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION. THIS WILL ACT WE
SUPPORT THE WORK OR THE JEEP AND
EDUCATIONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
ASPIRATIONS. IT IS SIR THAT YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO TRAINING COURSE.
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES THAT
WILL HELP PREPARE THEM TO MEET
THE DIVERSE. NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS FAMILIES AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE HE
SAID AND IF. REALLY RESPONSIVE
WAY WITH TWO THROUGH TWENTY FIVE
MILLION SET ASIDE FOR WORKFORCE
TRANSPORTATION WAIT AND- ENABLE
PROVIDERS. FOR F. MADE BY. READ
PERCENT OF CHILDREN. AGED FIVE
NEARLY FORTY PER HERE FOR
CHILDREN UNDER YEARS OLD. THE
BILL YOUR SPECIFICALLY ACCORDING
TO THE LANGUAGE LEARNER TO MAKE
UP NEARLY PERCENT OF CHILDREN
AND CAL- THOSE MY COM AND THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN FOR THE- TO YOU.
THANK YOU. THE FORD THE FINAL OR
DEPARTMENTS SIR. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE RMR. REGIONAL
MARKET SURVEY RATE SURVEY-
THERE'S REALLY ME IT'S TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IT'S ALREADY
OLD BUT SPECIALLY LOVE THE
PANDEMIC AND INFLATION WHAT
WOULD IT COST TO FUND ALL
PROVIDERS AT THE NINETIETH
PERCENTILE OF THE R. M. R.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION-
WE DON'T HAVE AN ESTIMATE THIS
TIME FOR THAT- FOR WHAT THE
POTENTIAL COST WOULD BE TO- TO
REIMBURSED AT THE NINETIETH
PERCENTILE APOLOGIES THAT
PROTECT INTEREST MYSELF GABBY
CENTER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JUST AS AN ASIDE OFTENTIMES WE
OUTSCORED CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND OUR TEACHERS. TO GIVE SO
MUCH MORE BECAUSE OF THEIR
ABSOLUTE DEDICATION TO THE
CHILDREN. AND I THINK THE
QUESTION IS AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND KNOWING WHAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE. SO THAT WE DO
PROVIDE FOR THAT IN OUR BUDGET-
SO IF YOU WOULD GET THAT
INFORMATION TO OUR CHAIR. SO YOU
CAN GET THAT TO THE REST OF US.
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. TELNET RESTRICTING.
IF THE COMMAND CHAIR JUST A
FOLLOW UP TO WIN COULD WE GET
THAT INFORMATION FROM FINANCE.
AB GABBY CENTER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WILL BE SURE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF
JUSTICE TO PROVIDED. A SENSE OF
TIMING OF WHEN WE CAN PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION. DO YOU HAVE A
ROUGH ESTIMATE FIRST IN THE
COMMITTEE. IF POSSIBLE I WANT TO
REFRAIN FROM COMMITTING TO
SPECIFIC TIME LINE JUST BECAUSE
I'M I'M NOT CERTAIN AT THIS TIME
HOW LONG IT WOULD TAKE TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION OR ARE
WE TALKING MAY. SELECT PERSONS
LIKE IT'S SOMETHING YOU COULD
TURN AROUND IN A WEEK OR SO. I
MEAN WE I THINK. APOLOGIES I
CERTAINLY THINK THAT THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP ON. AT IN
TERMS OF THAT TIME MIGHT YOU
SUGGESTED FOR THAT FOR ME VISION
FOR WORKING AT THAT POINT IN
TIME. OKAY HOW ABOUT YOU GET
BACK TO US BY THE END OF THE
WEEK. GIVE US A SPECIFIC TIME
FRAME AS TO. WHEN YOU THINK YOU
COULD GET THAT DONE BY HOW'S
THAT SOUND. CERTAINLY THANK YOU
VERY GOOD. OKAY- THE THIRD.
COUPLE QUESTIONS- I THINK WE
WERE A LITTLE BIT SURPRISED TO-
NOT THE RATE INCREASES- IN THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL AS PER FOR WHAT
WE THOUGHT WE HAD AGREED TO IN
THE BUDGET- IT'S OUR EXPECTATION
IS THAT WAS A REASON WHY THAT
WAS NOT IN THERE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION CAN
BE CENTER WITH PARTNER FINANCE-
AS- A KID JOHNSON HAD.
REFERENCED AND THE STATE HAD
BREACHED- THE FIRST AGREEMENT
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT WITH- SEE COULD BE YOU
LAST YEAR- WHICH WAS CODIFIED
INTO LAW THROUGH AB ONE THIRTY
ONE- NEED AT. AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUT MAINTAIN THAT RATE
REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE
REFLECTED IN THIS AGREEMENT THAT
IS IN EFFECT JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
ADDITIONALLY JUST ONE THING
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
AGREEMENT AT THE STATE ANTI
SPEAKING YOU ARE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY THROUGH. A JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT HE OR JAIL AND
SEE TO DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR A SINGLE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
STRUCTURE THAT QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR EQUITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
WHILE SUPPORTING POSITIVE
LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN. AT THE
DANCING WILL PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS NO LATER THAN
NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH OF THIS YEAR.
BOB THE STATE IS ALSO CONVENING
A SEPARATE WORK GROUP TO ASSESS
THE METHODOLOGY FOR ESTABLISHING
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. AND THE
EXISTING QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT AND
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS. HI THIS BY
WORKABLE PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR LATER THAN AUGUST FIFTEENTH
OF THIS YEAR. I'M SORRY WHAT'S
THE- POINT OF THE RESEARCH THAT
ALL THE RESEARCH SAYS THAT THE
RATES ARE TO ALLOW US TO DO YOU
NEED. I DON'T THINK WE NEED
SOMEBODY ELSE TO TELL US THE
RESEARCH ABOUT. SO WHAT'S THE
POINT OF THIS. RESEARCH. SURE AT
THE AND THE INTENSITY IS TO
FURTHER DELVE INTO-
RECOMMENDATIONS IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED- IT WAS A COMMON
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED FOR THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT FOR NEXT YEAR. HOW
TO GET TO MY QUESTION. CAN YOU
BE MORE SPECIFIC AS TO WHAT
ISSUES YOU WERE SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT THAT SOMEHOW THE RATE
STUDY FOR ALL THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ILLUMINATE. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION. I THINK THAT
THAT I SHOULD NOTE- THAT THE
CRIMINALS REACHED LAST YEAR-
RECOGNIZES THAT THEY'RE ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED- IT'S
JUST THE- IT IS WITH THE INTENT
TO SET TO ENGAGE IN.
CONVERSATIONS TO. I WAS IN THE
ROOM WITH THAT AGREEMENT AND
ALSO MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
AGREEMENTS WITH- PUBLICLY FUNDED
CHILDCARE SO THE WHOLE PRIVATE
SECTOR OF CHILD CARE WHICH IS
NOT PART OF THAT UNDERSTOOD THAT
AGREEMENT SO- COULD YOU. TO
EDUCATE US AS TO WHAT ISSUES
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. BECAUSE I
I'M I'M NOT AWARE OF WHAT THEY
ARE SO IF YOU COULD PLEASE. TELL
THE COMMITTEE WHAT THEY ARE. AT
A CERTAIN I MIGHT ADD TO FOR TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WHEN THEY ARE AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT AND THE EXTENT ONE
THREE THANK YOU- THIS IS KEN
JOHNSON AT THE PARKING OF SOCIAL
SERVICES JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. RELATED
YOUR QUESTIONS RELATED TO RATES
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
COMING OUT OF THESE WORK GROUPS
ARE OUTLINED TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS ON CREATING A
UNIFIED RATE STRUCTURE. TODAY
THERE IS THE REGIONAL MARKET
RATES AND THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. AND THOSE
RATES ARE HE DIDN'T NEED TO HAVE
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
STRUCTURES BASED ON. THE TYPE
OF. THAT PROGRAM IS BEING
OPERATED SO. AT PRIVATE
PROVIDERS TO YOUR TO YOUR POINTS
OUT CAN CERTAINLY ACCESS. CHILD
CARE SUBSIDIES THAT ARE PAID TO
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE
STRUCTURE. THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE STRUCTURE IS
FOR THOSE WHO ARE CONTRACTED. TO
PROVIDE THOSE SUBSIDIES IN LARGE
ENOUGH CERTAIN NUMBER OF STEPS
THESE PER AT PROGRAM. AND SO
PART OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE WORKGROUP ARE TO CREATE ONE.
UNIFIED RATE STRUCTURE I
WITNESSED AT THE ENTIRETY OF A
PROGRAMS BETTER AGAIN.
SUPPORTING AT. BUT OUR LOW
INCOME BETTER ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIES AND WHAT THAT. WOULD
LOOK LIKE. IN ADDITION TO THAT
UNIFIED RATE STRUCTURE THERE'S
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO HOW WE ESTABLISH. OUR
THOSE RATES AND AGAIN THE
STANDARD REMEMBER RECENT RATE
STRUCTURE IS DIFFERENT THAN THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE IS WE
ACTUALLY CONDUCT A SURVEY. AFTER
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE SURVEY
AT TO GET TO ADD IDENTIFIED FIVE
REGION. I WATCHED THAT PROVIDERS
ARE CURRENTLY CHARGING. THEM SO
AGAIN LOOKING AT UNIFIED RATE
STRUCTURE. AND LOOKING AT THE
PROCESS BY WHICH WE DEVELOP THE
RATE. STRUCTURE FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE. OKAY THANK YOU FOR ANSWER
A SO. I GUESS MY QUESTION IS THE
- RATE STRUCTURE MEAN THE REASON
WE HAVE A REGIONAL RATE
STRUCTURE IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES IN COST OF
LIVING VRY VERY LARGE.
DIFFERENCES TO HOW WITH. THE END
AND I'M NOT AGAIN I'M NOT
ADVOCATING FOR KEEPING THE
REGIONAL RATE STRUCTURE I THINK
WE'VE ALL SEEN- IT'S CHALLENGES
OVER THE YEARS. BUT HOW WOULD
YOU THEN INCORPORATE THE COST OF
LIVING DIFFERENCES INTO I GUESS
WHAT WHAT I HEAR A REUNIFIED
RATE STRUCTURE ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT. A SINGLE RATE STRUCTURE
FOR THE- STATE WHICH I ASSUME IS
KIND OF WHERE YOU'RE GOING MY
QUESTION WAS HOW HOW DO YOU
ACCOUNT FOR THE REGIONAL COSTS
OF LIVING DIFFERENCES. SURE SURE
SO WE COULD STILL WITHIN A
UNIFIED STRUCTURE THINK ABOUT
THE REGIONAL DIFFERENCES THAT
CAN CERTAINLY BE PART OF HOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT THAT'S KIND
OF A CONVERSATION THAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE WORK GROUPS
NOW. SINGLE IS JUST SIMPLY TO
SAY WHY DO WE HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
RATE STRUCTURES IN THE ENTIRETY
OF THE FIELD. CAN WE HAVE ONE IN
THE IN THE GET THAT ONE COULD
ABSOLUTELY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES THAT'S
EXACTLY THE WORK AB. AT THE
COMMITTEES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADMINISTRATION FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ALLOWS FOR
A SURVEY AGAIN THIS REGIONAL
SERVICE THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
HISTORICALLY IN CALIFORNIA IT
ALSO ALLOWS FOR ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGIES TO IDENTIFY HABITS
THAT THOSE RATE SO AGAIN. I THIS
IS A CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE
HAVING TO DETERMINE ALL THINGS
CONSIDERED TO YOUR POINT AROUND-
IN IN WHAT IN THAT PANEL IS THAT
I'VE SPOKEN THIS MORNING I WHAT
ARE THE COMPONENTS THAT NEED TO
BE PART OF A UNIFIED STRUCTURE.
EVEN IF EVEN TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES. UNDERSTOOD
BUT I THINK I THINK MY CONCERN
IS WE HAVE AN INDUSTRY THAT IS.
ALREADY UNDER- WE KNOW THAT
THEIR ALSO INDUSTRY WHICH IS
VERY CRITICAL FOR THE STATE TO
GET A CERTAIN SEGMENT. OF ITS
WORK FORCE BACK TO WORK. A I
KNOW IF YOU ANSWER THE I POSE TO
PARTNER FINANCE. WHY PLEASANT
THE- WHY WHY WASN'T THE RATE
INCREASE. THAT WE HAD
ANTICIPATED IN THE IN THE
BUDGET. BUT A TITO SOUNDED LIKE
OR WOULD WE NEED SOME MORE TIME
TO DO SOME RESEARCH AND I THINK-
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY'S DOING
MORE RESEARCH TO DETERMINE THAT
THIS FIELD IS UNDERFUNDED. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAINST THE
RATE INCREASES THAT WERE AGREED
TO THEIR WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
MARKETING. AND THEY AFFECT THEY
WERE INCLUDED IN THE MAIN
AGREEMENT WHICH IS A TWO YEAR
AGREEMENT SO THEY ARE THERE LET
ME JUST LET ME JUST. KIND OF AT
A SURE YOU GOT THE RATE
INCREASES THAT WERE AGREED TO AB
AS OUTLINED IN THAT MADE
AGREEMENT WITH CHILD CARE
PROVIDED UNITED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE THERE IN THOSE
CONTINUE THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. RIGHT BUT THOSE ARE THE
ONLY THE GROUPS ARE REPRESENTED
BUT THERE'S A WHOLE SEGMENT OF
GROUPS THAT ARE REPRESENTED THAT
WEREN'T AT THE- TABLE SO YOU'RE
JUST. PUTTING THOSE. IMPOSING
THOSE RATES THAT WERE NOT AGREED
TO BY THE PEOPLE ON TO THEM. THE
INCREASES ARE UNIVERSAL FOR
ANYONE RECEIVING THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE. AND EXTENT THE
REFILLS ARE INCLUDED IN BOTH
COMPONENTS SO YES THOSE WERE
AGREEMENTS THAT WERE MADE
UNIVERSALLY. AFTER BOTH RATE
STRUCTURES OKAY. SO- WHERE WERE
WERE ASSUMING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GONNA- FUND A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND NEW
SLOTS FOR CHILD CARE- ARE WE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO I JUST
CONTACTED PART OF FINANCE ARE WE
GONNA BE SEEN THOSE ESTIMATES
BEFORE THE MAY REVERSE. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SAID TOMORROW
WEBER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WHEN AND-
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADHERE TO THE
COMMITMENTS MADE IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT TO
INCREASE CHILD CARE SLOTS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE L. A. O.
TO DO SO. I WILL CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE L. A. O.
AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATE BUDGET
METHODOLOGIES TO ESTIMATE THE
COST OF SLOTS AND ANY REVISIONS
WOULD BE REFLECTED IN THE MIRROR
FISHING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. OKAY SO- SO THAT THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A YESTERDAY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS AROUND ESTIMATES ARE
PRIVATE OR MAYBE LESS IS A- IS
THAT WHAT I'M HEARING. WE'RE IN
CONVERSATIONS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
LEADING UP TO THE MAY REVISE
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. THOSE ARE
MY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. SOME
ARRESTS. THANK YOU I JUST WANT
TO BE SURE THAT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE- PROVIDERS
AN EARLY EDUCATORS WE ARE
INCLUDING OUR HEAD START
TEACHERS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE ALL FAIRLY COMPENSATED FOR
THEIR WORK- I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS- WORK IN TRYING TO
INCREASE THIS. BEYOND EVEN WHAT
SOME SOME OF THE- SOME OF THE
OTHER GROUPS ARE REQUESTING AND
ALSO SPECIFICALLY- TO INCLUDE
THE COLA WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU I'D WANT TO GO BACK TO
CD AND I KNOW I KNOW I MISSED
THIS- BUT I DON'T THINK
UNDERSTANDING BEGIN QUITE ANSWER
THIS SUBSIDY YOU CAN ANSWER US.
AS FAR AS WHAT THE COST WOULD BE
TO DO THE RATE REFORM EFFORTS A
PRESCHOOL TO GET PASSED TO THE
NINETY PERCENTILE FOR THE-
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
VIRGINIA EARLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WE WOULD
NEED AN ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE MILLION TO GET
TO THE NINETIETH PERCENTILE OF
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SURVEY. SO
THAT'S FROM OUR CURRENT RATES
TIED TO THE NINETIETH PERCENTILE
THE RIGHT SUPPLEMENTS FUNDING-
FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET IS
GETTING US. CLOSE TO THAT BUT
THAT RATE SUPPLEMENTS FUNDING IS
TEMPORARY. FOR ESTIMATING THAT
THE RIGHT SUPPLEMENTS FUNDS WILL
GET US TO THE EIGHTY FOURTH
PERCENTILE. AND THEN- SO DURING
ONE OF THOSE ARE IN EFFECT IT'S
AN EXTRA TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
AND THEN WHEN THE RIGHT
SUPPLEMENTS FUNDS EXPIRE IT WILL
BE AND YOU KNOW THE FULL THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
ONGOING. YEAH AND THIS IS. WE
HEAR LL THE OTHER SPEAKERS SOME
OF THE COMMON DENOMINATORS ARE-
CHALLENGES AND MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES AND JUST THE FINANCIAL
STRESS OF OPERATING- EITHER A
CHILD CARE CENTERS STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. YOU KNOW WE
WE'RE NOT PROVIDING ENOUGH TO
PAY LIVABLE WAGES AND WE SET ALL
TIME IS A FRAGILE WORKFORCE YOU
KNOW PEOPLE LOVE WORKING WITH
YOUNG KIDS BUT THEY CAN GO WORK
AT COSCO OR STARBUCKS AND WAKE
MAKE WAY MORE MONEY. AND HAVE
FAR LESS STRESS PROBABLY SO WE
DID HALF THE JOB LAST THROUGH
RATE REFORM AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO MAKE CLEAR THE MINISTRATION
IS WERE NOT DONE WE WANT TO BE
FULLY FUNDED FROM LAST YEAR'S
DEAL NOT ALTERNATIVE BUDGETARY
GIMMICKS THAT SOUNDS LIKE
ALTERNATIVE FACTSTHERE. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE PROPERLY FIND
LAST YEAR'S ARRANGEMENT BUT WE
REALIZE THAT'S NOT NOT DONE WE
WANT TO COMPLETE. THE JOB AND SO
I KNOW RIGHT HERE THANK YOU FOR
THREE HUNDRED PLUS MILLION WE
CAN GET US TO THE- THE RATE
REFORM AND GETTING SAID NINETY
PERCENTILE WE'RE GOING TO GET
WITH THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE
AND THAT'S A PIECE OF THE PUZZLE
AND SO THAT WILL CERTAINLY BE
OUR PRIORITY AS WE FINALIZE. THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THIS BUDGET
AND I ASSUME THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE SENATE
AS WELL. SO JUST ONE OF A MARKER
DOWN THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE
PRIORITY FOR US HERE- SEEING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS ON ISSUE
NUMBER. TWO WE WILL PROCEED NOW
WITH ISSUE NUMBER THREE. WHICH
IS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM OVERSIGHT IN
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSALS WE WILL
HEAR FROM HER AND FINANCE L. A.
OF CD AS WELL AS A ENTITY FROM-
THE TULARE- COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. BERMAN A FINANCE
PLEASE PROCEED. THE MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GENERALLY RUN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'LL BE
GIVING AN OVERVIEW OF THREE
PROPOSALS PUT FORTH IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET THE FIRST
PROPOSAL WOULD BE TO MAKE
CHANGES TO ELIGIBILITY AND I
KNEW REQUIREMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO INCLUSIVE
PRESCHOOL ENVIRONMENTS THE
SECOND PROPOSAL IS TO EXPAND THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM AND THE THIRD
PROPOSAL IS FOR EDUCATOR
TRAINING ON PRESCHOOL ASSESSMENT
TOOLS. MINISTRATION RECOGNIZES
THAT CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE BETTER LONG TERM OUTCOMES
IN THIS DISABILITIES ARE
IDENTIFIED EARLY AND
INTERVENTIONS BEGAN AT A YOUNG
AGE HOWEVER WHILE ABOUT 12% OF
STUDENTS IN PUBLICATION TWELVE
SCHOOLS STATEWIDE HAVE A
DISABILITY ONLY ABOUT 4% OF
STUDENTS AND STATE PRESCHOOL OUR
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES.
MEANWHILE THE FEDERAL HEAD START
PROGRAM REQUIRES AND ROOM
INCLUDE AT LEAST 10% OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES. TO INCREASE
ACCESSTO INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS AND TO ALIGN WITH
HEAD START THE BUDGET REQUIRES
STATE PRESCHOOL CONTRACTORS TO
MAINTAIN ENROLLMENT OF AT LEAST
10% STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
TO PROVIDE CONTRACTORS WITH THE
FUNDS NCESSARY TO SERVE
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS WITH
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT NEEDS.
THE BUDGET PROVIDES A HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN POINT EIGHT.
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO INCREASE
THE ADJUSTMENT FACTORS FOR THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT. TO
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
TO LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET PROPOSES
SEVERAL CHANGES TO ELIGIBILITY
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO STATE
PRESCHOOL. FIRST THE BUDGET
INCLUDES CATEGORICAL ELIGIBILITY
TO STATE PRESCHOOL FOR ALL AGE
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WITH WITH
DISABILITIES REGARDLESS OF
INCOME. SECOND AUSTIN'S
PARTICIPATING IN STATE PRESCHOOL
WILL MAINTAIN CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY FOR TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS AS OPPOSED TO TWELVE
MONTHS. AND FINALLY PROVIDERS
THAT HAVE SERVED ALL ELIGIBLE
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS IN
THEIR SERVICE WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SERVE TWO YEAR OLD CHILDREN. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL IS FOR INCLUSIVE
EARLY EDUCATION EXPANSION
PROGRAM. AS YOU MAY RECALL THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM WAS PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS PART OF
THE EDUCATION ON MYSELF. EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM IS A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM FOR
ALLOCATION TO LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
INCLUSIVE EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. BUT MAYBE IT'S FOR
FACILITIES ADAPTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION OF KNOWLEDGE
AS THE INCLUSIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS ARE BENEFICIAL TO
THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
ACADEMIC DEVELOPMENT OF NOT ONLY
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES ALSO
GENERAL EDUCATION STUDENTS.
BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM. AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
INCLUDE INCLUSIVE CLASSROOMS. OF
THESE FUNDS THE SUPERINTENDENT
ALLOCATE UP TO FIFTY MILLION TO
WORK WITH LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES AS ACCOUNT SUCH AS THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE STATEWIDE ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT. EFFORTS TO OFFER A LINE
EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS. THE
THIRD PROPOSAL IS AIMED AYE AT
IDENTIFYING SOCIAL DISABILITIES-
EARLY AND STARTING INTERVENTIONS
AT A YOUNG AGE AS PRESCHOOL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IS
EXPANDED WE SHOULD FURTHER
REFINED THE DIAGNOSTIC
ASSESSMENT TOOLS USED FOR EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF STUDENTS. WITH
LEARNING DISABILITIES AND ENSURE
TEACHERS RECEIVE THE TRAINING TO
EFFICIENTLY USE THEM IN A LINE
WITH THIS THE BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO INCORPORATE EARLY
IDENTIFICATION FOR LEARNING
DISABILITIES. INTO THE DESIRED
RESULTS DEVELOPMENTAL PROFILE
INCLUDING A ONE IT INCLUDING A
PROCESS FOR FOLLOW UP EXPERT
ABOUT THE LEADERS AND SIXTY
MILLION ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
PROVIDE TRAINING FOR EDUCATORS
ON EFFECTIVE USE OF THESE TOOLS.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
L. A. L. THERE CORD HAS L. A. L.
AND WE JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS
REGARDING THE PROPOSED
REQUIREMENT THAT 10% OF CHILDREN
ENROLLED OUR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES- SO IMPLEMENTING
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
WOULD MEETING STATE PRESCHOOLS
PROVIDERS WE NEED TO MAKE
MODIFICATIONS TO HOW THEY
OPERATE AND THIS MAY INCLUDE
MODIFICATIONS TO THE EXISTING
CURRICULUM IMPROVING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OTHER
AGENCIES THAT CAN REFER STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES. WELL FOR SOME
PROVIDERS PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT OPERATE THE HEAD START
PROGRAM THEY MAY NOT NEED TO
MAKE MUCH MODIFICATION GIVEN
THAT THEY ALREADY MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS- THAT THAT THE
STATE REQUIREMENT- WE WOULD NOTE
THAT MEETING THE STATE
CORRECTIONAL WOULD BE RELATIVELY
EASIER FOR- LBJ'S PROVIDERS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES TO
THEIR STUDENTS. AT LEAST MAY
HAVE AN EASIER TIME HAVING
STUDENTS REFERRED TO ACTUALLY
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND HAVE
GREATER ACCESS TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION EXPERTS ALTERNATIVELY
NON ELITE PROVIDERS ESPECIALLY
THOUGH NOT OPERATING HEAD START
PROGRAMS WILL LIKELY FIND
SERVING  LARGER SHARE OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES MORE
CHALLENGING- TO THIS AND WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE SET
ASIDE A LARGER PORTION OF THE-
OF THE FUNDING FOR STATE LEVEL
SYSTEMS AND SUPPORT THEY CAN BE
ACCESSED. BY NOT LA PROVIDERS.
IS THAT YOUR COULD ALSO CONSIDER
RE DIRECT OTHER SO FUNDING FOR
NON ELITE TRAINING AND- THE LAST
THING I WANT TO LOOK FOR. TO THE
PERCENT REQUIRE. IT WILL THINK
10% IS A REASONABLE STARTING
POINT LOGISTIC MAIN TO. THE
FUNCTIONAL IN A FEW YEARS. IN
LIGHT OF THE MAJOR CHANGES THAT
WILL BE OCCURRING IN EARLY
EDUCATION WITH THE EXPANSION OF
TRADITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. WITH
REGARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DISSERTATION ROLES- WE
JUST. LIKE TO KNOW THAT THAT
THEY'RE SOME OF THE TRADE OFF
HERE- THIS COULD BE BENEFICIAL
TO PROVIDERS AS IT WOULD HELP
ENSURE PROGRAMS ARE FULLY
ENROLLED. HOWEVER PROVIDERS MAY
NEED TO MAKE SOME- PROGRAM
PHYSICALLY MODIFICATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE HAVING FOR STAFF FOR
CHILD EIGHT- HAVING TO CHANGING
STATIONS. GIVEN ADDITIONAL
COMPLEXITIES OF THIS CHANGE THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO WAIT A
FEW YEARS AND SEE HOW THE
EXPANSION OF KFX PRESCHOOL
ENROLLMENT BEFORE DECIDING. TO
ADJUST ELIGIBILITY IN THIS WAY
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT
I'M AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY YOU
WELL HERE NOW FROM. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION VIRGINIA
EARLY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS VIRGINIA EARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO ALSO ASKED WE WILL
CHECK IN MY LOUD ENOUGH. YEAH WE
CAN HEAR YOU TOO WELL SOME
MEASUREMENTS ARE- SYSTEM HERE
YOU SO MAYBE YOU CAN GET A
LITTLE CLOSER TO YOUR MIKE ALL
RIGHT. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME BETTER
NOW SAM THIS IS IT'S THE SAME I
THINK MAYBE IT MAYBE IT'S US. IS
THAT OUR SYSTEM IN. YES. THANK
THAT THINGS OPEN UP THERE.
ALCHEMY CLIMATE IS THAT. THE
YOUNG ACTOR YOUNG AND AGILE. ON
THE TELEPHONE KEY. OKAY PLEASE
POLICY. GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT GOOD
YOUR BREAKING POINT ALL RIGHT SO
GOOD MORNING AGAIN EVERYONE
VIRGINIA EARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I WILL BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHT OUR SOME OF OUR
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR RECENT
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM INVESTMENTS I'M ALSO
BRIEFLY SHARE SOME COMMENTS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
SO IN TERMS OF THE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION FOR C. S. P. P.
EXPANSION AND THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR BUT WE ESTIMATE THIS WILL
ALLOW FOR ABOUT EIGHTY SIX
HUNDRED NEWS ST PRESCHOOL SLOTS
I WILL KNOW MORE AFTER WE'VE
RECEIVED THOSE APPLICATIONS BACK
APRIL SEVENTH AND SEE THE RATIO
BETWEEN PART AND FULL DAY
REQUEST FOR EXAMPLE WHEN YOU
LOOKED AT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET IMPLEMENTATION
THE LEGISLATURE ALLOCATED FUNDS
FOR ABOUT TWENTY NINE HUNDRED
FULL DAY SLOTS. BUT WHAT ENDED
UP BEING FUNDED WISE ABOUT
THIRTEEN HUNDRED FULL DAY SLOTS
AND ABOUT- FORTY THREE HUNDRED
PART DAY SLOTS ON RATES WE'RE
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT OUR
CONTRACTORS PROVIDING PRESCHOOL
AND EIGHTEEN OF OUR HIGHER COST
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES RECEIVED A
RATE INCREASE TO THE SEVENTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REGIONAL
MARKET RATE. ON JANUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR WE'RE ALSO ENTERING ON
THOSE RATE SUPPLEMENTS THAT I
MENTIONED ON OUR LAST PANEL
WHICH WE EXPECT TO GET US
TEMPORARILY. UP TO THE EIGHTY
FOURTH PERCENTILE. I WELL THE
RATE SOMETHING ARE. WE REALLY
LIKE TO SEE FUTURE INCREASES AND
OUR CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM RATE TO SUPPORT EQUITY
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM AND ALSO TO
BRING GREATER EQUITY BETWEEN THE
PRESCHOOL RIGHT. HANDS THE
INFANT TODDLER AND SCHOOL AGE
RATES SO FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE OF
PREVIOUS INVESTMENTS MADE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO TO THE INFANT
TODDLER RATE. I AND THOSE
ADJUSTMENT FACTORS UNDER OLD
RATE SYSTEM THE MAJORITY OF
INFANT TODDLER REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ALREADY EXCEEDED THE
SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE BEFORE
THE RECENT CHANGES. I DO HAVE
MORE COST INFORMATION FOR FUTURE
CHANGES IN FRONT OF ME AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THAT IT'S HELPFUL
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT THAT
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
MILLION NUMBER IS AN INCREASE TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. SO DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDS AS WELL. ON THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL I THE BUDGET PROPOSALS
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENTS AND INCLUSION ARE
SUPPORTING MULTILINGUAL LEARNERS
AND ENSURING STABILITY FOR
CHILDREN ENROLLED IN STATE
PRESCHOOL. ON INCLUSION THAT'S A
REALLY KEY ISSUE FOR US SINCE AS
WE LOOK AT THE DATA WE REALLY
LAG BEHIND OTHER STATE AND THE
NATION IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN. IN WHAT'S CALLED THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT
AND THAT'S WHERE CHILDREN ARE
ENROLLED. WITH DISABILITIES ARE
ENROLLED IN PROGRAMS IN
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS INSTEAD OF IN
A SPECIAL DAY CLASSROOMS- THAT'S
ONLY FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. SO IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE CALIFORNIA SERVED
UNDER 30% OF PRESCHOOLERS WITH
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION PLANS
OR IEPS. IN AN INCLUSIVE
STARTING. SO AS WE LOOK AT THE
RESEARCH IT REALLY SHOWS US THAT
WHEN WE SERVE CHILDREN WITH IEPS
IN INCLUSIVE SETTINGS THEY'LL
HAVE FEWER OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THE START WHEN THEY'RE NOT
SERVED IN INCLUSIVE SETTINGS.
THEY HAVE FEWER OPPORTUNITIES-
TO ACCESS GENERAL EDUCATION THEY
TEND TO REMAIN IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND THAT WHEN WE
INCREASED THAT PROPORTION OF
THEIR TIME SPENT AND GENERAL
EDUCATION. THAT IS A STRONG
PREDICTOR OF ACADEMIC GROWTH
IMPROVED OUTCOMES AND
INTENTIONALLY THIS SUPPORTS ALL
CHILDREN BOTH OF THOSE AND WITH
AND WITHOUT DISABILITIES. BUDGET
PROPOSAL STRATEGIES ARE REALLY
KEY FOR ADDRESSING THAT FULL
INCLUSION KEYS ARE IN PURPLE
PROVIDING SUPPORTS TO PROGRAMS
TO GET THEIR- SO WITH NEARLY
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND PRESCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN WITH IEPS IN
CALIFORNIA NOT SERVED IN AN
INCLUSIVE PROGRAM WE DO EXPECT
THAT STATE PRESCHOOL CONTRACTORS
WILL BE ABLE TO MEET THE 10%
REQUIREMENT. ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE GIVEN TIME IN SUPPORT TO
DO SO AS IS THE CASE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WE
REALLY THINK A KEY PART OF THIS
IS THOSE INVESTMENTS THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION PROGRAM OR KEEP. AS
WELL AS THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
INTERVENTION WHICH WILL SUPPORT
I'M NEEDING THAT TEN PERCENT. ON
THE EVE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE STATE PRESCHOOL BUT
THEY WOULD GREATLY BENEFIT FROM
SUPPORT PROVIDED THROUGH THE
PROGRAM SO WE DON'T MINOR
COMMENTS HERE WITH THE L. A. IN
FLAGGING THE NEED FOR FUNDS TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THIS COULD BE
DONE EITHER BY INCREASING THE
AMOUNT. OF FOR STATE LEVEL
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WILL SUPPORT ALL
PROGRAMS INCLUDING COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON WHAT THE NEED. IS THERE AND
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT.
UNDER OTHER STATE PRESCHOOL ON
THE OTHER STATE PRESCHOOL
PROPOSAL SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE THE ADJUSTMENT FACTOR
FOR DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AND
THE PROPOSAL AROUND TWENTY FOUR
MONTH ELIGIBILITY SINCE THAT
WILL PROVIDE STABILITY FOR
FAMILIES. OUT FOR TWO YEARS OF
HIGH QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
BEFORE KINDERGARTEN. I'M SERVING
A TWO YEAR OLD CHILDREN IN STATE
PRESCHOOL WE KNOW THAT WE DON'T
THINK THAT MANY WILL BE SERVED I
SINCE THEIR LAST PRIORITY UNDER
THE LANGUAGE. AND ONLY 13% OF
ELIGIBLE THREE YEAR OLDS IN
STATE ARE SERVED IN STATE
PRESCHOOL. ARE WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THOSE CHILDREN ARE IN
DEVELOPMENTALLY DIFFERENT PLACES
SO THEY'RE GONNA NEED DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT SUPPORT IN THE
CLASSROOM. THAT'S SOMETHING WE
WOULD NEED TO ADDRESS AT CD AND
R. REGULATIONS AS PART OF
IMPLEMENTATION HERE WE WOULD BE
WORKING WITH- ARE YOU UNIVERSAL
PREKINDERGARTEN. RESEARCH DESIGN
TEAM WHICH INCLUDES NATIONAL
EXPERTS TO LOOK AT WHAT WOULD BE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE HERE. BUT
EVEN WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR CURRENT
STANDARDS AROUND- RATIOS- ARE
THERE ARE THERE DIFFERENT NEEDS
THERE IS THE L. A. R. MENTIONED.
STILL GIVEN ALL OF THIS WE HEAR
FROM CONTRACTORS THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AN ADJUSTMENT FACTOR
FOR THESE CHILDREN TO COVER
THEIR ADDITIONAL COSTS. IN
CLOSING WE ALSO HEAR FROM THE
FIELD THAT THERE ARE SOME
STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO STATE
PRESCHOOL THAT WOULD STRENGTHEN
ITS BUILT ABILITY TO BE A STRONG
PARTNER. IN THE UNIVERSAL PRE
KINDERGARTEN SYSTEM AND THOSE
INCLUDING MAKING IT STATE
PRESCHOOL LICENSE EXEMPT
ALLEGATIONS FOR BOTH THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS. USING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE AS WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER REDUCING OR
REMOVING FAMILY FEES OF FOR
STATE PRESCHOOL TO PROBE TO
ENSURE FAMILY CHOICE AND EASE OF
ABILITY TO PARTNER BETWEEN. ALL
THE AS AND THEN FUNDING STATE
PRE SCHOOL BASED ON ENROLLMENT
RATHER THAN ATTENDANCE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE.
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE TULARE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY
NAME'S ERIC SONNENFELD WITH LAKE
COUNTY HOSTAGE CATION. I ALSO
SERVED AS A MEMBER ON THE RATE
REFORM METHODOLOGY WORKGROUP
THAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
DURING THE PRESENTATIONS AND
ALSO REPRESENTING EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA. HANK YOU FOR THE
OCT THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS-
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF EARLY LEARNING CARE
IN OUR STATE AS A CRUCIAL- HI.
SUPPORT TO ARE NOT ONLY ARE
WORKING FAMILIES BUT THE
YOUNGEST AMONG US. AND I WANT TO
POINT OUT A COUPLE THINGS THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN- HIGHLIGHTED
EARLIER TODAY. BUT FOR THE CFP
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY FOURTEEN
OUT OF THE SIXTY FIVE COUNTY
SERVICE AREAS WHICH IS 62% DID
NOT. RECEIVE RATE REFORM RELIEF
. IN THE STATE FISCAL PROGRAM AS
OF JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. TO THE SHIFT FROM THE S. R.
ARCH OF THE REGIONAL MARKET
RIGHT. THE CAN SERVICE AREAS
THAT DID. INCREASE THAT INCREASE
RANGED FROM 68% A MERE 2%
ILLUSTRATES THE ONGOING WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND THE IN
EQUITY ACROSS THE STATE AND ITS
ABILITY TO ENSURE QUALITY
SERVICES AND RETAIN QUALITY
STAFF IN A VERY COMPETITIVE JOB
MARKET CORRECT LET'S THAT THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION MENTION
WILL ASSIST HOWEVER IF THEY ARE
ALLOCATED UNITS UTILIZING THE
SAME METHODOLOGY WILL MAKE THIS
INEQUITY STATEWIDE EVEN WORSE.
THE DRESS THE TO YOUR PROPOSAL
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS- PUT FORTH
THERE IS CONCERN RELATED TO THE
RATIO REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
YOUNGER LEARNERS AND THE FUNDING
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THESE EFFORTS. YOU JUST FACTOR-
THIRTY WOULD BE NEEDED EITHER IN
REGULATION OR LAW TO ENSURE
THAT. THE FUNDS ARE THERE TO
SUPPORT AGENCIES. TO PURSUE THIS
AS AN AVENUE OF SERVICE MODEL
DELIVERY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONAL ONGOING TRAINING AND
SUPPORT FOR THE CURRENT STATE
THE SCHOOL WORKFORCE TO ADDRESS
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF YOUNGER
CHILDREN. AND MANY OTHER CASE
MAY OR MAY NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE
THESE CHILDREN DUE TO- EXISTING
LABOR AGREEMENTS. TO SPECIFIC
ETHNIC GROUPS SO THAT WOULD ALSO
NEED TO BE POTENTIALLY ADDRESS
AS WELL. REGARDING THE SPECIAL
NEEDS PROPOSAL THAT IS NOT AS
CLEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. WE APPRECIATE
THE 10% SET ASIDE TO SERVE
CHILDREN SPECIAL NEEDS. AND
JUSTIN FACTOR OF TWO POINT FOUR
FOR STATE FISCAL CONTRACTED TO
SERVE THOSE CHILDREN. AT THE
HEAD START GRANTEE MYSELF AS MY
IN MY AGENCY IT WILL. THAT WILL
START TO CLOSE THE GAP TO SERVE
OUR SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN IN
STATE PRESCHOOL. BUT I WILL
REMIND THE PANEL AND EVERYONE
WHO IS LISTENING THAT STAFF WILL
NEED NOT JUST ONE TIME TRAINING.
BUT CONTINUED AND ONGOING
TRAINING AS EASY OR EASY
WORKFORCE WILL BE TRANSITIONING.
THROUGH THE IMPACT OF THE G.
CARE ROLLOUT THE IMPACT OF
COMPETITIVE LABOR. MARKET AND
THE JUST GENERAL TURNOVER THAT
THE EARLY EDUCATION FIELD
EXPERIENCES. ARE CURRENTLY. KIND
OF SITUATIONS COULD BE AN AVENUE
TO LINK THE- SERVICE THAT SETS
FOR ME BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
SERVE CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS TO PROVIDE THAT ADDITIONAL
TRICKS- TRAINING AND SUPPORT
ONGOING. NOT JUST ONE TIME. AND
FINALLY- SPECIFIC ASKS EXTEND
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISIONS AND
FLEXIBILITY GRANTED TO DIRECT
SERVICE CONTRACTING AGENCIES AND
PROVIDERS DURING THE ENDEMIC
INTO FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. CONTINUE TO WAIVER
OF FAMILY FEEDS INTO TO IT'S
CLEAR TWENTY FIVE THREE AND THE
BACK FILLING TO THE CONTRACTING
AGENCIES AND PROVIDERS. ALSO TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL RATE INCREASES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THOSE FORTY
KEVIN SERVICE AREAS THAT DID NOT
BENEFIT FROM THE ALIGNMENT OF
THE S. R. ARTS THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE EFFECTIVE JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TRYING TWO. STATE
PROGRAMS CANNOT WAIT UNTIL THE
RATE REFORM WORK GROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS. IF THE STATE
WANTS YES COULD BE CONTRACTORS
TO BE A CONTINUED VIABLE PARTNER
THE ROLL OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MASTER PLANNED FOR EARLY
LEARNING AND TO PROVIDE
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL TO ALL.
ELIGIBLE FOR ENTRY ROLE. THANK
YOU UNPAYABLE QUESTION. OKAY
THANK YOU WILL HAVE A FEW ON
THIS ALSO ALL START OUT WITH I
KNOW LAST YEAR CENTER WE MOAN
AND THE NUMBER OF US WORK ON THE
COMPANION BILL TO THE UNIVERSAL
TKA WITH THIS SB ONE FIFTY TO
REVISE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY IN
THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT. AND SAID
HE'D COME BACK WITH PROPOSALS
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WHICH THEY
DO- THE ONE THAT'S NOT THERE IS
THE ODD THAT THE TODDLER RATES
IN THE STANDARDS FOR TWO YEAR
OLDS IN PRESCHOOL I WANTED TO
ASK. BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN CDP TO TALK ABOUT
THIS LET'S START WITH DEPARTMENT
OF. OF- EDUCATION ACTUALLY. AND
AND AS WE LOOK ABOUT WE HEARD
FROM THE EARLIER SPEAKERS AND-
AND THE FIELD IN THE CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO FOUR
YEAR OLD SO- WHAT COULD WE DO TO
BETTER. ALIGN OUR POLICIES TO
PRIORITIZE AND FURTHER INCREASE.
THE RATE STRUCTURES FOUR. ZERO
THREE THREE YEAR OLDS. THANK YOU
VIRGINIA EARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO IN TERMS OF SERVING
OUR CHILDREN THAT ARE TWO YEAR
OLDS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM LIKE LIKE I
DID MENTION- WE DO HEAR A LOT
ABOUT THE NEED OF. THAT HAVING
AN A JOB SOME TYPE OF ADJUSTMENT
FACTOR HIGHER RATE FOR THOSE
CHILDREN. BECAUSE AS THE L. A.
O. MENTION THEIR DIFFERENT
RATIOS THAT CURRENTLY APPLY SO
SPECIFICALLY- UNDER OUR CURRENT
REGULATIONS PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SERVING CHILDREN EIGHTEEN TO
THIRTY SIX MONTHS ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE ONE ADULT FOR EVERY FOUR
CHILDREN. AND THEN IT BUT ONE
TEACHER FOR EVERY SIXTEEN
CHILDREN AND THAT'S DIFFERENT
FROM THE RATIOS WE HAVE. UP FOR
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS WHERE
IT'S ONE ADULT FOR EVERY EIGHT
CHILDREN AND ONE TEACHER FOR
EVERY TWENTY FOUR CHILDREN SO
WHEN YOU ADD AN EXTRA JOLT AND
YOU ADD AN EXTRA TEACHERS IN
THOSE SMALLER SIZES. BUT THAT
DOES CREATE EXTRA COSTS FOR
PROGRAMS- THIS COULD BE
ADDRESSED IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH- THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION- AS YOU WORK
THROUGH- AT THAT THESE PROPOSALS
GOING FORWARD. HE SO
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WHAT WHAT
WOULD WE NEED- AS FAR AS THA
RATE ADJUSTMENT FOR ZERO THREE
THREE IF YOU HEAR THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR FROM SOME OF THE
EARLIER SPEAKERS IN THE FIELD-
ABOUT THE CONCERNS FOR THE YOU
KNOW RATIOS AND- AND JUST NOT
ADEQUATE. REIMBURSEMENT RATES I
KNOW YOU'D GIVE US A NUMBER FOR
WHAT THAT- THE NINETY PERCENT.
REGIONAL MARKET RATE FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL WOULD BE THIS IS
ANOTHER PIECE OF THIS WHOLE
GREAT. PIECE FINISHING THE JOB
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT TO
INCREASE FOR ZERO THREE THREE.
TO MAKE THESE PROGRAMS VIABLE.
YOU KNOW PAID LIVING WAGES AND
THEN THE YOU KNOW TIÞN TO WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH UNIVERSAL
ACCESS FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS WHICH
IS THE NEXT OF COURSE THE
GENOCIDE IN WHICH IS LAW IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ADJUSTMENT FACTORS THAT ARE
OPERATIONAL FOR THIS AGE GROUP-
FOR THE PROGRAMS FOR THE GENERAL
CHILD CARE PROGRAM THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
OPERATE. OUR CHILDREN IN THIS
AGE GROUP THAT THIS THIS TWO
YEAR OLD AGE GROUP ARE GETTING A
ONE POINT EIGHT ADJUSTMENT
FACTOR. SO SO THAT WOULD SORT OF
BRING THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM SERVING- SERVING TWO
pCOMPARABILITY WITH WHAT THE
ACCESS IS PROVIDING. OKAY THANK
YOU AGAIN THIS IS JUSTIN YOU
KNOW YOU'RE A PRIORITY FOR. THE
ASSEMBLY AND WILL LIKELY
ADDRESSES THAT ARE. THE PROPOSAL
IN THE COMING MONTHS. QUESTIONS
ON A FRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. OKAY SEEING
NINE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
FOR SAKE PROCEED NOW WITH ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR THAT IS UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
IMPLEMENTATION IN JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL SPOKE HERE FROM. PHILLY
AND THE FIRST. WE ARE FROM LA-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN AND
APARTMENT OF ED AND THEN A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. L. A.
M. REPORTER ALLELES I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO GET TO DISCUSS THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACTIONS- A
REVIEW OF THOSE I'M SO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
AGREEMENT SPECIFIED TO SCHEDULE
TO GRADUALLY EXPAND TO CATCH ALL
FOUR YEAR OLD BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX I'M THE BUDGET
PACKAGE ALSO INCLUDES-
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES IT JUST
SETS CLASSIFIES REQUIREMENT THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS MAINTAIN AN AVERAGE TWO
CAMERAMEN OF NO MORE THAN TWENTY
FOUR STUDENTS EACH SCHOOL SITE-
ON THERE ARE ALSO SEVERAL ONE
TIME I'M ENGAGED TO SUPPORT
EXPANSION SPECIFICALLY FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY MILLION. NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND- FOR SCHOOLS TO CONSTRUCT
RENOVATE I'M STATE PRESCHOOL TKM
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOMS
TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO THE-
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT TO
SUPPORT I'M PRETTY STATE
PRESCHOOL TAKING EXTENSION FOR A
VARIETY OF PURPOSES- YOU CAN USE
FUNDS FOR WRITING PURPOSES SUCH
AS RECRUITMENT. TRAINING AND
MATERIALS. ONE HUNDRED MILLION
PROPPING COMPETITIVE GRANTS FOR
ELLIE A- TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF. ALL I'M STATE PRETTY TO
KEEP. AND THEN TEN MILLION ON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND UPDATE. ON THE CALIFORNIA
PRESCHOOL LEARNING FOUNDATIONS.
WITH REGARD TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE PROPOSED BUDGET
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
AT THIS TIME I'M AND WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE PREVENTION
CALCULATIONS ARE IN LINE WITH
WHAT WE WOULD HAVE. EXPECTED
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
I'M AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
LEANING GRANT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS- I'LL BE
PRESENTING WITH WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EXPANSION AS WELL
AS THE ADULT TO STUDENT- ADULT
TO STUDENT RATIO REDUCTION
PROPOSAL SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A REVENGE OF THE
TEST ONE PERCENTAGE OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE ESTIMATED
INCREASED COST OF ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS SERVED IN TRADITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AS A RESULT OF THE
EXPANSION THAT WAS APPROVED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET. AT
BUDGET ACT FOR A TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THIS EXPANSION IS
CURRENTLY ESTIMATED AT SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE MILLION
AND AS A REMINDER IT REFLECTS
OPENING TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TO ALL CHILDREN
TURNING FIVE BETWEEN SEPTEMBER
SECOND AND FEBRUARY SECOND%
RATHER THAN SEPTEMBER SECOND IS
DECEMBER SECOND. BEGINNING WITH
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL YEAR. WELL THAT'S NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED THE
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH PAST
PRACTICE TO ADJUST THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
CALCULATIONS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
FOR THE MOVEMENT. AND FUNDING OF
PROGRAMS WITHIN OR OUTSIDE THE
GUARANTEED RELATIVE TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN LEVELS.
IN ADDITION TO THE INCREASED L.
C. F. F. FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
EXPANDING TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES A SEPARATE
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FORTY
K. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
TO HELP LEDS REDUCE ADULT
STUDENT RATIOS TWO ONE TO TWELVE
PER TKA CLASSROOM THAT'S
PURSUANT TO STATUTE- AND THIS
CONCLUDES MY BRIEF PRESENTATION-
MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS BERGSON IS
ALSO ON THE LINE AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE A QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SERO SERO NEVER
MORGAN DEPARTMENT OF AN- GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THERE AN APPLE MARKET ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE HISTORIC INVESTMENT BEGAN
LAST YEAR IN UNIVERSAL PRE
KINDERGARTEN FOR U. P. K. AND
CONTINUED WITH THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT THE FIRST YEAR AND FORTY
K. EXPANSION AND REDUCING THE
ADULT CHILD RATIOS IN TKA. TO
SUPPORT THIS HISTORIC INVESTMENT
IN DECEMBER CVD RELEASED A
TEMPLATE FOR ELEAZAR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO USE IN
THEIR U. P. K. PLANNING THE
TEMPLATE COVERS BASIC COHERENCE.
AND UNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
PARTNERSHIPS WORKFORCE
RECRUITMENT AND PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING CURRICULUM INSTRUCTION
ASSESSMENT FACILITY SERVICES AN
OPERATION THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
LOT WHEN YOU'RE IMPLEMENTING THE
PK. IN FEBRUARY WE ALSO RELEASED
NINETY FIVE PAGES OF GUIDANCE TO
SUPPORT AND LIAISE CHARGED WITH
DEVELOPING PLANS FOR EXPANDING
U. P. K. WHICH ARE DUE TO THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNING BOARDS OR BODIES
FOR THEIR CONSIDERATION BY JUNE
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR. FIFTY
EIGHTY PLANS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE THIS MONTH.
TO DEVELOP BUT THE TEMPLATE AND
THE GUIDANCE TO SUPPORT ELEAZAR
IN THERE AT THE U. K.
IMPLEMENTATION PLANNING THIS CD
EIGHT DEVELOP A COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS TO ENGAGE WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS COUNTY PARTNERS
AND LOCAL IMPLEMENTORS A BIG
THANK YOU TO ALL OF US WHO
HELPED. US WITH THE TEMPLATE AND
GUIDANCE. THIS PROCESS HOW THE
C. INSURE THE TEMP AND COMPING
IS RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL NEEDS AND
SUPPORTS IMPLEMENTORS TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING RESOURCES AND
CREATE NEWPARTNERSHIPS TO
ADDRESS BARRIERS TO
IMPLEMENTATION. WE'VE ALSO
HOSTED MULTIPLE U. P. K. AND P.
THREE WEBINARS SWITCHING OVER A
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS WITH EACH
. AS PART OF THIS WE'VE BEEN
EMPHASIZING TO LIAISE THE
IMPORTANT IMPORTANCE OF PROTEIN
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTNER UTK IN A U. K.
FRAME. WHERE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING OUR STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM HEAD START OTHER PRIVATE
OKAY AND- EXPANDED LEARNING
PROVIDE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WITH A TRULY UNIVERSAL AND
INCLUSIVE ACCESS. TO A FULL DAY
OF BOTH RICH AND JOYFUL
LEARNING. AND IF NEEDED XTENDED
LEARNING CARE. YOU BEAT IT
PROVIDES US WITH THE TRULY
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO THE
PICNIC IT LAKS MANTA WE ARE
SERVING AS A STATE. AS WE LOOK
AT THE DATA FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THERE WERE OVER AND
MILLION THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD
CHILDREN BUT LESS THAN A THIRD
OF THEM IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
ACCESS TO EITHER PUBLIC PRE K.
OR SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE. WE
ALSO FIND THE CALIFORNIA LACKS
THE LICENSED CAPACITY TO MEET
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES NEED WITH
JUST UNDER EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND LICENSE SPACES FOR
CHILDREN FROM BIRTH TO AGE
TWELVE. DEFINITELY NOT ENOUGH TO
SUPPORT THE DEMANDS FOR NON
PARENTAL CARE. WHEN WE LOOK MORE
DEEPLY AT THE S. P. P.
SPECIFICALLY WE KNOW THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN ELIGIBLE THAT ARE
ENROLLED IS VERY LOW IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. STATE PRESCHOOL
HAD FORTY THOUSAND ENROLLED
THREE YEAR OLD CHILDREN OUT OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ELIGIBLE THREE YEAR OLDS. THAT'S
ONLY 13% OF ELIGIBLE THREE YEAR
OLD SIR. I'M GOING TO SAY THAT
AGAIN ONLY 13% OF ELIGIBLE THREE
YEAR OLD CHILDREN WERE SERVED
AND THAT REPRESENTS 8% OF ALL
THREE YEAR OLDS IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR FOUR YEAR OLD CHILDREN OUR
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM SERVE
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED IN TWO
THOUSAND OUT OF THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN ELIGIBLE OR. 32%
OF ELIGIBLE FOUR YEAR OLDS. EVEN
IF FOR YEAR OLD SIR IN OUR
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM PROGRAM MOVING
FORWARD AND ALL OF THOSE CURRENT
A HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND
SPACES WENT INSTEAD TO ELIGIBLE
THREE YEAR OLDS. THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE THREE YEAR
OLD CHILDREN THREE IRON THREE
THOUSAND WAS MORE THAN TWICE THE
TOTAL OF STATE PRESCHOOL
ENROLLMENT FOR THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS. WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO IN SERVING THOSE ELIGIBLE. U.
P. K. PROVIDES AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLD CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY PRE K. THE YEAR BEFORE
KINDERGARTEN. AND TO THE EXTENT
FAMILIES WHO PREVIOUSLY WOULD
HAVE ENROLLED THEIR CHILDREN AND
OTHER STATE AND FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAMS CHOOSE TKA. THAT MEANS
WE CAN INCREASE THIS YEAR THREE
YEAR OLD CHILDREN SERVED IN OUR
PROGRAMS AND POTENTIALLY EVEN TO
YOUR OLD CHILDREN. CALIFORNIA IS
NOWHERE NEAR CLOSE TO SERVING
ALL AS A LITTLE PRESCHOOLERS AND
HIGH QUALITY PRE K. EXPERIENCE.
IN THIS INVESTMENT IN A GETS US
MUCH CLOSER. TO FURTHER THIS
DENTIST SERVING CHILDREN WE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED ELEAZAR TO
PLAN FOR HOW THEY WILL BE
CREATING MORE CAPACITY I'M NOT
CREE QUE RATHER THAN MOVING
CHILDREN FROM ONE PROGRAM TO
ANOTHER. AND WE THINK THE
FACILITY FUNDS FROM LAST YEAR
THAT WENT TO THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION ALONG
WITH ANY YOUR FACILITY
INVESTMENTS ARE KEY TO THIS
EFFORT.BECAUSE THE
IMPLEMENTATION REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT PLANNING TO BUILD
OUT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR U. P. K.
SUCH AS THE TEACHER PIPELINE AND
FACILITIES WE ARE FRAMING OUR
CURRENT EFFORTS AS AN INITIAL
PLAN. AND ARE EXPECTING ELEAZAR
TO MAKE UPDATES OVER THE ISSUE
HERE IS THEY DIVE DEEPER INTO
YOU PK AND DEVELOP A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR ON GOING
IMPLEMENTATION ME. WE'VE ALSO
BEEN HARD AT WORK TO RELEASE THE
FUNDS TO SUPPORT U. P. K.
EXPANSION. WE RELEASED THE
ESTIMATES FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION U. P. K. PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS IN
DECEMBER. AND REVISE THIS
RECENTLY WITH SOME UPDATED DATA
THOSE ARE GOING OUT THROUGH THE
APPORTIONMENT PROCESS. SECOND AB
RECENTLY RECEIVED FOUR HUNDRED
ELIGIBLE LETTERS OF INTENT FOR
THE A HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
EARLY EDUCATION TEACHER
DEVELOPMENT GRANT. AND WILL BE
REALLY THINK THAT REQUEST FOR
APPLICATION SHORTLY. AS WE LOOK
TO THE NEXT YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION WE KNOW HOW
CRITICAL WILL BE BASED ON THE
RESEARCH TO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
ADULT IN THE CLASSROOM WE WERE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT INVESTMENT
IN IMPLEMENTING LAST YEAR'S
VICTORY- AGREEMENT. RESEARCH
SUPPORTS THAT MAINTAINING
APPROPRIATE TEACHER CHILD RATIOS
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN
GREATLY IMPACTS THE ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF
STUDENTS. FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW
FROM RESEARCH THAT LOWER STAFF
CHILD RATIOS TEND TO BE LESS
STRESSFUL FOR TEACHERS WHICH CAN
LEAD TO A MORE EMOTIONALLY
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR
CHILDREN. SECOND LOWER STAFF
CHILD RATIOS ALLOW FOR MORE
EFFECTIVE USE OF SMALL GROUP
INSTRUCTION WHICH CAN INCREASE
CHILDREN'S OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENGAGE IN MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION.
AND LASTLY LOWERS STAFF CHILD
RATIOS HAVE CONSISTENTLY AND
POSITIVELY RELATED TO MEASURES
OF CLASSROOM QUALITY. NINETEEN
AN ADDITIONAL ADULT IN THE
TICKET CLASSROOM WE ALSO BE A
CRITICAL STRATEGY FOR ELLIE A
PARTNERSHIPS WITH STATE
PRESCHOOL AS WELL AS FOR
SUPPORTING INTERNET AND
RESIDENCY BASED TEACHER PIPELINE
SOLUTION. DISTAFF T. K. WITH
FULLY QUALIFIED TEACHERS IN OUT
YEARS. AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
STABILIZE THE STAFFING SHORTAGES
EXACERBATED BY COOK AT NINETEEN
WE WOULD RECOMMEND REQUIREMENTS
TO ENSURE ALL ADULTS WORKING IN
U. P. K. HAS SPECIFIC EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND CHILD
DEVELOPMENT UNITS AS WELL AS
ONGOING PD. FINALLY WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE ALLEY ACE THAT WHILE
THEY FULLY SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF TKA IN IMPLEMENTATION OF U.
P. K. THEY COULD USE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND A FEW KEY AREAS THAT
POTENTIALLY IMPACT THE FEAST AND
REPROACH. INCLUDING WORKING ON
THEIR DIVERSE TEACHER PIPELINE
STAFF ADEQUATE STAFFING TEEKAY
AND OTHER GREAT. THIS INCLUDES
WAYS TO ADDRESS KEY THREE ARE
PRE K. TO THIRD GRADE AND
PATHWAYS FOR THE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT. LUCKILY FOR
ALL OF US THE COMMISSION I
TEACHER CREDENTIALING UNDER
MERRY SANDY'S DIRECTION IS
ALREADY ENGAGED IN MAKING THIS
HAPPEN. WHERE THIS THERE IS ALL
A NEED TO WITH. PARK
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO ALSO CHANGE AND MORE QUICKLY
ADAPT AND SUPPORT COURSES AND
PATHWAYS. SEE MORE CREDENTIALED
AND PERMITTED TEACHERS EMPOWER
EDUCATORS. R. ELLIE IS ALSO HAVE
FACILITY NEEDS INCLUDING
PLAYGROUND BATHROOMS PARKING AND
TRANSPORTATION AND FINALLY
FINALLY AS HAVE EXPRESSED THE
NEED TO DO FULL UTK EXPANSION
IMMEDIATELY IN ORDER TO HAVE
ENOUGH STUDENTS TO CREATE A
CLASSROOM WHILE OTHERS HAVE
EXPRESSED THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE FACILITY AND TEACHER
PIPELINE. NEEDS THAT THEY CAN
NOT ACCOMPLISH THE QUICKLY THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO TESTIFIED TODAY AND I HAVE
SOME OF MY TEAM HERE IF THERE
ARE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. OKAY THINK YOU'LL
COME BACK TO YOU IN IN THE SACK
THAT WE NOW HAVE THE REPRESENTED
FROM LA A PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE MORNING CHURCH MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UNIVERSITY
KAITLYN TATIAN IT'S A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS FOR THIS
INVESTMENT AND I'M HUMBLED TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT HOW IT'S
GOING IN THE FRESNO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO PROVIDE YOU THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH THIS WORK IS OCCURRING
FRESNO UNIFIED HAS A STUDENT
POPULATION. OF SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE STUDENTS. 88% OF
OUR POPULATION ARE LIVING IN
DISADVANTAGED CIRCUMSTANCES.
FRESNO OPERATES FOLD ATK
CLASSROOMS AT SIXTY THREE OUT OF
SIXTY SIX ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS WE
PROVIDE WITH A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
AT FIFTY SEVEN SCHOOL SITES AND
SIX INFANTS TO SCHOOL AGE CENTER
BASED CHILD CARE CENTERS. OUR
SUPERINTENDENT AND BOARD PAST
AND PRESENT ARE FULLY ENGAGED
AND INVESTED IN OUR EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS AS A STRATEGY
TO HELP CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP WHAT YOU. CAN BURKE. YOU CAN
TELL FROM OUR DATA IT'S CRUCIAL
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT. MUCH
WORK HAS BEEN DONE IN OUR
DISTRICT TO DEVELOP A STRONG
CONTINUUM OF LEARNING FOR
CHILDREN THIS WORK INCLUDES A
ROBUST AN INTENTIONAL FOCUS OF
RESOURCES IN CROSS SECTOR WORK
ADMINISTRATOR EFFECTIVENESS.
EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS
INSTRUCTIONAL TOOLS LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS IT DRIVEN
IMPROVEMENT AND ENGAGING
FAMILIES. AND IN FACT WE ARE
BRINGING KHRISTICH OURS HERE TO
HELP US AUDIT HOW WE'RE DOING IN
THOSE AT FIRST. THROUGH GRANTS
FROM THE DAVID AND LUCILE
PACKARD FOUNDATION AND AN EARLY
EDGE WE'VE HAD THE OCCASION TO
TEST AND LEARN USING INNOVATIVE
PRACTICES IN THE THIRTY FIVE
SPACE OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
INCLUDING OUR LOCAL RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCY CHILDREN
SERVICES NETWORK. AND START
FRESNO COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS DEVELOP STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS IN EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
YOUNG TO LEARN LANGUAGE LEARNERS
FROM INFANTS THROUGH PRESCHOOL.
THESE PARTNERSHIPS ARE GROUNDED
IN THE BELIEF THAT THE
COLLECTIVE COMMUNITY WE CAN MAKE
A DIFFERENCE. THE FOCUS ON EARLY
LEARNING HAS CEDED THE GROUND-
FOR UNIVERSAL T. K. LIMITATION
AND FRESNO. AND THOUGH WE ARE
POINTING. THE CHICKENS
PRACTICALLY NOTHING MAKING TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH INCREASING
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN ZERO TO
FIVE. WE KNOW THAT WE CANNOT
LOOK AT TJ SEPARATE FROM INFANTS
TO THREE YEAR OLDS AND
KINDERGARTEN TO THIRD GRADE WITH
THAT IN MIND WE'VE BEEN PLANNING
FOR UTK WITHIN THE BROADER WORK
ABOUT BIRTH TO THIRD GRADE
SYSTEM. UTK OFFERS A NEW OPENING
FOR SERVING MORE CHILDREN IN
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THE
DIFFERENCE THE STARTING EARLIER
PROVIDING TWO YEARS OF QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS HAS A
GREATER IMPACT ON LONG TERM
SUCCESS.THE OTHERS HAVE SPOKEN
TODAY IT SYSTEM CHANGE DOES NOT
COME WITHOUT CHALLENGES. THERE
HAVE BEEN DEEP CONVERSATIONS
AROUND FACILITY CHALLENGES.
THESE CHALLENGES CAN BE OVERCOME
HOWEVER. THERE ARE CONCERNS
ESPECIALLY COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC WITH COMPETING NEEDS
FOR CLASSROOM SPACES STUDENTS
ARE COMING BACK TO SCHOOL WITH
ADDITIONAL SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
CHALLENGES AND THERE IS A NEED
TO PROVIDE SPACES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT THAT'S COOL WE
APPRECIATE THE FACILITY FOR
COMING SOON HOWEVER THE NEED IS
HIGHER THAN THE FUNDS PROVIDED
CONSTRUCTION COST IS VERY HIGH
RIGHT NOW. AND THE COST OF
MODULAR SYNTH DOUBLED TO SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
WILL TAKE SIX TO TEN MINUTES TO
OBTAIN WE KNOW THAT
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
PRACTICE CALLS FOR APPROPRIATE
SETTINGS WE NEED AN INFUSION OF
DOLLARS TO HELP DISTRICTS
CONSTRUCT RENOVATE OR PURCHASE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
FACILITIES WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE IN YOUR DOLLARS DO NOT ARE
US FROM PURCHASING PORTABLE OR
MODULAR. TO MEET THE NEEDS
SOCIAL. YOUR SOCIAL AND- PRO PRO
PROGRAM AND EARLY LEARNING PRO.
AS PART OF OUR RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION EFFORTS IN THE WORK
FORCE WE ARE FACING CHALLENGES
IN MEETING THE AUGUST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE DEADLINE
FOR CREDENTIALED TEACHERS TO
OBTAIN THEIR TWENTY FOUR YOU SEE
UNITS. FUNDS OR GRANTS FOR
TEACHERS TO PAY THOSE UNITS FOR
FAKE PAY FOR THOSE UNITS AND
FLEXIBILITY ON AUGUST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE DEADLINE
IF NEEDED. AS YOU HEARD
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS. ALWAYS TOP
FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE ESPECIALLY
FACING CHALLENGES IT'S ME WITH
EXTREME. IN THE NEED TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL INTERNET CREDENTIAL WE
DO HAVE PARTNERSHIPS WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR INTERN PROGRAMS.
BUT WE NEED ADDITIONAL TIME TO
BUILD PARTNERSHIPS WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION BOTH AT THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEVEL SPECIFIC TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. WITH ARE
YOU TAKE A IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
DO IN JUST A FEW MONTHS IT WILL
pBE CHALLENGING TO GET THE
MESSAGE TO ALL COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE SERVING MORE YOUNGER CHILDREN
HOWEVER IT WILL NOT BE A LOSS TO
ANY PROGRAM. WILL BE A BENEFIT
FOR CHILDREN. I WAS SO EXCITED
TO HEAR ABOUT THAT I TRIPLE E.
P. EXPANSION FOR MS LIEBERMAN.
THIS IS A HIGH NEED AREA IN IN
WITH EVERY DISTRICT.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND I.
TRIPOLI P. GRANT FOR INCLUSION
HAS HELPED FRESNO UNIFIED MOVED
FROM ONE INCLUDES ADDING THE
SIXTEEN IN TWO SHORT YEARS. THIS
IS BEEN A HUGE LIFT DURING A
PANDEMIC AND AS A SHIFT FOR OUR
EDUCATORS. AS A STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
PRACTICE THERE IS A CONCERN
AROUND BOTH CURRICULUM AND
ASSESSMENT. TEEKAY WITH MISCHIEF
BASED ON THE BELIEF THAT
KINDERGARTEN IS NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS OF YOUNGER CHILDREN. IN A
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
APPROACH AND NOW IT'S TO
CONSERVING EVEN YOUNGER CHILDREN
THE NEED FOR GUIDANCE ON
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
CURRICULUM AND ASSESSMENT IS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IS
NEEDED FOR EDUCATORS TEACHERS.
THEIR SYSTEMS AND SITE
ADMINISTRATORS FRESNO UNIFIED.
HAS DEVELOPED AN EARLY LEARNING
PRINCIPLE ACADEMY UTILIZING
FIRST FIVE GRANT FUNDING BUT WE
WERE NOT UNABLE TO CONTINUE THAT
WORK WITHOUT FUNDING. AS WE
CONTINUE. TO DEVELOP A COHESIVE
PRESCHOOL TO THIRD GRADE I TOLD
WITH THEM. IT WOULD ALSO BE
HELPFUL FOR PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS TO HELP FLEXIBILITY
IN THE C. S. P. P. STATUTE ON
ENROLLMENT. PARENTS HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN PRE REGISTERING THEIR
TEACHING CANDOR AGE SCHOOL
CHILDREN WE BEGAN EARLY THIS
YEAR TO GET A BETTER PROJECTION
FOR TEEKAY THIS COMING SCHOOL
YEAR PRESCHOOL PARENTS COULD NOT
BEGIN THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS.
UNTIL LATER BECAUSE OF STATUTE
AROUND CERTIFICATION. THIS
CAUSES FRUSTRATION IN Q. AND
CONFUSION FOR PARENTS. IT DID
NOT TAKE IT FOR WHEN ROLL
PRESCHOOL CHILDREN BUT ALSO FOR
HARDSHIP FOR PARENTS BUT THAT
MAY BE ASKING TOO MUCH OF YOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU AND AGAIN. WE APPRECIATE
THIS HISTORIC LEGISLATION AND
INVESTMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
I'LL NOW TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS ALL HAVE SOME BUT FIRST
WE'LL TURN TO OUR MAJORITY
LEADER ASSEMBLY MEMBER S. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO BEGIN
BY. THANKING YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK. TO MAKE
THIS DREAM COME TRUE OF
UNIVERSAL. TEEKAY IT WAS A LONG
TIME IN THE MAKING AND PLANNING
AND I SINCERELY APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOUR WORK ON THAT AND YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE DETAILS MAKING
SURE THAT WE TOOK CARE. OF ALL
OF OUR FOUR YEAR OLDS- I BUT I
DO HAVE A QUESTION I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE STATISTICS
THAT ARE BEING SHARED- THE ONLY
FOUR HUNDRED ELEAZAR SUBMITTED
LETTERS OF INTENT FOR THIS
TEACHER PREPARATION. ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE A HUNDRED MILLION THAT IS
BEING THAT IS BEING PROVIDED FOR
THAT. AND I WANT TO BE SURE THAT
ARE ELLIE AS- I FEEL THAT THEY
DO HAVE THE CAPACITY AND CAN
CONTINUE TO APPLY AND MAYBE WE
NEED TO PROVIDE FOR SOME
FUNDING. IN THE OUT YEARS AFTER
THE PANDEMIC THE STATE PLANNING
FUNDS- SPECIFICALLY ALLOW
ELEAZAR TO PARTNER WITH SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY BASED PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS. SO MY QUESTION IS R.
ELLIE AS WORKING AND PLANNING.
FOR THIS UNIVERSITY K. WITH OUR
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS. DID YOU
WANT THAT CALIFORNIA. YES. SORRY
IT WAS THE THING WE KNOW WOULD
PROBABLY GO TO ME YES THEY ARE
NEVER MARKING CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AT THE
AS FAR AS WE KNOW I'M IT'S A MIX
SO THERE'S A LOT GOING ON RIGHT
NOW IN EDUCATION AS YOU ALL KNOW
AND JUST LIKE THE SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
CHILD CARE WORLD OUR TEACHERS
OUR ADMINISTRATORS ARE DEALING
WITH A LOT OF VARIOUS NEEDS
INCLUDING RISK CONTINUING TO
RESPOND TO THE STATUS THAT THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SO WITH
THAT PLANNING THEY HAVE ALL BEEN
VERY ENGAGED IN OUR WEBINARS
THEY HAVE THEIR DIVING INTO THE
GUIDANCE THERE'S A LOT THERE AND
SOME OF THEM HAVE ALREADY
STARTED THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY
MEETINGS AND PLANNING WE ALSO
KNOW THAT COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WHO ALSO ARE RECEIVING
FUNDS FOR THIS ARE GETTING
TOGETHER AND SUPPORTING THEIR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN SOME
OF THAT PLANNING WE DID HAVE A
RECENTWEBINAR I THINK IT WAS
TWO WEEKS AGO AT THAT ADDRESS
THE COMMUNITY PLANNING PIECE. OF
THE GUIDANCE AS A WAY TO MAKE
SURE WE WERE SHARING VERBALLY
NOT JUST WITH THE WRITTEN
GUIDANCE WHAT NEEDED TO HAPPEN
AND HOW THEY COULD MOVE FORWARD
WE ARE ALSO PARTYING WITH THAT
AND CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE ON
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE AS WELL
AS THEY COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING. FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN ACROSS THE STATE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I COULDN'T AS WE
MOVE FORWARD I DO WANT TO SEE
WHAT IT IS THAT THE- STATE CAN
DO. TO HELP SUPPORT OUR
PRESCHOOL SYSTEMS AS THEY ADAPT
TO OUR TRANSITION TO UTK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WANNA FOLLOW UP
ON THOSE QUESTIONS FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES SANTIAGO LIAISING
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER- SERRA
FROM CD ABOUT. SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN FLEXIBILITY AND I KNOW IF
YEARS AGO WEEKLY- ADDED A CLAUSE
INTO THE STATE LAW ALLOWED
DISTRICTS TO EXPAND T. K. AND
THEN ROLL STUDENTS EARLIER THAN
THEY WERE ELIGIBLE TECHNICALLY
BUT THEY'D HAVE TO ESSENTIALLY.
EAT THE MONEY UNTIL THAT KID
TURNED FIVE AND THAT YOU KNOW LA
IN A BUNCH OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE UTILIZED THAT AS
WE ROLL OUT. TEEKAY AND OF
COURSE IT'S NOT EVEN LAW UNTIL
JULY ONE SOME DISTRICTS LIKE SAN
DIEGO WE'VE HEARD IS GOING ALL
IN. THEY'RE GOING TO STATE THAT
THEY THINK IT'S EASIER TO JUST
DO IT ALL AT ONCE- DO WE NEED TO
ADDRESS- FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW
DISTRICTS TO COLLECT. EIGHTY
EIGHT EARLIER TO ALLOW SOME WHO
WANT TO DO EARLY ADOPTION. OR IS
HOW WE LAID OUT LAST YEAR
SUFFICIENT. I THINK IT'S THEIR
NOVEL MORGAN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WE HAVE
HEARD FROM SOME OF OUR AND WE AS
SPECIALLY THOSE ARE PEARL
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY COULD USE
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN UP A FULL CLASSROOM NOW.
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT AND
ME AND WOULD NEED THAT IT DOES
EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDS TO BE PART OF
THAT AT THE SAME TIME WE'VE
HEARD FROM SOME OTHER DISTRICTS
ESPECIALLY SOME LARGER ONES THAT
THEY MIGHT NEED MORE TIME. TO
ADDRESS THE FAITH THEN BECAUSE
OF THE IMPACT ON THEIR
FACILITIES AND TRYING TO BUILD
THAT WORK FORCE OUT I THINK
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL OF OUR
ALLEY AS- SAME THING IS IN THE
CHILD CARE WORLD THAT THE
TEACHER EDUCATOR PIPELINE.
CONTINUES TO NEED SUPPORT AND
WHILE IT MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A LOT
TO EVERYBODY ELSE WE THOUGHT
FOUR HUNDRED LETTERS OF INTENT
WAS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT. AND-
I'LL OF THOSE- COMING TOGETHER
AS THE CONSORTIUMS THAT WE HAVE
SOME FROM COUNTY OFFICES OF BAD
WITH THEIR THAN PULLING TOGETHER
AND SUPPORTING OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WE WILL NOTE THAT
EDUCATOR PIPELINE HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE FOR A WHILE NOW IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT THE CODE
NINETEEN DEFINITELY HAS
EXACERBATED THE AMOUNT OF
TEACHERS THAT HAVE LEFT THIS
FIELD AND ONLY GROWN HOW MANY
MORE TEACHERS AND OTHER STAFF
ARE NEEDED TO COME IN. SO
ENSURING THAT THERE ARE ON GOING
SUPPORT. AND DIFFERENT PIPELINES
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN IS ALWAYS A
CRITICAL PART OF THAT. SOME OF
THAT MAY BE A CAPACITY ISSUE AS
WELL SO GOING BACK TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACIST COMMENT WE
DO THINK THAT IT IS HARD FOR
SOME ELEAZAR AND OTHERS TO
ACTUALLY APPLY FOR FRIENDS
BECAUSE OF THE ALL THE COMPETING
CAPACITY NEEDS. AND WOULD ALSO
LOOK TO OTHER WAYS TO SUPPORT
THEM. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THOSE
THAT ARE JOINING TOGETHER IS THE
CONSORTIUM TO HELP ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CAPACITY ISSUES. SO IT
IS. IT IS THAT A YES OR NO THAT
WE NEED TO. TO CHANGE THE LAW TO
ALLOW. EIGHTY TWO DISTRICTS TO
START COLLECTING EIGHTY EIGHT
MEDIALLY. WE WOULD RECOMMENDS
THAT SCHOOLS DISTRICTS ARE READY
WOULD BE ABLE TO COLLECT EIGHTY
EIGHT FOR THOSE STUDENTS AS WELL
AND WE ALSO I WANT TO FLAG AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE HEARD THAT
SOMEONE TO SERVE CHILDREN WITH
SUMMER BIRTHDATE AND THE JULY
FIRST TO SEPTEMBER FIRST
BIRTHDAYS AREN'T COVERED IN
STATUE INTO FULL IMPLEMENTATION
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. BUDGET OKAY. BURKE SHERMAN
APARTMENT YEAH. YEAH CHRIS
FERGUSON WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WOULD JUST YOU KNOW
NOTE TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INTERESTED IN
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR AT
THE GAMES TO CLAIM ADDITIONAL
ADA FOR THOSE COHORTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY PLANNED FOR FUTURE
YEARS THERE WOULD BE GENERAL
FUND IMPACT BECAUSE IT WOULD NOT
CHANGE THE B. BENCH AND- FIFTY
EIGHT WOULD. CHANGE THE
RETENTION SCHEDULE SO THAT WOULD
BE GENERAL FUND IMPACT. YEAH
THAT SHOULD BE A LONG TERM ISSUE
BECAUSE EVENTUALLY THEY'RE GOING
TO BE THERE ANYWAY THAT YOU KNOW
. GETTING THAT. BIG BOWLING BALL
THROUGH THE STAKE AT DIFFERENT.
TIME I WOULD CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH YOU I THAT YOU KNOW IN THE
LONG TERM WE WOULD ULTIMATELY
GET THERE BUT THERE WOULD BE AN
ADDITIONAL COST IN THE
INTERVENING YEARS THE PUT UP
WOULD BE SCHEDULED INTO THE
GUARANTEE IS PART THAT REVENGE.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU I KNOW I
KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
HEAR A LOT THAT- THE YOU'RE
MAKING THESE GREAT CHANGES IN
EARLY EDUCATION WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF PANDEMIC CHANGE IS
HARD AND I UNDERSTAND THAT AND
SO- YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE RECORDED AS BEST AS WE
CAN OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
PROVIDE MAXIMUM OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SUCCESS- ALSO KNOW WE HAVE
WORK TO DO IN THIS ZERO THREE
THREE SPACE AS WE NOTED EARLIER.
BUT THIS IS- THAT AN ABSOLUTES-
PRIORITY AND YOU KNOW I THINK A
GAME CHANGER FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
AS THAT SERRA NUMBER MORGAN
FILTERED EARLIER THERE ARE A LOT
OF KIDS ON WAITING LISTS TO
DON'T HAVE ELIGIBILITY AND THE
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
FAMILIES WHO MAYBE THEY CAN PAY
FOR IT NOW BUT YOU KNOW RENT IS
SO HIGH COSTS ARE SO HIGH
INFLATION AND EVERYTHING ELSE
GAS PRICES IT'S- HARD TO PAY.
BETWEEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED ON THE
LOW END AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
HERE AND SOME OF THAT SOME OF
THE URBAN MORE HIGH COST AREAS
RIGHT CALIFORNIA PER MONTH. FOR
PRE K. FOR FOUR YEAR OLD MAN WHO
CAN AFFORD THAT YOU KNOW. IT'S
MORE THAN IT COST TO GO TO UC
BERKELEY. TO GO TO A- PRIVATE
PRESCHOOL SO THIS IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT COULD HELP-
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES AND AGAIN.
YOU KNOW. ALL THE MONEY THAT WE
CURRENTLY SPEND FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS. I THINK IF WE SPENT THAT
TO HELP MORE. OF HIGH QUALITY
EARLY AT BEFORE PRE K. BUT I
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT JUST-
SOMETHING WE CAN SAY WE NEED TO
PUT. OUR RESOURCES AND OUR YOU
KNOW THE WEIGHT OF OUR STATE
BUDGET OUR POLICY BEHIND THAT SO
WE'RE WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING.
JUST THAT A QUESTION ON MORE TO
THAT THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
T. K. AND THE FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES- YOU KNOW THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT I HEAR LOUD AND CLEAR
WHEN I TALKED TO- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ENTITIES ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION AS WORKFORCE. AND
FACILITIES SO CAN WE ASK- CD
AND- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
LEYVA WHOEVER WANTS TO ANSWER OR
EVEN THE FRESNO- UNIFIED FOLKS.
ABOUT THE MONEY WE PUT IN FOR
YOU TAKE A FACILITIES AND IS
THAT ENOUGH TO NEED TO DO MORE
WHAT ELSE WE NEED TO DO ON THIS
FRONT. LISA SILVERMAN ON THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE OFFICE
OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
AND- THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY. AT WHAT WE HAVE- FOR
WITH A FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION. OF THE STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD DID ANNOUNCED TWO FUNDING
ROUNDS SO JUST TO PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE THAT OF THE FIRST
FAMILY AROUND WILL BEGIN IN
APRIL FIRST OF THIS YEAR AND
CLOSE APRIL THIRTITH OF THIS
YEAR. AND THEY'LL BE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE. FOR THE PURPOSE. AND
SO THAT EXTENT- THAT WILL BE THE
FIRST FAMILY AROUND. AND THEN WE
ALSO TO ESTABLISH THAT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO
ARE NOT READY TO SUBMIT THEIR
APPLICATION FOR THE SITE EXTEND
THE PROGRAM. ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO FILE. FOR PROGRAM FUNDS OUT
OF THE REMAINING FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION- THAT THEY WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY ON APRIL
FIRST. OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
AND THAT. ALSO CLOSE ON APRIL
THIRTIETH SO AGAIN. WE'RE
FORWARD TO HAVE A- ROBUST
PROGRAM FOR THE FOR BALLING
AROUND AND OUT THIS. WE
NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT THE NEED
IS SO- IF IT'S COMPARED TO THE
LAST- PROGRAM WE HAD FOR THE
HUNDRED MILLION. YES WE WOULD
DEFINITELY OVERSUBSCRIBED I'M SO
WE DEFINITELY WILL. KEEP TRACK
OF ALL THE OPTIONS. THAT COME
THROUGH THE DOOR AND BE ABLE TO
SHARE THAT WITH THE FUTURE. NOW
AGAIN REMIND ME IS THERE ARE
THERE IS THERE A MATCH
REQUIREMENT HERE THIS IS JUST
100% WELL IT'S BASED ON SOME
ELIGIBILITY- COMPONENT SO IF YOU
ARE A DISTRICT- THAT HATCH
DEMONSTRATES A FINANCIAL
PURCHASE. YOU ESTABLISH FIFTY
POINTS OR HIGHER CRITERIA. AND
IT IS ALSO BASED ON A FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH SO YOU COULD. JUST
YOU COULD RECEIVE UP TO A
HUNDRED PERCENT. OF THE PROJECT
FUNDED- AND THEN THERE'S ALSO
THE- OTHER MATCH YOUR
REQUIREMENTS- IF YOU DON'T MEET
THAT THRESHOLD AND- THERE IS A-
COULD BE A FIFTY FIFTY MATCH.
WHEN IT COMES TO- EXTEND YOUR
FULL THEY CAN- PROGRAM. AND
THERE'S ALSO A CITY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE MATCH. FOR THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND PRESCHOOL- AS
WELL AS A FOR A FULL DAY PROGRAM
SO. AGAIN IF VERY- DEPENDING ON
THE TYPE OF PROGRAM AND THE- THE
CRITERIA WHICH THE- DISTRICT.
ITSELF SO WE SENSUALLY FLAX THIS
SO IT'S FULL DAY. KINDERGARTEN
IN E. U. T. K. AS ONE. DO WE-
AND I KNOW YOU WERE. IN THAT
JUST ABOUT READY TO GIVE OUT.
THE FIRST ROUND OF TWO YEARS OF-
THAT. AWARDS DO WE SEE THAT THE
MAJORITY IS YOU T. HER FULL DAY
CAN. WHAT THE MAX. WELL AT THIS
TIME THE FAMILY AROUND OPEN
APRIL SO WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS YET- SO THE STATE
OCCASION BOARD THE STAFF THE
FINE ROUND SO WILL MORE IN. IN
THE UPCOMING MONTHS AND THE
GROUND THAT'S CLOSE SO WE'LL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CORRECT. BASED
UPON OUR KNOWLEDGE FROM THE- WE
HAD THAT CHUNK OF MY FOR FULL
DAY. KINDERGARTEN AND THERE
WASN'T MUCH OF AN APPETITE SO I
ASSUME THAT THAT. THAT THE FOCUS
HERE WILL BE- THE UNIVERSITY K.
FACILITIES. WELL THEY- SORRY WAS
PRIOR PROGRAM WITH THE PRIOR
PROGRAM WAS ONLY FOR FULL THAT
CAN I'M SO WE DIDN'T USE THAT
LIFE DOESN'T TAKE COMP ANALYSIS
THAT. I WILL BE NEEDED AS MUCH
AND SO THE YOU TO WILL BE THE
PRIMARY. WHICH- I THINK MAKES
SENSE BASED BASED ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA OVER
HEARING. CAN I ASK. YES THIS IS
DEANNA MATHIS FROM FRESNO
UNIFIED- WE ARE PROJECTING TO
NEED ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL CLASSROOMS THROUGHOUT
THE FOUR YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION
. YEAH AND I ARE THOSE
ADDITIONAL CLASSROOMS ARE SOME
OF THOSE CONVERSION FIVE YEAR
CLASSROOMS AT SITES WHERE YOU
HAVE DECLINING ENROLLMENT AND
UNDER UTILIZED CLASSROOMS. I'M
EITHER ADDITIONAL CLASSROOMS AND
WHILE WE HAVE NOT A MOMENT-
THERE ARE MORE SUPPORTS NEEDED
AT SCHOOL SITES SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORTS AND ASK THOSE PEOPLE GO
TO SCHOOL SITES THEY NEED ROOMS
TO DO THE WORK. SO IT'S SORT OF
A COMPETITION OVER FACILITIES
BUT IT IS AN AREA OF DEEP
DISCUSSION. OKAY CAN WE SWITCH
NOW TO TALK ABOUT- THE ISSUE OF
THE WORK FORCE IN TEACHERS AND
PROFESSIONALS. WE ASK SERRA
DOUBLE MORGAN PROVIDE ANY
INSIGHT ON FOR THE L. A. O. OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHAT WE
NEED TO DO ON THIS FRONT TO HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH STAFFING
NEEDS. AND GRANTED THIS IS NOT
IMMEDIATE FOR THIS YEAR- OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS. WHO WANTS TO
ANSWER. THAT NUMBER MARKING
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I'M HAPPY TO START IT
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE MERRY'S
THING INDEED THAT DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING HERE AS
WELL SHE IS FAR MORE OF AN
EXPERT IN ALL OF THIS THEN I AM
SO ALSO HAPPY TO TAG HER INTO MY
PHONE A FRIEND SAID THAT SHE CAN
ADDRESS MORE OF IT. BUT WE HEAR
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT NEEDS FROM
OUR ELEAZAR AND OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS. AROUND
NEEDING MORE. HI MORE SUPPORT.
AND NOT STUDY STREAM OF HIGHLY
QUALIFIED EDUCATORS AND AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN MY
TESTIMONY THIS IS SPEND
SOMETHING THAT HAD SPEND ISSUE
IN CALIFORNIA FOR QUITE AWHILE.
WE HAVE HAD A LACK OF DIVERSE
TEACHERS AND ENSURING THAT THE
TEACHERS REALLY REPRESENT THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED
MORE BILINGUAL TEACHERS WHO CAN
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE MULTI
LINGUAL PROGRAMS. AND WE NEED
MORE TEACHERS WHO CAN SUPPORT
OUR CHILDREN STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. SO NOW WITH THIS
WILL NEED MORE TKA TEACHERS WHO
BOTH HAVE THAT TEACHER
CREDENTIAL AS WELL AS TRULY
UNDERSTAND DEVELOPMENT AND HOW
TO SUPPORT PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN. IN THE ALLEY A STUDY
SO THAT CREATES ANOTHER NEED ON
THERE AND WE WOULD STAY AS THEY
EXPANDED T. K. WE'RE HOPING THAT
MORE OF THEM. NOT ONLY ARE
DIVERSE BUT ARE BILINGUAL SO WE
CAN EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
BILINGUAL PROGRAMS STARTING IN
STATE PRESCHOOL AND T. K. AND
THEN ALSO CAN SUPPORT INCLUSION
SO HAVE THAT GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF WORKING WITH
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. IN
THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET THERE
WERE SEVERAL INVESTMENTS
INCLUDING IN OUR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
WHERE YOU CAN HAVE PATHWAYS WERE
CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS CAN
ADDRESS THE NEEDS AND ACTUALLY
HAVE DUAL ENROLLMENT. THERE WERE
ALSO PLANS TO ADDRESS TEACHER
RESIDENCIES. AND I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT THE REQUEST FOR FUNDING
APPLICATIONS ON THAT HAS CLOSED-
IS STILL OPEN BUT THAT REALLY IS
A GROW YOUR OWN. AND A VERY MUCH
NEEDED MODEL BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TALKED QUITE
A BIT ABOUT IS THAT NEED TO
SPARK OUR INSTITUTES OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AS WELL. BECAUSE THESE
PATHWAYS HAVE TO BE CREATED
PRETTY QUICKLY AND THE. TYPICAL
PROP. HIGHER EDUCATION CAN TAKE
IT LEAST TWO YEARS TO GET
THROUGH NEW COURSE SAYS AND-
COURSE CORRECTIONS ALL OF THOSE
PIECES THAT WE ACTUALLY NEED TO
HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY. IN ORDER TO
EXPAND AND TRULY CAPITALIZE BOTH
ON OUR TEACHERS WHO HAVE A CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT. AS WELL AS
OUR TEACHERS WHO ALREADY HAVE A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL AS WELL
THIRD CREATING A WHOLE NEW WORK
FORCE SO I WOULD TAPPED MARY WHO
WOULD ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO SHARE
MORE WITH YOU THAN I CAN OKAY
THANK YOU. AND MERRY AS AS
YOU'RE GEARING UP SUGGEST
ENLIGHTEN US WITH SOLUTIONS WE
KNOW PROBLEMS AND WHERE THEY CAN
MAKE. WE TRY TO BE THE SOLUTION
ENTITY HERE SO. HELP US HELP YOU
. I AM VERY HAPPY TO ADD TO FILL
THOSE SHOES FOR YOU ON THIS
RECORDED. IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU A SERRA- THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU SAID SUCH A GREAT STAGE
FOR ALL OF THIS- WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW OF BUILDING A
NEW A RETOOLING AND EXISTING
EARLY CHILDHOOD SPECIALIST
CREDENTIAL IT WILL BE
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO SERVE.
CHILDREN AGES THREE TO EIGHT
THROUGH SO PRESCHOOL THROUGH
THIRD GRADE WE EXPECT TO HAVE
THE COMMISSION TAKE ACTION ON
THIS CREDENTIAL AND DO STANDARDS
FOR PREPARATION LEADING TO THAT
CREDENTIAL AS EARLY AS JUNE OF
THIS YEAR THAT'S OUR GOAL AND
THEN WE'LL GO THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS I'VE- OUR OUR
HOPE IS THAT THIS PATHWAY WILL
WILL WILL WILL CREATE MULTIPLE
ACCESSIBLE. ROUTES FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE CURRENTLY WORKING IN THE
FIELD EITHER AS A MULTIPLE
SUBJECT TEACHER OR AS A CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT HOLDERS
SERVING IN THE STATE PRESCHOOL
OR ELSEWHERE- TO EXPEDITE THEIR
OF THE COMPLETION OF A PROGRAM
THAT LEADS TO THIS CREDENTIAL WE
WOULD HOPE TO SEE ENROLLMENT IN
PROGRAMS BEGINNING AS EARLY AS
NEXT YEAR FOUR. FOUR EIGHT
INSTITUTIONS THAT I THINK ARE
VERY EAGER TO BEGIN OFFERING
THIS PATHWAY WERE FOR THE FUTURE
SECOND SHORTER TERM IN THE
IMMEDIATE TERM THE ONLY
POTENTIAL THAT IS AUTHORIZED TO
SERVE IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN IS A MULTIPLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL AND ACCORDING
TO THE APPORTIONMENT FUNDING
PROVISIONS THAT MULTIPLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL HOLDER NEEDS TO HAVE
TWENTY FOUR UNITS FOUR
INEQUIVALENT. AS DETERMINED BY
THEIR EMPLOYER FOUR I HOLDING A
CHILD DEVELOPMENT PERMIT THAT IS
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS
PREPARING THEM FOR THAT- SO THIS
IS THE CHALLENGE THAT IS BEFORE
US AND IN THE IN THE ABSENCE OF
ADEQUATE NUMBERS OF MULTIPLE
SUBJECT TEACHERS WHO WOULD
REQUIREMENTS THERE ARE OTHER
STAFFING OPTIONS AVAILABLE
INTERN PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE WORKING TOWARD A CREDENTIAL.
PROVISIONAL INTERN. PERMITS
SHORT TERM STAFF BIG PERMITS WE
- LOOK MOVEMENT OPTIONS ALL OF
THE OPTION ARE OF. TO FOR
IMMEDIATE STAFF NEEDS AND- WHO
IS THAT THE WHO BE A WILL OF
THEMSELVES OF THE- OPTIONS AS
THE MENU TO- WHILE WE'RE
BUILDING. OTHER THE WORK FOR
THAT THAT WILL. A READY SERVE
THE SPACE- IN TERMS OF THE
TWENTY FOUR WE HEARD LAST WEEK
IN THE SENATE BUDGET HEARING
FROM PLASTER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND THEY HAVE A-
STRATEGY WHERE THEY ARE PLACING
ALL OF THE OR INVITING ALL OF
THEIR MULTIPLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL HOLDERS. WITH AN
INTEREST IN THIS TO- PARTICIPATE
AS A COHORT. OTHER PARTNERING
WITH THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LOCALLY. TO PUT TOGETHER A
PROGRAM THAT ENABLES THEIR
MULTIPLE SUBJECT TEACHERS TO
MEET THE TWENTY FOUR UNIT
REQUIREMENT AND GET THEMSELVES
REALLY ON TRACK TO SERVE IN
THESE CLASSROOMS. WE THINK THE
KIND OF STRATEGY IS BRILLIANT
CANNOT BE REPLICATED ACROSS
ACROSS THE STATE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE OFFERING. OF THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PREPARATION FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD SPACE AND
THEY'RE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
RESOURCE. GOING FORWARD AS WE AS
WE RETOOL AND. UPSCALE OUR- THE
- FOR MOLD SUBJECT. ESTARÁ MAY
ALL THE HER. THAT WE HAVE A VERY
RIGHT NOW OUR A REALLY IDEA
SUITED TO HELP. A LOCAL SCHOOL
NEXT DISTRICTS GROWTH HER OWN ON
FUTURE WORK FORCE THE RESIDENCY
FUNDING. IN FACT I THINK IS
IDEALLY SUITED FOR. TEEKAY
CLASSROOMS IN PARTICULAR AS WE
THINK ABOUT. THE SECOND ADULT IN
THE CLASSROOM. GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILD PERMIT
HOLDERS WHO ARE SEEKING A
CREDENTIAL THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO BE THE LEAD TEACHER IN THAT
CLASSROOM. A RESIDENTS THE
PERFECT PLACE FOR THEM TO
DEVELOP THOSE SKILLS INTO SPEND
THAT YEAR WITH HER COOPERATING
TEACHER AND EARN THE CREDENTIAL
TO BECOME PART OF THE WORKFORCE
THAT'S THAT'S GROWING. OF FOR
THOSE WHO NEED TO EARN A
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE BEFORE THEY
CAN MOVE FORWARD TOWARDS
CREDENTIALING THE CLASSICAL
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM GRANT IS
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT 88 DEGREES
HOLDERS AS THEY COMPLETED DEGREE
CREDENTIAL. SO WE'VE GOT SOME
VERY IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE GRANTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT OF PEOPLE MOVING INTO
AND THROUGH THE PIPELINE AND
CREDENTIAL OPTIONS ON THE
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE FOR THE
SHORT TERM AND ON DECK- COMING
VERY SOON. TO ENABLE AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD SPECIALIST CREDENTIAL
WE HOPE TO BECOME OF THE
PREDOMINANT WAY IN WHICH WE
STAFF CLASSROOMS. FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. I
LOOK THIS IS OF SOME HELP. OKAY
THANK YOU IT IS AND I KNOW THERE
ARE NO. YOU KNOW EASY SIMPLE
SOLUTIONS AND COURSE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE LOWEST HANGING
FRUIT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
HEARING IN A FEW WEEKS ON THE
OVERALL TEACHER PIPELINE ISSUE
SO. WE'LL CERTAINLY- DIG INTO
THIS A BIT MORE. I THINK THE-
ALL FOR ME NO OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEND QUESTIONS RIGHT
NOW THIS NOW- PROCEED TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. AND THIS IS JUST AN
INFORMATIONAL ITEM WITH THE L.
A. AND DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO GO OVER. THE
TRANSITIONING OF THE CHILD CARE.
DEPARTMENT FOR- CVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
YES LA- TO PRESENT FIRST THANK
YOU HELLO. THEY'RE CORTES ELLIE-
I WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE A
SUMMARY OF ACTIONS RELATED TO
TRANSITIONING CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS AND THE CHILD AND THE
ADULT FOOD PROGRAM I FELT AN
ADULT WHO CARE PROTECT YOU FROM
CD- SO CASF BEGIN ADMINISTERING
THE STATE'S CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
AND THE CHILD AND ADULT CARE
PROGRAM BEGINNING JULY FIRST.
I'M OF MAY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET INCLUDE TO
MILLION FOR DFS TO PLAN FOR THE
TRANSITION THESE FUNDS WERE
PRIMARILY USED TO FUND STAFF AND
EQUIPMENT. ON THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PACKAGE
PROVIDED AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY
FOUR POSITIONS AND NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
CSS IS PART OF. THE TRANSITION.
ALTHOUGH EIGHTY THREE POSITIONS
AND TWELVE POINT SIX MILLION-
I'M TO BACK THE POSITION THAT
THE EDO INSURE THAT C. E. STILL
HAD SUFFICIENT STOCK
ADMINISTERED THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND THEN THE VARIOUS
WILL ATTRITION PERHAPS- THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. MY NAME AGAIN BEHIND
THEM MYLAN DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CHALK AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION THIS PART OF MY OPENING
STATEMENT FRIDAY- ON THE FIRST
START BY SAYING THAT ON JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO MANY
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS TRANSFERRED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
STREAMLINE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AND ALIGN IT WITH
THE WHOLE CHILD WHOLE FAMILY
SERVICE DELIVERY MODEL. CDSS
SUCCESSFULLY PROCESS PAYMENTS TO
CONTRACTORS AND ALL TRANSFER
PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE CONTINUITY OF SERVICE. WE
ALSO HONORED OUR COMMITMENT TO
ENSURE THAT NO FAMILIES
HEALTHCARE SERVICE WOULD BE
DISRUPTED DURING THIS TRANSFER.
THROUGH THE TRANSITION CDSS AND
CVD HAVE PRIORITIZED THE CENTRAL
IMPORTANCE OF ENGAGEMENT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS CESS HAS HOSTED.
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK SESSION
INCLUDING MONTHLY CONTRACTOR
MEETINGS MEETINGS BUT
CHARACTERIZATIONS AND PARTS
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS THAT
INCLUDE ABOUT A THOUSAND PLUS
PARTICIPANTS. WHICH WE'VE BEEN
HAD UPDATE OUR EXHIBITS HEALTH
BECAUSE OF THIS TO PROVIDE
UPDATES AND CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
FEEDBACK WE ALSO WELCOMED MCV
TRANSFERRING STAFF. TO CVS S.
YEAR'S BY AGREE I EIGHTY FIVE
POINTS PER TRANSFERRED WEST. AS
PART OF THE- PROCESS OF OUR
TRANSFERRED EMPLOY YES PROVIDE
CUTS FOR YOU. TRAINING AN
EMPLOYEE CAN SESSION TO ENSURE A
SMOOTH AND OF OUR TÍNH MÀ. WE
CAN TO WORK DILIGENTLY TO FILL
ALL EXISTING VACANT POSITIONS WE
CONTINUE TO ACCESS WORK LOAD AS
THE TRANSITION HAS COME TO FOR.
THREE CAN AND PROGRAM. IS
CURRENT. THIS IS CONDUCTED A
SERIES OF SIR FOR THE TRANSFER
AND- PRIOR TO THE TRANSITION IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND- THEN IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
TRANSITION IN JULY. AND THEN IN
NOVEMBER THE RESULTS FROM THE
RESULT FROM THE MOST RECENT
SURVEYS SHOW THAT 89% OF THE
TRANSFERRED STACKED OUT THAT
THEY HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF THEIR ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT CESS. IN
81% FELT THAT THERE WAS A
CULTURE OF TEAMWORK AND
COLLABORATION WITHIN THEIR TEAMS. AT CSS. I'M A BILLABLE CANCER
ANY QUESTION. DR JON CHIEF THAT
. DIRECTOR TROY WHAT JOIN ME AND
ANY AT THIS QUESTIONS. I DO NOT
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM YOU I
KNOW THIS IS CERTAINLY THE
TRANSITION IS A GROWING PAINS
AND- AND- WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR IT AND JUST YOU KNOW
FIRST AND THEN THE DAY THAT WE
HAVE- CONSTITUENTS FOR THIS AREA
YOU KNOW FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS
AND WORKERS WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO RIGHT. BY THEM AND
CONTINUE WITH OUR MISSION FOR A
CHILD CARE IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
ARE YOU KNOW ENGAGING IN
MONETARY. I KNOW OTHER ISSUES
FOR ME RIGHT NOW ON THIS- WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS I DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM HERE TO
PARTICIPATE OKAY WE HAVE TO YOU
CAN LINE UP. THAT'S ONE MINUTE
ARE LAST YOU CAN COME LINE UP AT
THE MIKE OVER HERE IN FOR
ANYBODY WANTS TO CALL IN AGAIN-
THE NUMBERS. 1-877-692-8957 THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN. ONE MINUTE
OR LESS PLEASE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE ABLE TO WORK
LIVE AND RAISE THEIR FAMILIES
WITH DIGNITY. MY NAME IS LAURIE
FURSTENFELD WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER. AT THE AGENDA NOTES
CURRENTLY THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET DOES NOT EXTEND PANDEMIC
REALLY FUNDING OUR POLICIES.
POLICIES HAVE BEEN THE LIFELINE
FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS TO
REMAIN OPEN AND SUPPORT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS. THIS IS
WHY WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ADOPT THE BUDGET THAT EXTENDS
THESE POLICIES SUCH AS WEAVING
FAMILY FEES THROUGH SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
AND PAYING PROVIDERS BASED ON
FAMILY CERTIFIED NEED RATHER
THAN ATTENDANCE WE ALSO URGE
ADOPTION OF THE BUDGET AGREEMENT
THAT INCREASES PROVIDER SUBSIDY
PAID TO ADJUST LIVING WAGE AND
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF VOUCHERS
AS OUTLINED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AGREEMENT. THESE POLICIES
ARE INTERDEPENDENT AND ADOPTING
THEM WILL SERVE ALL FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND BE INCLUSIVE FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR WHO ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMIC SYSTEM.
THESE BUDGET PRIORITIES ARE
OUTLINED IN THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION LETTER AND
THE FAMILY FEE BUDGET REQUEST
LETTER SIGNED BY OVER THREE
HUNDRED SUPPORTERS MAINLY
PARENTS AND CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. EVERY CHILD
DESERVES TO THRIVE IN A LOVING
NURTURING ENVIRONMENT MY NAME IS
KARINA LIKE A WITH A CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER WE SUPPORT A UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR THREE OR
FOUR YEAR OLDS THAT IS TRULY
UNIVERSAL WHERE NO COST EARLY
EDUCATION IS OFFERED IN A
VARIETY OF SETTINGS THAT MEANS
THE CHILD'S DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS
WHETHER IT BE A FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOME A CENTER OR SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAM. EACH CHILD AND
FAMILY HAS UNIQUE STRENGTHS AND
NEEDS THIS IS WHY CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG EMBRACED PARENT CHOICE
WHICH AIMS TO ENSURE FAMILIES
HAVE AS MANY AFFORDABLE EASY E.
OPTIONS AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT A
CHILD CARE VOUCHER A SCHOOL
BASED SETTING IS CURRENTLY THE
ONLY NO COST CHOICE FOR PARENTS
BUT LOW TO MIDDLE INCOMES FOR
THEIR FOR AND SOMETIMES TWO YEAR
OLDS A TRULY EQUITABLE PRESCHOOL
AND CHILD CARE PROGRAM MUST BE
INCLUSIVE OF ALL TYPES OF EASY
SETTINGS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO DAVE HAS BEEN WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING THANK YOU CHAIR FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ADOPT A
BUDGET THAT INCLUDES MIXED OF
EVERY CHILD CARE FUNDING. SO
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS CAN
PROVIDE. SERVICES AS DOES THE T.
K. PROGRAM. WE MUST BUILD UPON
LAST YEAR'S EXPANSION OF THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN SYSTEM
TO INCLUDE A SYSTEM THAT'S MORE
INCLUSIVE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
CHAO QUICK. CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
WITH THOUSANDS OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE WITH
THE EXPERTISE THE SPACE AND HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMMING TO SERVE
THOUSANDS OF FOUR YEAR OLDS
ACROSS THE STATE. WE ASK THAT
YOU BUILD A MORE ROBUST SYSTEM
THAT WORKS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY NOW
LET'S PROCEED TO THE-
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CALLING IN
HOW MANY SPEAKERS DO WE HAVE
MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
EIGHTEEN LINE UP. OKAY NINETEEN
LINES THANK YOU. FIRST WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY SIX GO AHEAD YEAH
AND MODERATOR AND SO THE
NINETEEN WHO ARE THAT CAN YOU
I'M CAP AT RIGHT THERE WE'RE NOT
GONNA TAKE ANY OTHER THAN THE
NINETEEN WE HAVE I HAVE TO WE
HAVE ANOTHER- HEARING IN THAT
MEETING TO GO TO. JUST AFTER
NOON THANK YOU. I MEAN COLDER. I
MEAN THE CAL. HEALTH PAYMENT PRO
IS. CENT. TO ALL THE SPEAKERS
TODAY AND FOR THE- FOR TOGETHER
A FIVE THE GENDER I'D LIKE TO
LOOK AT SOME OF THE KEY CARE DID
DAY IN AND DAY TO THE NEW GM.
WERE BEING OUTDATED WHEN
IMPLEMENTING COMMUNITY EIGHT ARE
OFFICE BEING MORE CURRENT
ENROLLED FAMILY LIVED ACCESS TO
THEIR EXISTING CARE. YOU COULD
BE ON FROM CLOSE HE RICK TO THE
FUNDING OF NEW CHILD CARE SLOTS
HI RE THE DEBT I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO RESPECT ASK THAT IT BE
REVISITED THE LACK OF FUNDING.
TO ACTUALLY COMMUNITY TO ENROLL
INCOME ELIGIBLE FAMILIES AND
PROVIDE THEM A SUBSIDY THAT THEY
CAN THEN GO AND SHOP FOR A CHILD
CARE PROVIDER TO ACCEPT THEIR
VOUCHER. SIMPLY FUNDING A LOT
BUT NOT THE PROCESS OF THE
FAMILY THROUGH THE SPOT WHAT
ALLOW YOU TO REALIZE YOUR TIME
IT'S ALSO CRITICAL TO SHOP THAT
AT THE CAN YOU BASED NON. AND
COUNTY ALL AT THE- THAT THAT WE
CAN DO FOR WITH A NEW COM
STARTED WHEN PROGRAM FOR HIS TO
THE- EIGHTY CAN DIRECT MEET WITH
. AND SUPPORT THIRTY THE OTHER
SENSE OF SUCH AS MENTAL AND FOOD
AMONG THE THAT. FINALLY HAD MY
TO LIFT UP. EIGHTY SIX FORTY
NINE FOUR NINE THE THIRTY TWENTY
TWO TWO. DATE I WILL PERMANENTLY
PROVIDE EFFECT GUARANTEED
REMEMBER ABOUT FOR THAT FAMILY.
FINALLY I'D LIKE FROM ARTS WITH
THAT OF THE COLLECTION THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU.
BETTER TO BE STOPPED TWENTY SIX
YEARS AGO AND WE'RE STILL
FIGHTING. WITH A CHILD CARE IT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK. AND SUPPORT MY TWO
CHILDREN. I WAS ON THE WAITING
LIST FOR INFANT CARE PUT TWO
YEARS AND I HAVE AND- MY
CHILDREN TO THEIR GRANDPARENTS
IN THE PHILIPPINES. WE
EVENTUALLY GOT CHILDCARE AND
THANKFUL FOR THAT. SO TODAY WE
SUPPORT THE THIRTY THOUSAND YOU
FLATTEN THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND TO CREATE
AN EQUITABLE SYSTEM. WAIT UNTIL
. TWENTY TWO FOUR MY LOOK AT THE
WITH THREE HUNDRED WHICH WAS
MORE THAN 20% OF MY TAKE HOME
PAY AT THE TIME. HE ALSO URGES
INCREASED INVESTMENT CREATES. UP
FOR OUR PROVIDERS TRUCKERS HAVE
PARITY WITH. IN REGARD AND PAY
RATES THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. NEXT BIG LINES EIGHTEEN.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
JESSICA FALCO CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW- I WOULD EMPTY
EMPATHIZED URGENT AND IMMEDIATE
NEED TO STABILIZE OUR FRAGILE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM AND WORK FORCE
NOW WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
ECONOMIST IN BUDGET ASK FOR AN
INCREASE IN CHILD CARE PROVIDER
WAGES AND COMPENSATION AWAITING
A FAMILY FEES AND INVESTMENT IN
CHILD CARE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT WE
NEED AMERICAN BUT BUT THE
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT FOR OUR
YOUNGEST KIDSACROSS EARLY
CHILDHOOD I CAN'T CARE PROVIDERS
AND WORKING PARENTS THE REAL
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS FUNDING. THE
POOL TO COST OF OPERATING CHILD
CARE WITHOUT A WHICH EXPANDING
CAPACITY WILL BE CHALLENGING TO
SUPPORT OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
NOW AND INVEST IN OUR KIDS AND
OUR FUTURE PLEASE FULLY FUND
CHILD CARE AND HELP STABILIZE
THE FIELD IN REGARDS TO ITEM
FOUR AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WE WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CLARIFY THE
CRITERIA FOR THE SECOND ADULT IN
THE CLASSROOM TO ENSURE THAT THE
PERSON HAS THE NECESSARY
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE TO
PROVIDE H. LINGUISTICALLY
CULTURALLY AND PEDAGOGICALLY
APPROPRIATE SUPPORT AND EDUCATE
CLASSROOMS. THE CURRENT
PROVISIONS ARE IMPRECISE AND DO
NOT. PROVIDE THAT PROTECTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE SEND THIRD. LINE. THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MOLLY BYNUM ON BEHALF OF P. W.
YOU WANT TO JUST LET THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE PROVIDER
MATTHEW VAUGHN COTTAGE AND ALIGN
MY COMMENTS AND HIGHLIGHT THE
JAIL AND SEE UPDATES PROVIDED BY
MY COLLEAGUE KEN ROSENBERG YEAH
YOU FAMILY CHILD CARE REMAINS TO
BE THE BACKBONE OF OUR STATE IN
THIS PART COULD HAVE BEEN MORE
CRUCIAL THAN IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS WE DO APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT IN THE WORK FORCE
THUS FAR BUT IT'S NO ONE'S FAULT
BUT SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH.
RESPECTFULLY WE WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PRIORITIZE
ADEQUATE HEALTHCARE RETIREMENT
PAID TIME OFF BENEFITS FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS THE
ONLY WAY TO PROPERLY SHOW OUR
APPRECIATION AND RESPECT FOR
THIS REQUEST. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT BAKER PLEASE. FIND.
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS UPDATE THE SENATE I
SERVED AS THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY AT CHILD THREE SIXTY AND
WE JOIN THE STATE WHAT YOU SEE
COALITION IN CALLING ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO READ
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
PROVIDERS DOING SO WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT EASY PROFESSIONALS
ARE PAID A FAIR WAGE WELL
DRESSED THE CURRENT STAFFING
SHORTAGE AMOUNT BETTER SUPPORTED
FIELD COMPRISED MOSTLY OF WOMEN
OF COLOR THAT HAS BEEN UNDER
COMPENSATED UNDER RESOURCE FOR
FAR TOO LONG. WE APPLAUD THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SECURING
CRITICAL RATE INCREASES IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET BUT WE NEED TO DO
MORE THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD ALSO
RESTORE AND EXPAND EASY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT
DOLLARS THAT WERE SWEPT IN
TWENTY TWENTY AT A TIME WHEN THE
ECB OTHER THINKING BACK IN
SHORTAGE WHICH HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THOUSANDS OF
CHILD CARE CLOSER DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND PERPETUATED BY
CHRONICALLY LOW WAGES BECAUSE
WORKFORCE DOLLARS ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT. HE WILL HELP EXPAND
EASY WORKFORCE AND SUPPORT
CURRENT EARLY EDUCATORS CHEATING
THEIR PROFESSIONAL ASPIRATIONS
THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT WEEK-
PLEASE. I CAN GO. LINE FORTY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE THAT MAYBE OF THE
RIVER FOR DELIBERATION ABOUT
EARLY LEARNING OBJECTIVES
INCLUDING UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN FIRST-
DISAPPOINTING OR ON BEHALF OF
THE EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIA FIRST
EARLY AND WANT TO ALIGN ITSELF
WITH THE ECB COALITION BUDGET
PRIORITIES THAT FOCUS ON MUCH
NEEDED PROVIDER RATE INCREASES
AS WELL AS CALLS ON LAWMAKERS TO
RESTORE THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WAS PREMATURELY BE FUNDED ON
TECHNICIAN OF THE BUDGET
SHORTFALL THAT NEVER
MATERIALIZED. WE BELIEVE THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE CRITICAL TO
SUPPORT OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND EARLY EDUCATORS WHO CAREFOR
OUR CHILDREN AND SERVE OUR
FAMILY EARLY AND ALSO APPRECIATE
THE POINT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENT TO ENSURE
THAT THE PATH LOCAL LOCATION
I'VE NEVER SPOKETO QUE
INCLUDING A CRITICAL QUALITY
INVESTMENT IN LOWER
CONCENTRATIONS WE BELIEVE THE
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
QUALITY PRE KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM
FOR ALL CHILDREN IS AMONG ONE OF
THE GREATEST INVESTMENTS WE CAN
MAKE THE BOMBS ON OUR FUTURE AT. THE STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK PLEASE. NINE THIRTY. I
HAVE MY MARK WITH TODAY GO-
KIDDING IS SUPPORT OF EASY BUT
YOU CALL THIS ACT FOR IN THE BUT
CHAO CARE FOR WAIT LEAVING A
FAMILY DOCTOR AND FOR STRUCTURE
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FRANCE
I'M WE ALSO THE ADMINISTRATION
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR INCREASES FOR
TO A LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
IT IS IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED TO INCREASE THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION ADJUSTMENT FACTOR
FROM 5% 210% TO ENSURE THAT
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO CULTIVATE
AND SUSTAIN AN INCLUSIVE AND
ANTI BIAS. LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
WE ALSO APPLAUD THE EXPANSION OF
THE REPORT THE TWO YEAR OLD
HOWEVER THE FAMILIES WE SERVE
ASKING FOR INFANT AND TODDLER
CARE SO PLEASE CONSIDER
EXPANDING. IT TO EIGHTEEN MARCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN EXPECT
YOUR PLACE. BY FORTY FOUR. THE
MORNING MICHELLE MCKAY UNDERWOOD
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION ON ISSUE THREE WE
SUPPORT MANY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS INCLUDING THE CREATION
OF PRESCHOOL ELIGIBILITY FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES.
RATE THE JACKET RIGHT FOR ALL
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
AND RETURNING 10% OF PRE
QUALIFIED FOR THESE YOUNG
LEARNERS. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
HIGH PRIORITY LEVEL GIVEN THE
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
AFTER THAT 10% I FILLED. HOWEVER
WE WOULD LIKE THE PRIORITY LEVEL
FOR PRESCHOOLERS WITH
DISABILITIES TO BE REGARDLESS.
OF INCOME LEVEL. FINALLY WE
SUPPORT THE ONE TIME FUNDS TO
INCREASE INCLUSIVE SETTINGS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
WE AGREE WITH THE ALLEY OF THE
FACT THAT NON LDA PROVIDERS AND
THEIR PRESCHOOLERS. WOULD
BENEFIT MORE GREATLY FROM THE
FUNDS SO THE STATE SHOULD
CONSIDER PROVIDING PRIORITY TO
THOSE GRANT APPLICANTS THAT WILL
SUPPORT NON L. GAVE BASED.
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEKEND TO THINK
. ONE FORTY EIGHT. STATE HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS BOYCOTTED
CALLING ON BEHALF OF KERN VOICES
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT THIRTY
THOUSAND CHILD CARE SLOTS BUT
THAT MUST HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME
TO REACH THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SO I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
YOU HAVE MADE CLEAR TODAY THEIR
SUPPORT TO BETTER COMPENSATE
PROVIDERS. ET FIELDS BEEN
DEVASTATED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
WITHOUT RAISING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE MORE
PROVIDERS ARE AT RISK OF
PERMANENTLY CLOSING IN AND MAKE
NO MISTAKE CONTENIDO COUNTY
WHERE I RESIDE 10% OF CENTER
BASED IN 5% OF FAMILY CHILD CARE
CENTERS ARE PERMANENTLY CLOSED
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT THE RACIAL AND GENDER
PAY GAP IN CALIFORNIA GET OUR
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE PER
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
pWAGES. FOR THE IFIELD 97% OF
WHOM ARE WOMEN IN THE MAJORITY
OF WHOM ARE WOMEN OF COLOR IT IS
CRITICAL THAT OUR NEXT BUDGET
RAISES THE REIMBURSEMENT TO
SUPPORT PROVIDERS WE ALSO WANT
TO EXTEND THE FAMILY THE WAIVER
UNTIL SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
COURT SINCE JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FAMILY COULD SAVE NEARLY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THANKS TO
THE WAIVER IT'S TIME WE STOP
SUBSIDIZING THE SYSTEM ON THE
BACK TO WORKING FAMILIES SHOULD
BE WAITING FAMILY P. THAT THE
CRITICAL ANTI POVERTY MEASURE.
SIMILAR TO THE EARNED INCOME AND
CHILD TAX CREDIT. AUTHOR OF
THESE. CLOUDS BREAKING. RATE AND
WAVE FAMILY HE TALKS TOGETHER TO
A MORE ECO. SYSTEM THANK YOU.
YOU CAN EXPECT YOUR PLAY. MY.
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
MORNING MISSIVE. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHAOS AND DALY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK. WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE ENTIRETY
OF THE ECOLOGIST BUDGET ASK
ESPECIALLY THE ELIMINATION OF
FAMILY FEET IF THE PEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND IMMEDIATE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT GIVEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S INABILITY
TO MAINTAIN THE MONTHLY CHILD
CARE TAX CREDIT REFUND WILL
PREVENT FURTHER CATASTROPHE FOR
FAMILIES WORKING SO HARD TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. FURTHERMORE THE
PROVIDERS TO CARE FOR THE
FAMILIES CHILDREN NEED TO BE
PAYING MORE AND WE CAN'T
IMMEDIATELY RAISE RATES BY 20%
WE ALSO FULLY ALIGNED WITH THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER COMMENTS
MADE AT THE TOP OF THIS COMMENT
SESSION. FINALLY OUR IN OUR
CONTINUE TO SHOW UP AND SHOW OUT
AND OUR STATE GO TO AND RELIABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE DURING DISASTERS
INCLUDING THE PANDEMIC. BUT OUR
IN OUR STAFF WERE OVERWHELMED
WITH ALL OF THE ACT THE DAM BUT
RECENTLY AND URGENTLY AND
DESERVEDLY DISTRIBUTING AT HOME
CALLED ATTACK. AND THE REQUIRED
DATA COLLECTION ON THAT
DISTRIBUTION. OUR IN OUR
STRUGGLE TO AFFORD THE STAFFING
CAPACITY TO DO WHAT YES THAT
NEEDS THEM TO DO IN ORDER TO
PROPEL FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. ARE
IN R. C. TO BE FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTED TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR STATE DEPARTMENT. I'VE COME
TO ENJOY AND EXPECT WITH
INCREASED. I'M GOING FUNDING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NICK BAKER
PLEASE. LINE. FORTY NINE. HELLO
MY NAME IS LI MARC CAN I AM A
MEMBER PARA VOICES EXECUTIVE
COMMON PACKAGE. TO FITZGERALD
GREATER WITH THE NINETEEN A FIVE
YEAR OLD AND CREAKY SEVEN YEARS
AGO WITH THE WORKING
PROFESSIONAL HOMEOWNER READY TO
START MY OWN FAMILY BUT LITTLE
DID I KNOW THAT I WAS GOING TO
HAVE ABOUT WHAT COULD HAPPEN ANY
HUGE CALL ALTHOUGH I CAN'T MY
PURSE AND I WAS STILL NOT WHEN I
BECAME PREGNANT ELEVEN MONTHS
LATER WITH MY DAUGHTER BUT IT
WAS INTRACTABLE TOOK CAN
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE. FOR TWO
BABY SO I HAD TO QUIT MY CAREER.
HI PORTABLE I HAD I HAD TO PUT
UP AT THE I WOULD HAVE THEM LIKE
CHANGING DIFFERENT DECISIONS
THAT AFFECTED WILL BEING I WILL
COME CALCULATED FROM THREE YEARS
AND I NEVER GOT A CALL FROM
ASKING FOR THREE THINGS TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD ONE EXTENDED
FAMILY UNTIL SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THAT WILL HELP ME TO
PAY FOR THEM AND THAT MONEY CAN
GO TOWARD. OTHER EXPENSIVE
PERSONAL. EXPENSE ESPECIALLY THE
TIME OF THE PLACE IN WHICH WE
LIVE AND TO INCREASE THE
PROVIDER WAITED BY RAISING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. BOTH IN THE
FIELD WHICH IS ALREADY UNDER
FUNDED. FOR THE BIG CONTAINER
FILL FIELD AND THEN. WE GET
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
HAVING THIRTY THOUSAND YOU CHILD
CARE SLOTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES ARE A LONG LONG WAY.
GETTING UP CHILD CARE WHAT YOUR
COULD HAVE BEEN A HUGE CHANGER
ME AND ALLOW ME TO STAY IN THE
WORK FORCE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY TWO. HELLO
CHAIRED MEMBERSHIP MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CRAPPIE REPRESENTING
PARA PLACES CALIFORNIA AND ARE
ELEVEN CHAPTERS ACROSS THE STATE
WE SUPPORT THE ECB COALITION
BUDGET ASK WHICH INCLUDES OUR
SUPPORT BY THIRTY THOUSAND
VOUCHERS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET SO THAT MORE
FAMILIES CAN ACCESS THE CHILD
CARE THEY SO DESPERATELY NEED
SHEEP BELCHER'S MUST BE
ACCOMPANIED WHICH BE LABOR AND
WAGE INCREASES FOR PROVIDERS.
THE NEEDS OF PARENTS AND
PROVIDERS CONTENT AGAINST EACH
OTHER FOR FAR TOO LONG OUR
SYSTEM CRUMBLES IF WE AREN'T
MEETING BOTH OF THEIR NEEDS AT
THE SAME TIME WE MUST HAVE A
MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM TO MEET
THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND PROVIDE. MAXIMUM
CHOICE PREPARING. WE ALSO MANY
THAT HOPING TO CATCH A FLIGHT
TODAY. BUT WILL PROVIDE. HAVE IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE
. NINE FIFTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS ANA ARE YOU COMMUNITIES AND
THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR
HEADSTART CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING
TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
FIFTEEN MILLION IN THE STATE
BUDGET TO SUPPORT HEAD START
TEACHER SALARIES AFTER PROGRAMS
ARE NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED FOR
THEIR HIGH QUALITY WILL CHILD
FAMILY SERVICES BUT HAD FOR
TEACHERS ARE STRUGGLING YOU
HEARD FROM REPRESENTATIVES TODAY
FROM CRITICAL CARE HEAD START
GRANTEE ABOUT THE URGENT NEED TO
INCREASE TEACHER SALARIES.
FUNDING ALLOCATED TO INCREASE
SALARIES AND STATE SUBSIDIZED
PROGRAMS DOES NOT IMPROVE
COMPENSATION FOR FEDERALLY
FUNDED HEAD START TEACHERS WITH
THE COLLAPSE OF THE BUILD BACK
BETTER PROGRAM HAD THIRD DID NOT
EXPECT ANY IMMEDIATE SUPPORT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BEYOND THE COST OF LIVING
INCREASE WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE MEMORY AS FOR HER ADVOCACY
ON OUR BEHALF AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORTS TO THE HEAD
START CLASSROOMS REMAIN OPEN AND
SERVING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN. ACTOR CALIFORNIA WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO INDICATE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FULL BUDGET
REQUEST IN THE EP BUDGET
COALITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. NINE FIFTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PROGRAM A CAR RENTAL LEN
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION COURSE
BEYOND LIFE YOU ALIGN MYSELF ARE
MY COMMENTS WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER AND PEOPLE- WHO
TESTIFIED IN PERSON AND
COMMITTEE AND MODIFIED TO SAY
QUICKLY THAT- YOU KNOW I KNOW I
CAN I HAVE TO TELL YOU MISTER
CHAIR HOW IMPORTANT- EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION FOR CHILDREN BUT
AS WE ALL KNOW AND HAVE SEEN
WITH THE PANDEMIC PROGRAMS ALSO
ENABLE PARENTS TO GO TO WORK. IN
GAME TRAINING AND EDUCATION SO
IN TERMS OF OUR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH TE COMMITTEE TO
OUR CREATE A ROBUST AND DIVERSE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT IS INCLUSIVE OF ALL SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDER TYPE IN ORDER TO
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND THEIR
NEEDS- AND BUILD UPON LAST
YEAR'S EXPANSION IN SCHOOL BASED
SETTING BUT THE COURT THE
BROADER ECC SYSTEM INCLUDING-
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AGAIN WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO PROVIDE OPTIONS.
THAT WORK FOR ALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WEEK YOU'RE PLEASE.
TEN FIFTY SEVEN. FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE
PICK UP YOUR HANDSET. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NOT ENOUGH PASSED THE AND THE
MEMBER AND SELECTED SAN
FRANCISCO. TODAY TO ADD MY VOICE
TO MANY OTHERS AND SHARE MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE ABOUT THE
LACK OF CHILD CARE WHICH WOULD
MEAN HIGHER EDUCATIONAL GOALS I
HAVE WAITED SO LONG FOR MAKING
THE CALLS. I HAVE NO CHOICE NO
CHOICE OTHER THAN TAKING ONE
FROM MY CLASS OF THE TIME I HAVE
SO MUCH IN THE STATE NOT ONLY
BECAUSE MAKE IT TO A CLOSE IN
AGE THAT'S BECAUSE MY SON HAD
REPORTED ME TO THE OTHER WHICH
MAKES IT HARD. WHICH MADE IT
HARD FOR ME TO PROVIDE. HIM WITH
A CAT HE NEEDED OTHER KIND.
FORTY THREE AND MANY OTHERS. I
WOULD ASK YOU FOR MORE. CARE FOR
ALMOST TWO INTELLIGIBLE SHOULD
NUMBER WE WITH. AN EIGHT AND
FIFTY ON WEIGHT AND CONTINUE TO
WAIT FAMILY EATS. AT THE
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FOUR LAST MONTH
WE- INCREASE THE WAGES AND THE-
OF FAMILY AT. CHECKED PROVIDER
AS WELL AS THE FEATURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE BEEN SIX LINE. SIXTY YOUR
NUMBERS TO BE CARED CALL WITH
NEAREST CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON
FUNDING FOR THE CHILDREN'S
HEALTH CARE PROGRAM. SHE
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET TO
RESTORE THE STATE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT IT GIPHY AND THIS
YEAR NURSE CALIFORNIA AND- THE
ROUNDTABLE HERBS THE LEGISLATURE
TO GO FURTHER BY ENABLING ALL
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS TO QUALIFY
FOR REIMBURSEMENT EQUIVALENT TO
THE HIGHEST FEDERAL RATE FOR
MEALS SERVED. IN THE- CALIFORNIA
RESORT THE FIRST IN THE NATION
CONNECT CREAMY. ALL KEEP TWELVE
IT. NOW TIME TO A SIMILAR
INVESTMENT OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS
. WITH AN INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY
MILLION ANNUALLY AND ONE TIME
SUPPORT FOR START UP GRANT. YOU
CAN FILL THE GAP AND EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HEALTHY MEAL THE CHILD
CARE WELCOME FOURTEEN THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF THE CHILD
CARE WORKFORCE. WELCOME TO FOR
THE FULL EASY BUDGET REQUEST IN
THE COOPER TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE TO ENSURE OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS RECEIVE THE
NUTRITION YOU NEED TO DRIVE. AND
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ARE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER PLEASE. ONE SIXTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A FOR
LEON AND I AM COMPARED WITH THE
CURRENT. I'M HERE THREE I'M
CALLING FOR THE GOVERNMENT. I'M
IN SHOCK. THEY'RE CURRENTLY OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND PANELS ON THE
WAITER MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR YOU I WAS ONE OF
THOSE PARENTS NEVER THOUGHT I
HAD TO PUT MY COLLEGE EDUCATION
UNFOLD I THINK HOME SECURE FILE.
I WOULD HAVE HAD SHALL HERE I
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO COMPLETE
MY DEGREE HELP SUPPORT MY FAMILY
AND HELP MY COMMUNITY THROUGH MY
DREAM JOB. YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
MAKE ARGUE EDUCATIONAL. OR WORK
BOTH. I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
EXPAND THE THIRD THIRTY. BAHT
SHALL HEAR HOW. WORKING. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE FORTY FOOT
. BY. FORTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR- GOOD AFTERNOON IT
IS NOW CARE ACT OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER GIVE
A COUPLE OF CONCERNS ARE RELATED
TO T. K. FIRST OFFICE THE LACK
OF FACILITIES FUNDING THIS IS
ESPECIALLY ACUTE FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHO HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM THAT HOLD A- PRE K. FOR
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN GRANT
PROGRAM AND IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
WILL BE ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES AND
OTHER THAN THAT THERE ARE NO-
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES FUNDING
SOURCES FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE. ACROSS THE BOARD
SECOND WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
PENDING MANDATE TO HAVE TWENTY
FOUR UNITS OF ECT ARE SIMILAR
CREDIT FOR PK TEACHERS WE THINK
THIS IS KIND OF GILDING THE LILY
AND SORT OF EXCESSIVE AND THAT
IT SHOULD BE DELETED OR TURNED
INTO AN EITHER OR REQUIREMENT
FINALLY ON LONG TERM WE REALLY
BELIEVE THE STATE SHOULD MERGE
THE ATK PRESCHOOL CHILD CARE AND
OTHER PRE K. PROGRAMS THAT THE
STATE FUNDS INTO A SINGLE MORE
COHERENT PROGRAMS- THAT GIVES
PARENTS. COMPLETE FLEXIBILITY OF
CHOICE AND THAT THAT WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO STRETCH IT DOLLARS
TO SERVE A MUCH BROADER CROSS
SECTION. OF THE POPULATION IT'S
INCLUDE FOR YOUR AS WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BY
SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS ON BEHALF BECOME
ALTERNATIVE PROGRAM. WITHIN OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE EASY COALITION
BUT YOUR QUESTION ALSO INFORMING
THE COMMITTEE OF AN ISSUE THAT
HAS YET TO BE ADDRESSED IN OTHER
DURING THE PANDEMIC ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS WERE GIVEN THE
FLEXIBILITY TO EXPEDITE THE
ROMANCE OF THE CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND CHILD CARE
ABOUT THEIR PARENTS COULD SERVE
ON THE FRONT LINES A POLICY
WE'RE VERY THANKFUL FOR BUT WILL
SUNSET ON JUNE THIRTY THIS YEAR
WHILE MANY OF THOSE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ARE STILL INCOME
ELIGIBLE TO REMAIN. SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE AND ROLLING THEM IN
THE PROCESS THAT CAN TAKE UP TO
ONE TO THREE MONTHS LEADING OUR
AGENCIES WERE ALREADY SHORT
STAFFED AND RUNNING ON VERY THIN
MARGINS WITH ANOTHER NEW
UNFUNDED WORKLOAD AND THEN
GROWING THESE FAMILIES INTO
STABLE TOP SPOT WHILE ALSO
HAVING TO RETURN THOSE MUCH
NEEDED ESSENTIAL WORKER FUNDS
BACK TO THE STATE WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERED IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO ALLOW AN EXPANDED
COVERT NINETEEN ESSENTIAL WORKER
FUNDS WITH OUR AGENCIES AND ROLL
OVER INTO THE COP CONTRACT. SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
FAMILIES AN ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THAT ARE DURING THE. DEPTHS OF
THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BAKER PLEASE. NINE SIX
THREE. GOOD MORNING BY
INTERVIEWING GUYS THE TRUCK CARE
RESOURCE CENTER AT THE LARGEST
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
NONPROFIT IN CALIFORNIA IF
YOU'RE A FELINE BURKE COMMENTS
WITH THE EASY COALITION
INCLUDING INCREASING
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
PROVIDERS AND WEEPING CHILD CARE
FAMILY FEES SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR IN ADDITION TO THE
APPOINT AN ACTING A UNIVERSAL
CRITICAL SYSTEM BUT IT'S
INCLUSIVE OF ALL SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS IN OUR
MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF ON ITS
DIVERSITY OF PEOPLE LANGUAGES
AND TRAIN WHICH IS WHY WE NEED A
ROBUST UNIVERSAL CRITICISM WITH
DIAPERS OPTIONS. FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THANK YOU
. SURE THAT IS NINETY LINES THE
- THIS IS FOR THE NINETEEN. SIX
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WILL
ADJOURN.